gatsby is an open source website
generator you're about to learn all
about it from john smilga
john is one of the most viewed teachers
on our entire channel what's up
everybody and welcome to gatsby version
3 tutorial video
so a few weeks back we as we rolled out
its latest version
version number three and as with all the
new versions there are some major
changes so it only made sense to record
a new gatsby video during the video
we'll cover such things as
file system route api
new syntax for css modules and of course
new plugin to handle images in gatsby as
with all my videos in order to make
things a little bit more interesting
we'll utilize our knowledge by building
a cool project a recipe site
if you'd like to take a project out for
a test drive just visit the url
gatsby version 3 tutorial
recipes dot notify that app
again the url is get b version 3
tutorial recipes dot netify that app and
lastly this video is first part of my
gatsby course where we build more cool
projects with gadbjs alright and welcome
to the course and i guess let's start
our journey by answering the most basic
and yet pressing question first
well
what is get bgs
and most likely the explanation you have
heard is this one
gatsby is a static site generator
and while it's true at the end of the
day gatsby does generate a static site
at this point in time gatsby just is far
more closer to a full-blown framework
than to just another static site
generator
gatsby is built on top of react so if
you do enjoy the amazing dev experience
that comes with react
so think things like components
modularity and etc you will feel right
at home when using gatsby
now that experience is of course nice
but what about the final product what is
so special about gatsby you see once
we're done with our project gatsby will
do its magic and without doing any extra
work we'll get things like code
splitting fast page loads
image optimization data prefetching and
i can go on and on and on since the list
of the benefits we get straight out of
the box is extremely long
what's also cool is that the static
content gatsby generates can then be
enhanced with client-side javascript
with the help of react hydration and
even though it's a muscle it simply
means that we get best of both worlds
not only our gatsby set can have
app-like features
so think traditional react app but it's
also super fast and optimized sounds
pretty cool right so keep watching the
course and i can guarantee you that
you'll be extremely happy with what
gatsby has to offer as far as the course
structure in the first module so the
module you're currently watching you'll
find a useful info about the course
in the second module
you'll find extensive gatsby tutorial
and after that every module contains a
unique project where we test out
different content providers as well as
advanced gas b features lastly let me
just mention that in order to make the
knowledge thick
and also in the process make things a
little bit more interesting during the
second module so the gatsby tutorial one
will also build a cool project a simply
recipes project where we create a nifty
recipe site when it comes to course
requirements my expectation is that you
are at least familiar with react basics
so things like components and props
have some experience with modern
javascript
so es6 and up specifically array methods
like map filter and reduce
as well as the structuring and spread
operator
and while you can still follow along
with a course
even if you have very little experience
with react and modern javascript in some
cases you might need to utilize some
external resources since i want to keep
gatsby as the main focus of this course
and therefore my plan is to cover
extensively
only the gatsby related topics
if you are struggling to find a good
place for resources i'm going to be bias
and suggest my own youtube channel
called coding addict where you'll find
lots of useful react vanilla javascript
node css and html content specifically
look for javascript nugget series where
i cover most asked course questions
in isolation and great detail as far as
the dev setup
since gatsby is an old app and will
install quite a few dependencies you'll
need a node on your machine
and when it comes to my text editor and
browser i prefer visual studio code and
chrome but of course they're not
mandatory and lastly all of the services
i suggest during the course have a free
generous tier
so you can leave your credit card where
it belongs
nicely tucked away in your wallet like i
mentioned previously for development i
prefer visual studio code
or vs code for short which at this point
is probably the most popular option out
there
and since i do a lot of recording i keep
my setup very close to the default one
with some exceptions like font size and
zoom level throughout the course just to
speed things up and avoid a necessary
boilerplate i will use few extensions
but i'll cover them later just so you
get a better understanding of the
benefits
now if you are interested in my overall
setup
just navigate to my github profile
john milga
and look for the repo vs code setup
and there you'll find all the extensions
i use as well as my settings json file
with all my config options
all right and welcome to our first
module gatsby tutorial module
and like i already mentioned previously
in order to make things more interesting
during the module we'll also build our
first project
simply a recipe site if you want to see
project in action or maybe you're
interested in complete source code like
always the fastest way is probably by
navigating to
johnsmilk.com so hit the url
johnsmilk.com
then
look for the project page
and then in the projects page
more specifically look for the gatsby
ones
in here you'll find all the course
project
and you're looking for the recipe site
if you click on this link
you'll see the project in action and
then if you want to access the source
code look for star files
or source code in this case they both
point to the same repo
and in here you'll find complete source
code for the project lastly since i find
gatsby documentation extremely helpful
in order to support my argument and
showcase where you can get more info in
future
i will reference gatsbyside somewhat
often especially during gatsby tutorial
part and the url is getbjs.com
again the url
for gatsbyside is
getbjs.com
nice and let's kick things off by
installing a gas bcli package which is a
tool that will allow us to quickly
generate gatsby projects and if you're
familiar with create react app the idea
is exactly the same
instead of spending our precious time on
config and setup we'll be able to spin
up a gatsby project with the help of one
command
they do suggest installing globally so
in mac don't forget to add sudo
and once i'm done with my install i'll
share a great resource if you do hit
some roadblocks or just need more info
on the whole setup so i'm going to
navigate back to my terminal
and i'll massively zoom in
the command is sudo since again we're
installing this globally
then we go with npm i dash g
and the package name is gatsby
cli
and i'll be prompted my password
and once i enter the password of course
i kick off the install it looks like
everything went great
i don't see any errors
so i should have the package now if you
do want to double check
just type gatsby
and then hyphen hyphen version
and if you see gatsby version 3 e in
terminal you are in good shape however
if the terminal spits back
that no such command is found then of
course you haven't installed the package
and you'll have to troubleshoot now if
you get stuck or just need more info
i suggest navigating to the gatsby docs
then look for tutorial
then click on this link and here they go
over how to set up your dev environment
where they cover how to install node on
your particular machine
set up git if you haven't already and
that sort of thing so if you do hit some
roadblocks i strongly suggest using this
resource for guidance
and once we have the gas bcli at our
disposal let's take it out for a spin
and the command for the new gasb project
is following
gatsby new than the project name
followed by the starter
project name of course is totally up to
you
and as far as the starter it's a url to
the github repo
and just like the name suggests star
provides some default setup now if you
omit this star url altogether it will
automatically use the default starter
and don't get me wrong there's nothing
wrong with default starter and in most
cases that's exactly what you'll use but
since it comes with few bells and
whistles
for our first project we're going to use
a hello world starter which essentially
is bare bones gatsby app why i went this
route because i think is going to be
more beneficial
if we add those bells and whistles
together since that way at least in my
opinion you'll have a better
understanding of the whole setup lastly
in order to spin up the dev server the
command you're looking for is gadsby
develop so let's do this people
i'm going to navigate back to my desktop
i will zoom in and first i'll navigate
to desktop
you can set it up your project whatever
you like but i always prefer desktop so
i'm going to go with cd and nest up and
then of course we just want to go with
command so gatsby new as far as tutorial
name not going to be particularly
original and i'm just going to go with
tutorial and at this point we can either
type out the url
or we can simply navigate to gatsby docs
and then we're looking for the starters
now technically they're under the
features but you're not going to find
them
under this features link at least at the
time of this recording so instead keep
scrolling scrolling scrolling scrolling
and then all the way in the bottom
you'll find the stars and then by
default they'll set it up as version two
again at the time of this recording
eventually things might change
so instead we're looking for
version three
and then this is going to be the default
one so basically the one that you're
going to get
if you omit the url altogether
and then the one that we're looking for
is hello world so notice here the search
box we can simply search for it here
now the idea for all of them is pretty
much the same
where if you're building some project
and if you know that you'll need a
specific config for example the strappy
one or the shopify one or whatever
you right away can get a star project
with a bunch of things pre-configured
and since they're github repos you can
simply
of course navigate and take a look at
the source code and see what the starter
is all about so essentially what are you
getting now in our case like i said
we're looking for hello world
hello world
and then i'm just going to click on a
link and we can visit the demo set and
all that
but i'm looking for this command now in
my case i'm not going to copy the whole
thing
because i only need the url
since as you can see here they go with
this name and i already have my tutorial
so take the url part
then navigate back of course and then
copy and paste and once you do that
that's bcli is going to start
bootstrapping our project and at this
point you have two options you can run
the gatsby develop from the terminal
or you can run it from the visual studio
code because visual studio code also has
the integrated terminal and in my case
i'm going to go with second option
so i'll close my terminal
then i'll open up my visual studio code
drag and drop the project
in the following video i'll go over the
general structure of the gatsby project
for now i just want to quickly get
something on the screen and therefore
i'll open up the integrated terminal and
that's a virtual studio code thing where
effectively they have the terminal that
is right away pointing to our project to
my tutorial in this case
and then i simply want to go with gadsby
develop so that's the command that spins
up the dev server and it is always my
preference to work side by side with a
browser so effectively i'll make this
smaller again this is not a gatsby thing
this is actually a mac thing where i go
with new window
so new browser window
and i just set them side by side
with my text editor
and then i'll also open up a new tab
on a bigger browser window so i'm going
to go with localhost and we're looking
for
8000 and if you see hello world on the
screen
you are in good shape so i'll set them
side by side here this is going to be
our complete project and that's the
project we're working on and then for
time being i'll just close these two
tabs and then i'll do the same thing
here we're on a smaller browser window
i'm gonna go with localhost 8000 and
again if you see hello world on a screen
that means that everything is correct
and you can proceed to the next video
beautiful and as far as the typical
gatsby project structure
we have cache folder
where gatsby stores the cache
then we have node modules since at the
end of the day it is a node app so
basically this is where we keep all our
dependencies and i honestly i don't see
any reasons why you need to go here and
do any modifications while you're
setting up your project
then we have a public one so this is
where our production ready project
lives and i'll cover it in more detail
when we take a look at the different
commands we have then we have source
and more specifically pages so we have
source directory with a pages directory
and since we'll spend most of our time
in the source folder i'll just leave it
at that there's really no point for me
to repeat myself
then we have a static folder where we
can set up assets that are going to be
publicly available
as well as we can access it in our
project
however i'll talk about the gotcha in a
second so don't start placing all your
images right from the get-go in a static
one then we have git ignore
which is just a file for search control
so in this file we specifically say
which files or directories are going to
be ignored once we push this project up
to github for example then we have
prettier ignore and pre-drc which are
just used for the package that gatsby
comes with and the package name is prior
then we have gadsby config so this is
where we'll set up all our configuration
for our site
things like plugin site info and all
that good stuff license pretty
self-explanatory package log json and
package.json so package lock is used for
the dependencies of the dependencies we
know that in node map once we install
dependency it possibly can have
dependency on its own so package log
just make sure that we can get the
correct versions of the dependency
dependencies and then of course we have
a package.json where we have our
dependencies and let's not forget readme
the markdown file where we can find
useful information about our project
and i guess let's start by exploring the
package.json
as you can see
we don't have that many packages if we
keep on scrolling we have dependencies
of course gatsby react as well as react
dom and then for development they use
this prettier package
and actually you can run a command
and the command is format and it will
format the project for you
now my preference is using this
extension instead
so let me go to my extensions
and i actually prefer using the
extension by the name of preview
and effectively the difference is that
it runs automatically so once you
install this package and make sure you
add this configuration to your settings
json that's definitely a must with the
later versions of vs code
if you won't do that it's not going to
work and then the moment you do that you
don't need to run the command because in
this case notice the package json
effectively if we want to run the
formatter we need to run this command
correct but once you install this
extension and once you set up the proper
configuration in settings json it will
automatically happen once you save or
once you copy and paste whatever setup
you choose and you can control that in
two places you can either use the gui so
first navigate to the settings and this
is going to be the graphical interface
and just type format
and in my case i use format on paste and
format on save
or
of course you can do it directly in
settings json i have editor format on
paste and format on save so those are
the options i use but of course you can
modify them to whatever makes most sense
to you
then
as you can see we have more commands we
have one for start one for serve clean
and we also have one for build remember
when we talked about the public on i
said that this is where our production
ready project is going to live
and in order to set it up we need to run
gadsby build so let's try it out first
in order to stop the dev server we
simply need to go with control c
then i'll clear the terminal so i'll
just type clear and then we run gatsby
and then build
so this will do all that gadsby magic
now there's also another option
later once we host our project actually
we'll set up our hosting provider to do
the build process for us but it doesn't
change the main idea where eventually
there is a public folder with our
project ready to go with all the guest
bigqueries so this is where we have all
our image optimizations all the
prefetching and all that cool stuff and
if you take a look at the result
you'll notice that it's just a bunch of
static files and again this is the key
thing about the gatsby where once we're
done building our site once our project
is ready to go we just ship it as bunch
of static assets so there is no back and
forth with a server we just send our
project over the wire it is extremely
fast because it's just a bunch of static
assets and once it arrives there then of
course it does the whole rehydration
thing and user gets this nice react
experience
that should do it for the public folder
and next i want to talk about the static
one
remember i just said that whatever asset
will place here will be publicly
available and you'll see how gatsby will
nicely transport that asset to the
public one now here's the key gotcha
just because you can does not mean that
you should
so imagine this scenario on my desktop i
have this cute image of these two
puppies i can simply open up my tutorial
and then drag and drop into my static
one and currently in my static one you
can see that we have a favicon and if
you're not familiar with favicon it's
just this icon in the browser tab
and once i spin up my dev server again
the command is
gatsby develop or notice how they also
have this start script and if you have
worked with create react app you know
that they also have this npm start which
just spins up the create react app so
this is similar where i can run either a
gatsby develop myself
or i can run npm start and in turn that
will run the same command
so i'll go with npm start just to
showcase
that it works
and once my server is up and running
i'll be able to see the cute jpeg in two
places i'll be able to see that once i
navigate to a localhost 8000 and then
more specifically
let me zoom in
i'm gonna go with forward slash and cute
jpeg
and yep i have my puppies and i can also
do that in my project now don't freak
out again there's going to be a proper
introduction for the source one but
since i want to get something on the
screen i'm just going to navigate to the
index.js in the pages
and then above the hello world just for
the time being i'll showcase that we can
access it here as well
and i'm gonna omit the alt attribute and
then once i save and then once i refresh
of course i have my cute image now just
because you can does not mean that you
should if you read the gatsby
documentation they actually are trying
to discourage you from this kind of
pattern because if you add your assets
in such a way where you just dump them
into a static folder essentially you're
not using any of the nice optimizations
that gatsby provides
so the whole point of using gatsby
is because of all the magic that it does
behind the scenes in this case you're
just adding it to a static one and then
you make it publicly available and if
you want to see that take a look at the
public one and you'll see the cute jpeg
so my whole point is following where be
mindful of what you place in a static
one just because you can does not mean
you should and of course all the
following videos i'll show you a proper
way how we can add assets and in turn
we'll use all the awesome gadsby goodies
so i'll remove the image for now
and i'll also remove it from my static
one
okay
and then let me just go back to the
package.json and let's complete our list
of commands so we covered build this is
production ready project we have also
covered develop we have covered format
as well as start and then we have serve
clean and test now there's not much to
say about the test but as far as serve
and gatsby clean
so with serve
we will serve our project locally so our
production ready project we can take a
look at how it looks locally because
keep in mind that as far as our current
setup we are looking at our development
project once we're done running gadsby
build and that's a must because you
cannot have serve without the public
folder
then go with gatsby and then serve
and then of course you'll be able to see
the project at this point there's not
much to see this is pretty much the same
project but if i go to a localhost and
9000 so that's going to be my production
ready project and then eventually we
have this one the gatsby clean and this
is super super super useful
once you start working with images
because once in a while
you'll hit the glitch where
the image gets stuck in a cache and once
you run gadsby clean
you'll notice something pretty cool
where if i go with gads be clean it will
tell me that the cache folder as well as
the public one has been deleted and
throughout the course you'll see me run
this command again it's super super
super useful once you start working with
images so imagine the scenario
you
add an image then
i don't know a minute later you decide
to change a path and even though your
code did not change
the image actually changed
and then you are trying to spin up the
dev server and you're getting this weird
bug now the bug is not because there's
something wrong with your code nabaga is
there because gatsby is still looking
for the older image again something to
keep in mind and lastly let me just
mention something about this whole dev
setup
in the gatsby docs they mention
that as far as the dev server it uses
the hot reloading what that means well
that simply means that once i spin up my
server so npm
start again
and if i go to the pages and index.js
again
don't worry i will give it a proper
introduction for time being i just want
to showcase how the hot reloading works
and if i go here and if i change this
text to
hello people
once i save
the changes should automatically take
place in the browser now in my case the
dev server is still spinning up but the
idea is following where the moment you
save
you should see the changes in the
browser now notice i use the word should
because in reality as far as my
experience whether that was version two
or with a version three
you'll still have to refresh now doesn't
mean that you'll have to refresh each
and every time there are times when
everything is going to work so if i'll
go back to the hello world and if i'll
save notice how in this case it updated
everything nicely just don't be
surprised where not only you need to
save the file but you also need to
refresh and also in gatsby version 3
they added this error model
and the best way for me to showcase is
by removing this div so notice if i
navigate to a bigger browser window of
course and as a signal i'm looking at
9000 should be looking for 8 000 you'll
see this helpful modal that explicitly
says where is the error now again this
is something that might pop up even if
there is no error now i'm not saying
that it's going to happen each and every
time there's going to be times when it's
very useful so for example in this case
it points directly where is my error but
yes once you start dealing with images
and all that
it might pop up once in a while where
there is no need and if that is the case
simply start by refreshing the browser
and if of course it doesn't go away
which in this case there is clearly an
error so it's not going to go away but
if it's there by mistake then you'll see
how it disappears and of course
throughout the course we'll probably hit
those bugs so that's when you'll see
that in action that should do it for the
overall setup and now we can start
working in our source directory where
like i just mentioned we'll do most of
our work
not bad not bad i think we have good
initial understanding of typical gatsby
project structure
so now let's get our hands dirty and
finally write some code and while there
are many things i like about gatsby the
two that i like the most are following i
find gatsby set up extremely
straightforward and since it's built on
top of react trust me if you have done
any work with react you'll instantly
feel at home since a lot of things are
very similar to typical react project
case in point if you take a look at the
source folder you can see that there is
a pages directory
now million-dollar question
what do you think we're going to do in
the pages directory
and if you answered well we'll be
setting up pages for a project you're
100
correct
so the only thing we need to do
in order to create a page in gatsby is
just navigate to source folder then
pages directory and then just create a
file so simple javascript file so if
you'll call this about.js then you'll
have about page if you'll call this
product js then you'll have a product
page and hopefully you get the gist so
that's the straightforward part now what
about familiarity well if you take a
look at the content in the index.js what
do you see over there
and
as far as what i see when i'm looking at
it i see a react component and
effectively in order to create a page we
just need to set up a area component now
that could be class-based component
even though i highly doubt you'll create
one because with arrival of hooks pretty
much the common convention is setting up
functional components but yes you can do
that or you can go with functional
component which is something we're going
to do throughout the course so as you
can see we just import react and then we
export our component now one gotcha is
that this export has to be default and
i'll show you what happens if we don't
do that but
as far as the setup it is straight up
react component again this could be a
regular function when you're setting up
functional component or this could be a
arrow function and don't worry we'll
cover both of those cases in a second
and then whatever we return
well that is displayed on screen so if
i'll change this of course around
and if i'll say that there's going to be
a heading 1 instead of a div
and we'll say hello
and then
people
if everything is correct
we should see a hello people on a screen
and what do you know now of course we
have hello people and just to give you a
visual representation this is going to
be the project we're going to be working
on
during the tutorial and of course it has
multiple pages it has recipes page it
has tags page about page as well as
contact page how do we create them we
simply go to
pages directory and just create files
now i'm not going to set up all the
files in this video but
in order to get some practice i will
navigate to the pages and in here i just
need to say new file now we have
multiple options in visual studio code
if you want to use the icons here on top
you can do that as well in my case i
just used a right click and i'm just
going to create a simple about js page
so i create a page and this is where i
need to set up my component now in order
to speed this up
i actually use this extension so let me
make my extensions bigger
and let's see let's see we have this one
the es7 react redux and blah blah blah
so i'm not going to read the whole thing
but basically you get these snippets so
if you take a look at the extension so
now of course i just need to make this
one smaller you'll see a bunch of
snippets that they provide and
effectively it just saves you time on
typing out the boilerplate now the ones
that we're going to use the most are for
setting up the components so keep on
scrolling keep on scrolling eventually
you'll hit the r
so this is going to be for setting up d
components so rcc is going to be for
class-based component and pretty much
i'm just going to show you one example
because like i said throughout the
course we'll use the functional
components instead
and then
the snippet for that is let's keep on
scrolling so we have rcc and then we
have the functional component one now
keep in mind that we right away want to
export as default and that is extremely
important so again if you want to find
more info just look for the extension
and i highly suggest installing because
throughout the course i will use this
extension to save some time on setting
up the boilerplate
so let me close this one and again we
can go with r and then they're going to
give us suggestions so notice once i
type r a this is going to be for the
arrow function and i right away want to
go for the r a f c e so this is going to
set up a component and right away export
it as default and as you can see it
right away takes the name of the file so
since i named my file about jazz set up
a component with the same name and
exported as default so let's write here
hello from about page or you can simply
type about page and for now we haven't
set up the navbar yet don't worry we'll
do that in a second but if you navigate
to url bar and if you type about there
you go now of course we have hello from
the about page and just to get a bit
more practice why don't we create one
more page so say new file in this case
let me show you that of course we can do
it from the visual studio code gui as
well notice this is the new file option
let's click here and i'll call this one
contact page again if we want to set it
up as class based component we can
definitely do so and the snippet for
that is rcc notice how we're setting up
class-based component again with the
arrival of hooks i don't know why you'd
want to do that but it is definitely an
option and it's going to work so i'll
say
contact page once i save again i just
need to navigate
in my url bar for now so say contact
so i do have the contact page that works
and another option we have is setting up
functional component but not as a arrow
function like we were doing in the about
we can simply set it up with good old
function keyword and the snippet for
that is r
f c and i just need to click now i have
my function which is contact so i'll say
testing contact
let's save it and if everything is
correct i should see testing contact on
the screen so in this case i'll have to
refresh now i have the testing one now
just to showcase what happens if you
don't set it up as default why don't i
create a testing page so i'm going to
navigate to pages i'll say testing.js
and in this case i'm going to go with
functional one but i'll omit the e at
the end for my snippet so simply go with
a arrow function and as you can see i'm
not exporting as default so right here
fail
and then once i save
i'm gonna navigate in my url bar to the
testing one and then once you navigate
there we have our big fat error and the
reason why we have this error
because every time you set up a page you
need to export it as default so the
named exports are not going to work and
at this point we have multiple options
either
you can just refactor it to the export
default here in the bottom or you can go
to the testing one and say export
default and then of course we can just
omit all of this stuff so we don't need
to come up with a name and now of course
it's not gonna fail so say
testing here
and once i save it and then once i
refresh
there it is i have my testing one so two
things to keep in mind always export it
as default and in order to save some
time
i suggest using this awesome extension
because it nicely takes care of all the
annoying boilerplate nice work at this
point i think we are experts on how to
set up pages in gatsby but while we're
still on the topic let me mention two
more things and the first one is going
to be 404 page so imagine the scenario
the user visits your project and then
for some reason he or she is looking for
a resource that doesn't exist so in this
case i'm going to be looking for the
company page but that page doesn't exist
in my project and what we're going to do
we're going to display a nice error
message and then possibly you can add
the link whatever you'd want so
essentially you are setting up the page
which you're going to display if the
user cannot find the resource and just
to give you another example for example
if you take a look at the gatsby
documentation and if you go for the
error page notice this is what they're
displaying as far as their page and
notice how we can nicely navigate back
to the homepage and the way you set that
page in gatsby
is following so again in the pages
directory however the name in this case
is important if previously
you could just set up whatever names you
want over here just keep in mind that
they will show up in the url when the
user is trying to access that resource
when it comes to 404 when it comes to
the error page
the file name is important and we go
with 404 and js
now the one gotcha with the snippets
that i showed you in last video is the
fact that they right away create a
component with the same name as the file
name now the problem of course is that
in react or more specifically in
javascript we cannot name functions
with numbers correct so this is going to
be the case where i need to rename it
i'm going to go with error and also
export as error and for the time being
will simply go with arrow page again
this is a standard page so we can set up
whatever functionality we want over here
and
in order to test it i'm just going to go
to a testing and then maybe info now of
course we don't have that resource so in
development we'll see this page first so
this is going to be displayed first and
then of course we can click on preview
on custom page don't worry
once we deploy our project this screen
won't appear and if i click preview now
of course i have my aero page hopefully
that is clear that's how we set up arrow
pages in gatsby beautiful and while
we're still on a topic of pages i also
want to show you how to set up nested
pages in gatsby now what am i talking
about well if you navigate to the gatsby
site and then hover over the docs link
notice how you have these options
correct and then if you click on for
example how to guides check out the url
so the url is the domain yes bjs.com
then we have docs and then more
specifically how to
and the way we set up this type of
structure
in the pages we just need to create
a folder so again keep in mind whatever
you're going to name your folder will
show up in the url
so if you'll call the second back
in the url you'll have to type the
domain in our case localhost 8000 then
shaken back and then whatever the page
name so in here i'm going to go with new
folder and then i'll just call this
company
company
and then whatever file i'm going to
create in the company again is going to
be displayed in the url but in the url
i'll have to have the forward slash
company as well
so if i create a new file
and i'll call this history
and js
and of course we create a component we
already know how to do that we have
history one and we'll say this is
history of our
company
now of course in order to get there i
need to go with company so i need to say
forward slash company and then the
history one so let me zoom out a little
bit and i'll say history so now of
course we're going to navigate this
specific page so again we can set up
whatever pages you want here so i just
need to come up with the file name and
then set up my component just remember
that the url will contain the folder
name in this case company
and lastly i just want to mention notice
how in the pages we actually have
index.js
now index.js always signals
a root
and of course when we talk about pages
that means that it is going to be our
homepage so once the user navigates to
your domain again in our case localhost
8000
whatever you set up in the index that is
going to be the home page now why am i
telling you that because at the moment
notice how company folder does not does
not have index.js and what that means if
someone just navigates to forward slash
company well there's no page for that
so of course now we'll display the error
page now there is a page for the history
so of course we can navigate to company
forward slash history we just saw that
but there is no page for the company so
if at any point you do want to create
that page for the company simply create
a new file in the company folder
and just call it index js so this always
signals root now in the pages that root
is our domain and in the company of
course that is going to be forward slash
company so again i'm going to go with my
component and i'm just going to say
hello
from
company
and of course we don't have the error
and we can clearly see hello from
company
that should do it for setting up pages
in gatsby and now let's take a look how
we can navigate from page to page using
gatsbylink component not bad not bad i
think we are comfortable with setting up
pages in nasbi now let's take a look how
we can navigate from page to page using
a link component
instead of the url bar because yes
technically i can force
my users to do that but you would
probably agree that that's not the best
user experience and if you have done any
work with react router dom setup is
gonna feel extremely familiar because
under the hood gatsby uses reach router
which in fact is built by the same
people who built a react router dom and
the way we set it up we just need to
import link component from gatsby and
i'm gonna do that in my homepage just
keep in mind you can do it in any of the
pages and then again this is a named
import so we need to specifically say a
link and this is coming from the gatsby
now the problem at the moment is that i
have my component but i'm returning just
heading 1 and we know that in react
in fact we can return only one thing so
if i want to set my link side by side
then of course i just need to set up a
parent div and then right after the
heading one i'm gonna go with link and
then this is a component and it's
looking forward to prop so in this to
prop we just specifically say
where we're going to navigate
so if i want to navigate to about page
i simply go with forward slash and then
the about so if i want to navigate to a
company and then history you get to just
you just need to type forward slash
company and then the history so i'm just
gonna add about and then whatever text
you place inside of the link of course
is gonna be displayed on screen and
since we're navigating to about page we
might as well set up a text as about and
once i save my index.js and
if i click on my about link
check it out now of course we can
navigate to about page and notice this
awesome react experience where
essentially we're not doing the full
page reload and again if you're
interested you can take a look at the
source so in this case i just need to
refresh
and you'll see that at the end of the
day yes it is a link so for example that
is important when you set up styling
you're still looking for the link
element however again under the hood
gatsby does all this magic where
essentially we have a react app and with
that said please keep something in mind
where we can use still traditional links
and we do need to use them when we're
setting up a link to external resources
so these link components are intended
for navigating around your project
not to the external resource as a side
note i'll place this one in the div
just so they are in separate lines so
create my div and then i'll just set up
regular html link element and as far as
the ahref let me try one more time to
about and i'll say regular
link and you'll see this full page
refresh
and again in this case i just need to
navigate back to the home page and
refresh notice this is going to be this
regular link and notice the difference
of course in this case i just navigate
and there is no page refresh however if
i press on the regular link check it out
we have this refresh so the idea is that
when you set up links around your
project you don't want to use the
regular html element however when you're
setting up a external link yes you do
need to use it so if we set up a link
back to the gatsby docs and i'll use
this full url here then of course i go
with link i can copy and paste and then
i'll say i don't know
gatsby docs and once i set up my link i
just need to navigate
back to the home page so let me see
i'm going to go back to my route and
then click on gatsby docs
so this works nicely where we use the
regular
link element and we can just navigate to
the external resource but around our
project we're going to use the link
complement
now to hammer this home
i'll add one more link
and i'll just show you how to navigate
to company and history so we have a link
remember the path we need to go with
folder name in this case company and
then whatever is the file name so we're
gonna go with history and here i'll
simply say history
and once i have my link in place i
simply need to click on the link in the
browser and there it is now we nicely
navigate to company history page now
you're probably wondering okay but why
are we always navigating back using the
browser can we set up the link and of
course the answer is yes so in this case
i'll simply copy and paste and i'm not
going to set up links in every page
because like i keep mentioning
eventually we will make a navbar so for
time being i'm just going to go to the
history one import my link i already
have the div here so why don't i wrap
my text in the heading two
the one that i currently have in here
and set up one more link back to the
home page just to showcase how is that
gonna look like so in this case i just
need to use forward slash that's how we
can navigate back to the home page and
of course whatever text so in here i'll
say homepage so now of course let's test
it out i'm going to go to my history
page
and then in this case i do need to
refresh and just like that i have my
home page so once i click i nicely
navigate back to the homepage so whether
you just have
one pages directory with simple pages or
you have a nested setup where you have
nested pages the navigation is exactly
the same you just go with a forward
slash and then whatever is the path so
if you want to navigate to about you go
with word slash about if you want to go
to history which is inside of the folder
then you go with the folder name and
then whatever is the file language of
course in our case is history excellent
once our project has awesome routing
let's take it a step further and add the
navbar
now i must warn you though there are
going to be few iterations of navbar so
don't be upset if after this video our
nav does not look exactly like in the
complete project however
this is our goal so eventually we want
to have a nav like this so this is the
look on a big screen and then if we make
this smaller
notice we'll have a nice button
that can toggle the links as well
and
our most basic setup
could look like this we're back in the
index.js since i have a div and you're
not at this point i'm going to close the
terminal just so i have a bit more real
estate in here and inside of a div let's
just say nav and then i can have one
link to the home page and then the
second one to the about page like i said
there's going to be a few iterations
we're going to say to home so that's
going to be our home and i'm not going
to add the page text here and let's say
to about we're just gonna go with about
let's save that one now of course i have
a nice looking nav where i have the home
as well as the about links now the
problem of course with this setup is the
fact that if i want to add this nav to
all my pages as you can see i'll have to
copy and paste
and since we know that our pages are
react components in react we can
actually nest another component
inside of the component correct so we
can obviously do that in gas b as well
so let's try it out
and the way we're going to do that is in
source we're going to create another
folder
now
you can name this folder however you
would please
just keep in mind that common convention
is naming it components so in this case
i need to go to the source and i need to
go with new folder just make sure that
you don't place it inside of the pages
again the goal is to place it inside of
the source and like i said common
convention is calling this components
and then of course
we can be rebels and come up with
whatever component name we would like
and in my case i'm going to call this
surprise surprise navbar
js and then i'm going to set up my good
old regular component and again my
preference is always
using the arrow function syntax so
therefore throughout the course this is
the syntax that you'll most likely see
but if you prefer different setup
i believe i covered those options in the
previous videos and as far as this
component returned well i can simply go
with nav and the same deal now since i
don't want them to be e in the same line
i'll just place a on our list then list
item and then same deal we need to
import our link
from
and you guessed it from gatsby so we go
here with our link again same addresses
we're gonna go with two prop
and we'll just set up to home page so
that's going to be forward slash and now
let me copy and paste this list item
and we're going to go with about
and let's just add here about as well so
let's save this sucker here and once my
navbar is ready to go then of course i
just need to go to any of the pages
that i want to set up the navbar import
the navbar and return it in my component
so back in the index.js we want to set
up the import and of course since i'm
exporting as default i can call it
whatever i want notice here export
default navbar so back in the index.js
i'm going to go with navbar and then
from and now of course in this case
we're looking in the components and then
more specifically navbar so now of
course i don't need to hard code it i
just simply go
with navbar like so and now of course we
have a good looking navbar so in here if
i click on about i navigate to about
page and since i want to navigate back
to the home page i'll do the same thing
e in the about.js so let's import the
nav bar
let's set it up here on the top so i
guess in order to speed this up i'll
just copy the component
and then
copy and paste i guess and then as far
as this text
so it's easier for you to see i'll just
place it in the heading two so let's say
this one
should probably restart now i have the
navbar in the about page as well as the
homepage so that's how we can add a
component to our gatsby pages
now in the next video i'll show you even
an easier way how we can set up a navbar
in all our pages nice we have a way of
adding components to our pages and
throughout the course we'll definitely
use this option
but not for the navbar why
well because navbar typically is a
global component meaning a component
that we want to display in all our pages
and a typical project you also want to
display footer in all the pages maybe a
sidebar model and hopefully you get the
gist
as you can imagine if we'll start
importing all the components all the
global components in all our pages
it's going to get messy pretty fast
so what option we're going to use
instead
a wrapper component approach now before
we set anything up let me just stress
something
this is not a invalid syntax
so we will use this approach where we
set up the component and then we use it
in one of our pages or maybe two of our
pages but the idea is that if you have a
component that is displayed in all your
pages
there's a better approach where you set
up a wrapper component and that way you
can group all your global components in
that one wrapper component
and then you don't have to import all
the global components in all your pages
now in order to stress the point of
multiple global components first i'm
going to navigate to components and
create a file by the name of footer and
then i'll create that wrapper component
now a common convention is calling this
layout just keep in mind it is just a
file name it is just a react component
so of course you can be a rebel and call
it whatever you want just keep in mind
that if you're reading someone else's
code most likely you'll see this
convention of naming it layout now first
i'll go to footer and in here i'll just
create my react component
and i'll close the sidebar just so we
have a bit more real estate and as far
as the footer
i'm just going to go with footer tags
and for time being
i'll just go with hello from
footer like so so we save the sucker
here and then of course we need to go to
the layout now layout is going to be the
component that wraps pretty much
all the pages
and the way we set it up we just go with
component and then in our return we're
going to place our global components and
then we'll use this layout to wrap all
our pages so first i guess let's start
by importing all our global ones the
moment we have two so we're gonna go
with import and we're looking for navbar
it is sitting in the same folder so we
simply go navbar and at this point i'll
use two cursors
so say here footer and then like i said
we just need to place them inside of the
return so i go with a navbar
and then the second one is the footer
now keep in mind one thing
when we use layout of course this div
will show up in our source code
so at this point you have multiple
options either you can return it as a
main you can return it as a section or
whatever element you want but just keep
in mind that that element will show up
with this particular setup
in your source code so my approach is
always using the react fragment so you
can write it the long way
react.fragment or the shorthand is just
using the angle brackets and effectively
it is a pattern
to return multiple elements because keep
in mind that in react we still need to
have this parent but using react
fragment we can group children without
adding the extra note again that is just
a react thing and that is my particular
setup i just prefer keeping my source
code as clean as possible so i'll save
the layout i'll open up the sidebar and
you know what i'll remove all the files
that i'm currently in but we're not done
we will have to return to layout because
there's one key thing missing with the
current setup but i just want to show
you what is going to be the error and
now of course i just need to navigate to
about an index and then wrap both of
those pages if i want to display the
footer as well as the navbar and we're
gonna first remove the navbar just so
you don't think that i'm cheating so
notice how i'm removing the import as
well as the component
then i also do the same thing here
where i'll remove the navbar and from
the return as well and now in the
index.js let's start by importing the
layout so we go with layout from
and then of course we're looking in the
components and then we go with the
layout
and then like i said
what we're going to do we're going to
wrap
all the return so everything that we're
returning from the page in our layout
component so at the moment we have div
and i can simply replace it i can say
that instead i'm going to be returning a
layout now keep in mind that the moment
you'll save you won't see any contents
of the homepage because we haven't
handled that in layout component and
once i save i do have the navbar as well
as the footer but what about the
contents of the page well we don't see
anything because we haven't handled that
in the layout
and if you're familiar with the react
you know that in react of course we have
a props object so let's quickly
console.log the props
for our layout
and now i'm going to navigate to the
bigger screen just so we can see a
little bit better
and in the console notice the object and
i'll try to zoom in
and basically props object
is a way to pass in the props
into the components so that is the react
setup
now one special prop is children and
essentially this children just
represents whatever you have inside of
the component so whatever is placed
inside of the component so i'm not
talking about the return of the
component i'm just talking about
whatever is placed inside of the
component and
since i want to display the contents of
the home page i need to access the
children
and then set up my return where i'm also
returning a children and in order to
access them there's multiple ways i can
do that you can either go with props dot
children somewhere here or you can just
structure it right away in parameters
and the syntax for that is the curly
braces and then we go with children
and then once i have access the children
now of course i just need to decide how
my return is going to look like and then
since i want a navbar on the top and
then footer in the bottom i simply set
up children
in between like so so once i save notice
now of course i have the contents of the
homepage now in order to make it less
confusing why don't we head back and
instead of hello people we just say home
page
so we save it and now i can clearly see
that this is my homepage now keep in
mind one thing where nothing stops you
from
moving the nav bar a common approach of
course is placing nav bar at the top and
that footer in the bottom but there is
no rule that says that you always have
to do that as long as you display the
children basically the contents of the
page that you're going to wrap and as
long as you have a valid syntax for the
component you're importing of course
you're going to be in good shape and now
to hammer this home why don't we do the
same thing in the about.js so let's
navigate to about.js we need to go with
import then we're looking for layout
from and again components and then the
layout and now of course i'm just going
to wrap the return of the about page as
well and as you can imagine if you have
more global components you simply create
them
and then add them to your layout and in
turn that does two things first it keeps
our project cleaner where we have only
one place where we have all the global
components and second you don't need to
hop from page to page for every global
component that you create and in order
to test it out why don't i go to my
navbar and click about so notice this is
my about page and i can nicely navigate
back to the home page as well so that is
a wrapper component approach
where effectively we set up one
component then import
all the global ones that we're going to
use in all our pages and then we simply
wrap all our pages in this layout
component but don't forget about the
children because otherwise you won't see
the contents of the actual page good job
i think at this point we have a solid
understanding of the gatsby basics
so switch gears and look at the styling
options in gatsby
as a quick side note since the primary
focus of this course is gatsby and
typing out the css takes a long time
for all the course projects including
this one all the css is already prepared
and ready to go we might type few lines
of css here and there while we work on
some examples but that's about it for
the most part styling is exactly the
same as in regular react
so if you already have the preferred
styling method you will be able to hit
the ground running in no time now since
i don't want this module to be three
hours long
i will only cover the major options as
well as my personal favorite just keep
in mind that gatsby fully supports other
options like bootstrap tailwind emotion
or any of the gazillion options that we
have out there as well
and you can find those implementations
within a matter of seconds
by just performing a quick search in the
starter library or utilizing your
favorite search engine all right and the
most basic way how we can style our
gatsby applications is using inline
styles
so if i go back to index.js
and for example i want to style the
heading 1 i can simply add a style
attribute but just keep in mind that
when we work in jsx we're actually
working with javascript now what that
simply means
is that if i set up my double curlies
and again the reason why we're setting
up double curly curlies because for a
style it is looking for the object and
then in order to access javascript we
simply need to use these curly braces so
the first curly braces is to go back to
the javascript and then the second one
is the object because again that is what
is required in the jsx when you're
setting up the style attribute because
at the end of the day you're setting up
the javascript and the same goes for
properties and values for example you
cannot type color and then colon red
like you normally would in the css why
because this is javascript so the value
needs to be in the quotation marks and
then of course once we save there is of
course my heading is red and like i said
the same goes for the properties if i
want to set up text transform notice i
don't write text hyphen transform again
we cannot do that in javascript as far
as the object properties so we need to
go with text transform and then as far
as the value again e in the quotation
marks and capitalized so that's the most
basic way how we can add css to our
gatsby application while setting up our
styling using inline css
is definitely an option
you can kind of see that it's going to
get messy pretty fast
and we don't need to even add that many
elements so for example if i set up
multiple heading ones so there's going
to be hello
world and copy and paste and hello
people and what if i want to style them
exactly the same of course you can say
well i'll just grab the style and then
you'll copy and paste okay but what if i
later want to change
all my heading ones to green am i gonna
hop from one heading one to another one
and keep changing these values okay and
what about different pages we have about
we have contact and hopefully you get
ages so a better approach is setting up
a
global css now
eventually we'll set up a separate
folder for that for all the assets the
images the css and all that but for time
being while our project is still nice
and cute i'm just gonna head to
components
and then we need to come up with a file
name and since i'm gonna be attaching
this to the layout i'm going to go with
layout
and then css so at this point this is a
traditional css file so you can do all
the cssc things that you like to do so
you can import fonts you can set up css
variables and all that cool stuff now in
our case we're not going to be that
dramatic we're just going to go with
body and then we're going to go with
font family and i'm going to go with a
system one like so and then maybe let's
add a bit of background as well just so
we can see that it actually works and
maybe let's go with red so maybe we will
be a bit drastic in the beginning now of
course nothing is happening because we
haven't imported this css
and
next i'm also going to style all the
heading ones and i'm just going to set
them up as color
blue
and then where do we import this file
well since we have a layout and that
layout is going to wrap all our pages i
think it kind of makes sense if we just
import this layout css here now with
this one since it is a css file we don't
need to specifically say what we're
importing however we do need to use the
extension so remember how when we use
navbar and footer we simply went with
navbar and footer notice there is no js
with the css one you need to have a full
extension since it's not a javascript
file so we simply go with import and
then forward slash and then layout
and then css now again we don't need to
say what we're importing now of course i
have my background red as well as the
color for the hanging ones now let me
mention two things
first keep in mind that since we have a
inline style
in our project
it will always be stronger than the
global one so even though i said all my
heading wants to be blue
because i'm using the inline style for
the first one
whatever color i have here is going to
be applied now why am i telling you that
because there's going to be cases where
you are not setting up the inline style
for example you're using a third party
library
and that library adds that inline css
and then it's your job to go back to the
source code and check what styles are
applied so that way you can either
override them
or maybe you can just fully understand
what is happening as far as the css now
the second thing with gatsby version 3
they have this interesting setup where
during the development even though
contact
or i don't know testing does not have
the layout component the styles will be
applied so previously the setup was
following where only the pages that had
layout the css was applied that's not a
scenario anymore with gatsby version 3.
what am i talking about well if i go to
about i can clearly see that i still
have my footer and bar correct and i
have hello from the about page so that
makes sense of course the global style
is present but
why i have the global style also in
contact so if i hop over to the navbar
and if i add a link
to a contact
so say contact here
and
contact you'll notice something
interesting so once we save first of all
we have a link
in navmar that makes sense and then once
you press check it out notice how the
page is read and if you still don't
believe me if we go to the contact and
just change to heading 1
and change the text to contact page
you'll see that there is no nav bar
so there's no nav bar footer so we don't
have the layout but the background is
red and of course the heading 1 is blue
so again we will still have to use the
layout we'll have to import the layout
set up the layout and all that but the
global css in asb version 3 is already
applied but let me be very clear as far
as i tested this is only happening in
development
so once you deploy your project
if the page does not have the layout
styles won't be applied while global
styles are great and will definitely use
them in our project
as your project gets bigger eventually
will run into two issues
where you'll have to get creative with a
class names because you don't want to
have name collisions and second it's
going to get harder and harder to manage
the global css and in this video i
simply want to show you the name
collision problem and then in the
following videos we'll take a look at
the approaches that we can use in gatsby
to avoid them and i actually want to
start by removing this background red
because i do find it a bit annoying and
again we have multiple heading ones and
you know what in these videos i'll just
focus on the about an index.js again
eventually we will add layout to rest of
the pages for now let's just work in
these two pages the homepage as well as
the about so in the about i'm just going
to change it around and i'll simply say
about page
and of course i just need to navigate
back
so let's go to about
for some reason it tells me that there
is no page so let me refresh of course
everything works and as you can see i
have the about page and i have the
homepage and in both cases i have these
heading ones and they are blue and of
course in order to avoid that i just
need to go with maybe a class of about
heading
and then i'm just going to say color
and we're going to go with green
and we can do the same thing with home
heading so home
heading
and then as far as these ones well why
don't we keep them as blue so i'll just
remove the global style and i'll set up
a color and i'll say color is equal to
blue now if we head back to index.js
first i guess let's just remove
the inline style
for these ones and then i want to simply
apply this class so where i can apply
the class well i can probably come up
with a div
and inside of this div i'm just going to
go with home heading so home
and then hyphen heading and then
whatever heading i'm going to place
inside of the div of course all of them
will be blue we can clearly see that and
then the same thing we'll do in about so
let's say here that i'm going to create
a div and this is going to be an about
heading class name and about heading and
now of course if i navigate to about
page the heading should be green but
it's not so let's see
first let's try to refresh that didn't
work
and maybe at this point i'll have to
restart the server so let's go with npm
start
and then once the server is up and
running we definitely should see that
green color so that's the thing
sometimes in development yes the hot
reloading is technically working but
once in a while you might need to
restart the server and then once you do
and once i refresh notice now of course
i have the about page and like i said as
your project gets bigger and bigger
you just need to get really creative
with these class names because you want
to avoid the name collisions as much as
possible and also the second issue is
the fact that as your project gets
bigger and bigger and bigger it is
harder and harder to manage the global
css file so in following videos we'll
take a look at two solutions that we can
use in our gatsby project all right and
the first solution that we have in
gatsby is built into the gatsby so you
don't need to install anything and it is
called css modules now i have to be
perfectly honest
i actually don't use that solution
because i do find it a bit clunky
and i actually prefer styled components
option instead and i'm going to cover
that in next video again that is just my
personal preference it doesn't mean that
it's a bad one i just find styled
components easier to use and the way we
set up css modules
we simply need to create a file by the
name of module css now what i'm going to
do is in the source i'm going to create
a new folder and i'll call this examples
and effectively in this folder i'll just
dump things that eventually are not
going to be part of our project meaning
part of our recipe site but just in case
you ever want to have a reference you
can just find it in the examples so in
the examples we'll create two css files
and the first one will be home module
css and the second one will be about
module css so as you can imagine
for every page you can create one for
every component you can create one it
really comes down to your preference so
in the examples i'm going to go with
home and naming here is important so
come up with whatever name you want so
in my case i'm going to go with home
then module
and then css so that is the proper
syntax and let's do the same thing for
the about as well so we're going to go
with about
module css and if you want to create one
for navbar one for footer of course you
can definitely do so and then in here we
just need to come up with a class and
since i don't want to be creative with
my class names i'll simply say page so i
go with page here and then i just need
to come up with the styles so in this
case
in my page i want to have a color
and i'm going to go with blue
so all the elements the color will be
blue and then let's also set up a text
one
so that's going to be another class
and in this case i'm just going to add
text transform
text transform and we're going to go
with capitalize and just to showcase
that we're not limited to only setting
up the classes meaning we can use other
css selectors instead i'll also write
page and planning one is going to be
color
and for time being why don't we go with
blue violet so i'll save it here
and now i just need to import now since
i named my one home module css now of
course it only makes sense
if i navigate to index.js and then i go
with import and this is the difference
between version two and version three
where in version three you need to be
specific of what classes you're actually
importing previously you just got the
whole object and then somewhere in your
code you used it now in this case it is
different where they actually want you
to name it now you can still import as
the whole thing and i'll show you that
in the about page but a typical approach
is getting the exact classes that you
have in the module css file so in my
case what classes do i have i have page
and of course i also have the text now
where is it coming from of course it is
coming from examples and then the file
name is home
module css again since it is a css file
you need to provide a full path and then
i just need to decide well where i'm
going to apply those classes and let's
start with the page class well this one
kind of makes sense if i'll apply to my
div correct and then that way i'll right
away style my headings and then this
text one well i'll have to create a
paragraph and probably add that text
class so we go here with class name
and then we need to use this dynamic
approach where of course now we have
imported the class name by the name of
page so we simply go with page like so
so once i save and once i navigate back
home
check it out i can see that all my
heading ones at the moment have this
color now if you don't see it try
refreshing the page
and then of course i also want to create
a paragraph with some lorem text so say
lorem and apply the text and of course
in here notice how the text is blue why
well because i say that everything is
going to be color blue but then the
heading ones are going to have this blue
violet color now if i want to capitalize
this of course i need to go back to
index.js and i already have this class
so the same deal we go with class name
and then we go with the text now why it
is so powerful because i can do the same
thing in a bot module meaning i can use
the same names
and just change the value so let me copy
this copy and paste and i don't need to
come up with about page or homepage or
contact page or whatever i can simply
change these values so for example i'm
going to go back to the annoying red one
so all the text here is going to be
color red and then the adding ones are
gonna be i don't know
yellow maybe yellow green and then as
far as the text i'm gonna go to
uppercase so notice how i'm using the
same names i'm just changing the values
so now of course if i navigate to about
again i just need to import we go here
import page and then text from and then
the module of course examples and then
about
module
and then css and in here again instead
of the div
why don't we go
with a page so that's the class that i
have and then of course right below it
let's add a heading 1 with hello world
just so you can see that it is actually
working and we can check it out notice
at this point nothing was updated so
again at this point we'll have to
refresh and there it is now i have about
page as well as the hello world and then
right below it why don't we set up a
text
and again this is going to be a
paragraph with just some dummy text so
we'll use lorem once we save
and then again once we refresh it is
going to be red why because
that's the styling i have in my about
module and then lastly if i want to have
this uppercase i simply go with text
and i add that to my paragraph so i'm
going to go back to about and then if we
go with class name
and then if we say text then of course
the moment we'll save
and again in this case we'll have to
refresh of course our text will be
uppercase so as you can see using these
modules solves both issues
first we don't need to be creative with
our class names and yet we can still
use the proper css selector so if you
come up with one class name you can just
say that i'm going to style heading ones
or paragraphs and all that and the
second thing your files will be way more
manageable because of course in here for
example i'm just going to apply styles
to the home page and in the about module
of course that is going to be 40 baht
module in navbar one the styles are
going to be for navbar and hopefully you
get the gist again it is my preference
to use styled components because i still
find it a bit clunky but it is
definitely a good option and what's
really cool it is right away built into
the gatsby now lastly i just want to
showcase that of course there's also an
option where we don't have to name them
and we simply do it this way where we go
with a star and we say as and then we
just need to come up with a name in here
i can say about styles
now every time i access this one i also
need to use about
and styles and then class name didn't
change
so class name is exactly the same
but of course the beginning part is
different so at this point i'm not
setting up
named imports i'm not saying hey get me
the page or text i'm just saying get me
everything i'm gonna rename it as styles
about styles and then i'm just gonna use
this value so that definitely is another
option you can do
and let me just save the text and let me
refresh and showcase that nothing
changed and at the very end i just want
to showcase that if you navigate to the
browser
notice the elements
so if we go to the gatsby one right now
and then instead of the div
and then inside of the div
notice the class name it is home module
and then page and then whatever value
over here and the way the modules work
effectively they set up these unique
class names so that's why i can use the
same name in my about module the same as
in home module and in any page module
that i possibly have so here notice we
have this class that i'm styling heading
once and the same works for the
paragraph where i have that text one
again this is a unique class name so
that way you won't have those name
collisions and if we navigate to about
check it out again this is going to be
different name for that div so about
module and then page and then again some
kind of different value and with that
said now let's take a look at the styled
components approach awesome job we're
almost done with the styling and as a
last topic in this module i would like
to cover styled components now i can
tell you right away that we will only be
scratching the surface of what styled
components can do
and we only cover them since in later
course projects i'll provide css using
styled components and therefore i want
you to be aware of the general setup as
a side note if you are interested in
style components i do have entire course
dedicated to style components and you
can check it out by visiting
johnsmilga.com
now the idea behind style components is
very similar to that of css modules they
add unique class names so we don't need
to worry about naming collisions and
also provide modularity so we don't need
to jam all of our css code in one file
what's also interesting in order to add
style components to our project we'll
learn how to add plugins to our project
and you can think of plugins as a way to
enhance our project's capabilities with
the help of gatsby community
so with that said let's first navigate
to the gatsby docs and we're looking for
the plugins link
so go to the gatsby docs and then look
for the plugins once we navigate here as
you can see we have many many many many
many plugins at our disposal and the
idea is following where if i have a
gatsby project and if i want to add some
feature i just go to the plugins get the
plugin and
basically somebody else in the community
has provided that feature for me now
there's official plugins so plugins made
by the gatsby team they're plugins made
by the companies and as an example later
in the project we'll use the contentful
one and of course since we can create
our own plugins there's also plugins
made by the community
and in my case since i don't want to
search through all the plugins just to
find the styled component one i'll
simply go to the search box and i'll
type styled and once we do
first option is going to be gatsby
plugin style components that's the
plugin we're looking for
and what i really enjoy for most of them
the documentation
is super super well written where they
right away tell you everything you need
to install everything you need to set up
and as a result you are up and running
in no time in this case they right away
tell us what
libraries we need to install what
dependencies we need to add to our
project so we simply copy this line and
then navigate back to our project now we
do need to stop the server so press ctrl
c i'll clear the terminal and copy and
paste and then keep on scrolling and
notice how to use we need to add in a
gatsby config
our plugin
and what's really important gatsby
config is a node file so this is just a
export syntax for node files they use
common.js that's why we call it module
exports we're exporting a object and
then in that object we have plugins
array and this is important don't rename
it to john peter or susan it has to be a
plugins that's a must and then we have
two options some plugins will be set up
as objects if we want to set up more
options and some of them will be set up
only as a string now
in this case they showcase as an object
but in fact we can use it as a string so
just copy this string keep in mind that
these are template literals those are
not quotation marks and that is very
important so now i have this string and
again i'll navigate back to my project
and of course in this case i'm going to
be looking for my gatsby config and then
notice i have my array i just copy and
paste and successfully i have my first
plugin now every time you install a
dependency or make some changes in
gatsby config
i suggest restarting the server
otherwise the latest changes might not
be applied so npm start we spin up the
dev server and the way we set up style
component we simply go to examples we'll
create a new file and i'll call this
button and more specifically button.js
so let me zoom out for some reason
i didn't add the js extension and the
way we work with styled components we go
with import and common convention is
calling this styled but it is a default
export so technically you don't have to
follow the conventions then we go with
styled components and the way we set up
our styled component we either can go
with export default or a named export
and effectively we're right away setting
up a react component now under the hood
it is still going to be a html element
and i'll show you that in a second in
the browser so in my case i'm going to
go with a named export option where i'm
going to go with export const and then
we just need to come up with the name
example button is equal to styled dot
and then whatever html element we want
so if you want div you just type diff if
you want article you type article if you
want a section you get to just type the
section now in my case since i have the
file name by the name of button as well
as the component name i might as well go
with the button and then we go with this
interesting syntax of tag template
literal now they're not unique to styled
components
in fact they were introduced in es6 but
the way style components use them is we
simply add here the styles and they will
be applied to our react component
and in turn our html element so if i go
with background
and green
and also add maybe a color of orange
and font size
is going to be two rems you'll see that
once we render the button all these
styles will be applied now quickly i
want to mention that if
your screen looks a bit different than
mine it is simply because i'm using this
extension the vs code styled components
i believe that was the name
style components extension yeah and this
extension does two things
it adds colors to properties so
properties are different color than the
value so probably in your case you
probably see everything as orange and
second it right away checks for the bug
so for example if i remove the semicolon
right away tells me that hey listen
there's something wrong with your code
if you don't have that extension then
you'll have to debug it yourself so
that's the extension
let me make this smaller now once we
have the button e in place and by the
way you know what i messed it up i did
not save gatsby config so my apologies
but i'll have to restart it otherwise i
might have to do that later anyway so
again i stopped the server control c
in this case i have saved all the
changes and then i go
with start okay
now back in our file system of course in
the index.js i want to get that button
so i'm going to go with import now since
it is a named export i need to go with
example button from and then of course
we're looking in the examples and then
the button and then i just need to
decide where i want to render it so i'm
going to go above the headings and i'll
say example button now as far as the
text inside of the button we're just
gonna go with click me so once i
navigate back home the moment i don't
see it but once i refresh i should see
my button
and that's interesting okay now it is so
i guess it took a little bit
for the server to spin up now of course
we can see the button not just the
showcase it is still a html element here
i also need to refresh so gatsby div
and then notice this unique class name
that's what's responsible for setting up
those unique styles so we don't need to
worry about the name collisions so these
styles will be only applied to this
specific button
not to all the buttons that we have in
our project and the way we'll use later
style components in our upcoming
projects is following where basically
i'm going to go to about.js keep in mind
that you can do it in any of the
components i'm just going to use
about.js as an example and i'm going to
go with import
styled
and then of course i'm looking for
styled components and then
typically i'll set up my style component
below
my actual component and then i'll just
wrap my component in the style component
so we go with
const and usually i'll probably call
them wrapper
and then i'll say style again whatever
html element you want so sometimes it's
going to be a section sometimes it's
going to be a div
and you get an idea so in this case why
don't we go with section here
and then as far as the styles why don't
we copy the ones from the about module
css so just grab everything and i'll
show you how we can set it up in the
start component and a setup in a style
component is pretty much just like in
normal css since i know that i'm going
to be wrapping my component
in this style component i actually don't
need this page anymore i can simply say
that
whatever elements are going to be inside
of my wrapper well the color is going to
be red and the same goes for heading
ones i don't need to have this class
anymore i'm just going to say all the
heading ones that are inside of this
wrapper will have this yellow green now
we can still use the classes if we want
in a style component if there is going
to be a text class inside of my
styled component then of course the text
transform will be equal to uppercase now
the only thing left to do is just scroll
up and then i'll remove these class
names
we don't need them apart from the
paragraph one that one we will add back
later but first i want to just change
the div to my wrapper so that's my style
component and then like i said let's
also add a class name of text for my
paragraph and we'll save it
and of course this is the homepage so
now i need to navigate to about page and
notice how my styles did not change and
if i'll change it from red to blue in
this case once we save once we refresh
of course the text color right now is
going to be blue now why do i find
styled components
easier to work with than the css modules
simply because i like the fact that all
my styles are in the same file as my
component so that way as i'm setting up
the functionality i can right away add
the styling as well the reason why i
find the modules a bit clunky because
you set up the logic and then you need
to rush back to the module css file look
for the class look for changes and all
that now again for some people that's
not a big deal but my preference is
always to have the styles in the same
file and effectively that is going to be
the setup in a future project where i
will prepare all the boilerplate for you
so we won't create the components every
time from the scratch it's only in this
project and tutorial one where we're
doing that and then also with the setup
there's going to be a styled component
in the bottom with all the styles so
we'll simply need to add the wrapper to
our component and we'll be in good shape
and you'll have all the styles and also
you'll be able right away to see
what styling i applied to my component
now i'm not complaining
the default modules option is a very
good one it's definitely better than
global css but i personally prefer using
styled components instead
that should do it for the main styling
options we have in gatsby
and now we can move on to our next topic
nice and before we cover data in gatsby
why don't we spend some time on our
current project
so it looks more like this
than whatever we have right now
and we're going to start with some house
cleaning
so i'm going to navigate back
to my project and in the pages i'll
remove that company folder again
that was just to showcase how the nested
structure works we actually don't need
it for a project now if you want to keep
it that's definitely your option but in
my case i will remove it and visual
studio code is concerned but i'll say
yes i want to remove the company and the
same goes for testing as a quick side
note you probably noticed that in the
terminal you get this warning so even
though i said that yes this is one of
the options that you can use when you're
setting up the arrow function where
essentially you just go with export
default and our function at this point
they right away set up the warning and
basically they just suggest using other
approach where we set up the name and
then we export as default which here is
going to be my option throughout the
course anyway now why am i telling you
that because i want to remove the
testing anyway so go with remove and
we'll remove that sucker as well now
that's a great start
then in the components
i'm not going to have the layout
all the css is going to be in a
different folder anyway so yes i want to
remove the layout css as well and then
one by one
we'll add the basic changes to all our
pages as well as create all the pages we
eventually will have in our project so
let's start with index.js
i don't want to keep this module one and
that was for your reference same goes
for the example button and i simply can
remove example button as well as this
class name now to tell you honestly i'll
just have the layout for now
with a heading 1 of homepage so i'll say
home page let's just keep things simple
at this point and since i removed the
files and all that it looks like i'll
have to restart so let's go here with
npm start
we'll start it up and then of course
next one is the about js again the same
deal i don't want the import for the
module i also don't want for styled ones
and i have another complaint where the
layout.js is of course looking for
layout css so let's remove this one as
well and once that one is fixed in the
about.js
of course we don't have the wrapper
anymore so remove that one
and
also
i'll remove the whole
styled component
and here also wrapper goes and the same
deal i'm just gonna leave one heading
one with a about page so again let's see
yep that fixes it so i have my current
navbar home about contact and then i
just have hello from footer and
effectively this is the structure that i
want to set up in all my pages and i
guess let's continue by setting up all
the pages that we're going to have in
our project so if i take a look at the
complete one i have home i have recipes
page i have tags page about and contact
and of course the error so effectively
we need to create two more we need to
create recipes as well as the tags
so since i'm going to use pretty much
the same setup i can just copy whatever
i have in the about and now in the pages
let's create
tags page so tags js
as well as new files and we'll call this
recipes js so copy and paste
now it's probably a better setup if we
change the name keep in mind we're
exporting as default so technically it
doesn't matter but just to stay
consistent i'm gonna go with recipes and
i always suggest using the capital
casing and i'll show you when we work
with navbar why it is better and
essentially it's because of react hooks
but don't worry we'll get there and i'll
say here recipes as well i'll just say
instead of about page
recipes page let's save it okay
awesome and then i want to do the same
thing in the tags so copy and paste
everything
and again instead of recipes
we're going to go with tags here
and tags here as well
and recipes
will become tags page now since i want
to quickly navigate around my project
just to see whether everything worked
i'll go back to navbar again there's
going to be multiple iterations of this
navbar
so we will have to restructure it a bit
later but for now let's just copy and
paste and remember that we have
tags
as well as the recipes
recipes okay let's save it and of course
i didn't change these values here so
that's why i have
multiple contacts so tags
recipes over here and i can clearly see
now all my pages so i have home
about
contact and of course in the contact
page i did not add layout so that was my
bad i guess let's go back to the contact
page so where it is over here and now
since we already have this setup why
don't we copy and paste it's going to be
faster so let's go back to the contact
select everything in here i'm showcasing
the function approach meaning the good
old function keyword approach but we'll
just change it to a arrow function
instead so i'm looking for recipes and i
want to change it to contact so let me
in this case select all three of them
we'll say contact here
and then if we refresh of course we also
have right now a navbar as well as the
footer in the contact page so now i can
nicely navigate around and i can see
that i have all my pages and lastly i
just want to add layout to my error page
as well
because if you remember i said that
error page is just a typical page so we
can do all the same things that we do in
other pages and again i think it's just
going to be faster selecting everything
copy and paste and just change the name
now if you're wondering why nothing
breaks well it is simply because layout
of course is sitting in the same place
so as we're setting up the files here in
the pages this path will always be
correct now of course if you'll have
nested structure that's a different
scenario so say here error
and
i'm going to do it here as well and then
lastly for the heading one let's just
say error so let's save this one as you
can see all these pages
are set up correctly and now i just want
to test out the error so simply add i
don't know whatever gibberish after
contact this is going to spit me back
this screen and of course now i can see
the error page so
we have good fundamentals in place and
now we can move on to our next task all
right and once we have general structure
in place
now let's quickly deal with styling and
don't worry since it's a gas because i
won't make you type out dcss i'll simply
copy and paste the styles from the final
project
and if you want to access the styles you
have two options probably the fastest
one is just going to be using
johnsmilk.com
navigate there again we're looking
for the gatsby project
and then we're looking for a recipe site
and then click on either the star files
or the source code both of them lead to
the same place and basically you'll hit
the repo now another option of course
you can look for my getup profile
johnsmilk.com or i'm sorry john smilga
and then go for gatsby version 3
tutorial recipes and once you hit the
repo in the source look for the assets
one
and in there more specifically look for
css and finally you'll hit the main css
and i suggest just clicking on raw
and essentially these are all the styles
we're going to use in the project so
just click select all
copy and navigate back now again in my
case i'll keep the same structure
because later i'll use those assets so
in the source i'll create a new folder
and the name is assets like so then in
this folder i'm going to create another
one and i'll call the css and then
finally in this one i'll create the new
file i'll call my one main css i'll zoom
out copy and paste and we have all the
styles
now you'll notice that at the very top
the fonts are commented out because
later
we will use a plugin to set up the funds
and of course i'll talk about it once we
get there for time being if you want to
have the same funds as in the final
project just uncomment the fonts that's
all you have to do now of course nothing
changed in our project because
we still need to include it
and the way i'm going to do that i'm
going to go to the layout one and
instead of looking for the layout css
now of course i'm going to go with
import and then
in the assets folder css
and again the file name is
main css and the moment you save notice
right away we have the styles
now i also prefer using normalized css
in my project keep in mind this is
nothing to do with gatsby it is just a
thing that i like to use now if you're
not familiar with normalize
effectively it preserves useful defaults
and tries to normalize the styles across
the browsers basically it gives us a
safe starting point
and if you're familiar with css reset it
is just a nicer version of this one you
probably have seen this one margin 0
padding and then zero and then box
sizing border box normalize just uses
way more complicated setup than that so
i'll remove this dummy code and if you
want to use normalize just quickly go to
normalize css now you can click on
download and you're going to get entire
css code and you can create a new file
that is definitely an option and then
copy and paste whatever code you have
over here or you can use the npm module
which is going to be in my case so i'm
just going to copy this line of code
i'm going to navigate back to my project
stop everything clear the console copy
and paste install normalize css again
this is the case where i don't need to
set up anything in the gatsby config i
don't need to set it up as a plugin
because this is not a gatsby thing
effectively this is a reacting
and of course i just need to navigate to
my layout and
before i import main css i'll also
import my normalize so in here i go with
import and then i look for normalize and
css that's all we have to do and the
moment i import my normalize as well i'm
just going to restart the server
and of course normalize has been added
to our project and once that is out of
the way now of course we can move on to
the next step
beautiful once the styling is in place
now let's knock out some components and
we'll start with the basic ones so the
ones that don't have any queries or
images
and once we have more knowledge about
gatsby then we'll complete the
complicated ones as well
and i guess our footer can be a great
starting point
so if you take a look at the complete
application of course you can see the
footer and this is going to be our first
component and i'm going to navigate to
the footer that's my component and at
the moment i just have this footer tag
with a heading 2 and instead i'm going
to use the class so i'm going to attach
the class that is coming from my global
css class name is page footer and then
as far as the return there's going to be
a paragraph
and first i'm going to use this html
entity where i do want to have this copy
one
and once i save i have my black footer
as well as the copyright symbol and then
after that we're going to go with date
now first i'll hard code this and then
in a second i'll show you how we can
make this dynamic then we have a span
and a span we'll simply write the name
of the site so in my case
that is going to be
simple recipes
then right next to this pan
we are going to have a text and
text is going to be following built
with and why don't we use the href so
why don't we use the simple link element
because i want this link to navigate to
external resource more specifically
gatsby site so let me go back here i'm
going to go back to the main site
and then i'll just copy and paste the
url here in the href and then we'll
simply place a text and i'll simply
write gatsby we save it
that's our look and then the only thing
that is actually missing is the dynamic
year now since we know that we are of
course
working in the jsx in order to go back
to the javascript plan we just need to
set up the curly braces and then we can
just use a javascript date we can go
with new date so
that gets us the date and then we can go
with get full year which is a method
that of course gets us a full year and
that way we don't need to come back
every year and update the hard-coded
value
will always display the correct current
year as far as the css if you're
interested
in styles that i set up just navigate to
main css and use the shortcut command f
and then just type whatever class name
so in this case of course you have page
footer so these are all the styles that
i applied to the footer and the setup
for next component is going to be the
same we're basically we'll be working on
our return and we'll just add the
classes so that way we can save some
time on typing out the css and lastly i
just want to mention that the site
doesn't look exactly the same as the
complete one because of course we need
to work on the other components as well
so eventually yes the footer will be all
the way at the bottom and it's not going
to be hanging out by the homepage but we
just need to add more components and add
more css and then we won't have those
issues and once the footer is in place
our next step is going to be
our error page
so let me navigate in complete one and
there it is so place a 404
some text and we'll be in good shape so
first i'm going to navigate back i'm
going to close all the files
and then i'll open up the 404 then i'm
going to close the sidebar and i'm also
gonna remove the finder and then we'll
still have a layout but we'll have a
different structure where there's going
to be a main tag with the class name of
error
and page and then inside of this main
let's place a section and then instead
of the section we're going to have a
heading 1 with 404
and then also a heading 3 page
not found that's it we save this one and
now of course we want to test it out so
in the browser let's navigate to the
error like so now of course we don't
have the page for that so then we open
this up and of course we have 404 page
not found awesome that concludes the
error page all right and our next step
is going to be a contact page and
basically here we have text on the left
hand side and then a working form on the
right hand side now for time being we'll
just set up to return and eventually we
will add the service that takes care of
the form submissions but for time being
let's just not worry about form
submissions and just set up the return
now as far as this component we'll work
on this one later because here we're
fetching
data from contentful and in fact we are
reusing this component all throughout
our application if you take a look at
the about it's the same component it's
actually the same component in recipes
now i know there's more recipes right
now but of course we'll make our
component flexible where we just pass in
the data and then the component displays
those recipes same one is used in home
here as well as the tags so if i go to a
specific tag this is the same component
again less data but same component so
once we create that component once we
understand how we can fetch data from
the headless cms then of course we'll
add it to the contact page as well so
let's navigate back and i'll open up my
sidebar and of course i'm looking for
the contact page
and then in contact inside of the layout
i just want to place a main first and
we're going to add a class name of page
like so and then inside of the main we
have a section with a class of contact
page contact page and then inside of
this section we have those two articles
so one is going to be a form
and second one is just a text so i'm
gonna go with heading three and in order
to speed this up i'm just going to copy
this i'm not going to write it now if
you're interested on where i'm getting
this text my preference
is using hipster ipsum and the site for
that is ipsum
and then you come here and you just say
how many paragraphs you want in my case
of course i'm gonna go with five and
then if you want you can start with i'm
baby if not then of course you can just
unclick it and then you bear me and of
course there is this is a text again in
order to speed this up i'll simply copy
and paste the values from the complete
page so that way you don't have to watch
me type out the text so this is going to
be my heading and then i'll have three
paragraphs so essentially three
paragraphs one after another and
i have this one as well
and then i have the third one right so
copy and paste
and then the sucker as well
of course i have my heading as well as
three paragraphs now i said that i'm
going to add two articles and for some
reason i skipped on that one so let me
add an article i'll add a class name
here
and i'll say contact
and then hyphen info and now let's place
the headings as well as the paragraphs
inside of this article my bad
let's do it and once we save then of
course i'll create another article and
in this case there's going to be no
class and then inside of the article
we're going to go with form tags and
then we're looking for two classes form
and contact form
and then i'm going to remove the action
because we'll work on this one later
we're not worried about it right now
and then we have a form row and instead
of the form row we'll have a label and
the input and effectively we'll have
three form rows and i said
i need to fix this bug this should say
email and also of course we'll have the
submit button as well so let's navigate
back and then like said for every input
there's going to be a
form row and then inside of this div
there's going to be a label so we're
going to go with label and as far as the
html4 what's going to be name because of
course the id
on my name input is going to be named so
say your name and then input now type in
this case is going to be text and then
we'll have name is equal to name and
then id is also equal to name and once i
save that's our first input and in order
to speed this up i'll copy and paste our
entire div and then i'm looking for the
name and i just want to change it to
email so i'll use command d again to get
all the instances
of this one and i'll change it around to
email now there's one bug this shouldn't
be email should be name so let's save it
now of course we have the second one and
the third one will be our message and
that is going to be a text area so this
is not going to be the case where i'll
copy and paste i'll simply say form row
and then inside of this form row let's
add another label now this is going to
be for the message
so let's write the text message as well
and then right next to the label let's
just go with our text area
and i did already set up the css so we
only need name so i'm going to go with
message and then the id
also message but as far as the columns
and rows
that's controlled by the css so i'll
just remove it and then like i said
eventually we also want a submit button
so we just go with button
and submit now i do want to add some
classes here and the class names are btn
and block and then instead of the button
write whatever you want so in my case
i'm going to go with submit so once we
save
that is our contact form so let me go
here and check it out so that's my home
page of course i have the contact page
okay awesome
as well as the error page so let's see
this sucker here as well
and of course that's my custom one and
yes and with this in place i think we
can tackle a bit harder component and
that is going to be our navbar nice
congrats on completing our first three
components i think we're in good shape
and we have finally arrived at the
navbar component now before we start
typing away we do need to get some
assets because if you take a look at the
nav bar there is a logo so there is
going to be a image in navbar as well as
on a small screen we have the button and
then instead of the button there's
actually a icon
now for my assets i'm going to get them
from the complete project because i
already have the logo of course and when
it comes to icons i prefer using react
icons but you don't have to if you have
your own assets if you have your own
logo
as well as you have a preference for
icons
you can definitely use your own assets
nothing stops you from doing that now
the only thing yeah you might need to
change some css around where maybe your
i don't know logo is bigger or maybe
your icon is smaller and something along
those lines and as far as getting the
assets simply navigate to complete
project so again i'm going to go to my
github i'm looking for gatsby
version 3 tutorial recipes
and then at this point i'm just going to
get the whole project so i'm going to
clone it and then in the project i'm
looking for the assets folder so i'm
going to navigate back
and i said i actually don't need this
one open
because once in a while it kind of opens
up the window that's a side note but
while you're recording it's just the
email pops out so we're going to go with
cd and desktop like so git clone
and i'm just going to clone it here so
that's my recipes
and as a quick say note it is actually a
working project so
if you want you can open up a new window
and just drag and drop and then i
purposely
left all my credentials as far as the
headless cms because that way you can
definitely see that the project works so
first you just need to run npm
install and the second one will be gadsb
develop now keep in mind that it will
spin up the dev server on localhost
8000. so of course it's going to ask for
a different port so let's spin this up
while i'm installing dependencies i'll
simply
go to the project here and then in the
source i'm looking for this whole thing
so i have the assets i have css i have
some data which we're going to use a
little bit later and i have the images
so i already have the css folder so
simply take these two folders and i'll
just copy and paste and set them up in
my tutorial so in here i'm going to go
back to the source i'm going to go back
to the assets i'll zoom in so you can
see better and i'll just copy and paste
now i have the data again something
we'll use later and then the images so
notice this is my logo svg and then i
have some images that we're going to use
later as well as a quick side note as
you can see it's a extremely basic logo
and yep notice here it says can i use a
different port and of course i'll say
yes and back to the logo like i said it
is extremely basic logo that i just made
in figma i've been getting questions how
you can make such image i just went to
figma and just typed out the text and
added different fonts and colors and all
that that's it that's all i did and as
far as the icons i prefer using react
icons but again this is nothing to do
with gatsby that's just my preference
regardless whether it is a gatsby
project or not and i simply like them
because they have tremendous amount of
icons
and you actually import them as a react
component and what that means that you
can add a class you can have all kinds
of effects and it's straight out of the
box so you don't have to do anything and
you simply install it as a dependency so
again the command is npm install react
icons now their site is react hyphen
icons github io and what's really cool
that you can basically search for the
icon so for example if you want to have
a person icon use that person and notice
how you have
all of these options and the way the
syntax works
you install of course which we're going
to do in a second
then you import the icon so that's going
to be the name but then you need to be
specific from which library because
notice these are all the libraries they
use so you import the icon specifically
say which library this is going to be
from and then you just stuck it in your
code and everything works i mean it's as
easy as it gets now they do show two
installs
one straight up react icons and then the
second one with all the files but i
don't think we'll run into this issue
since we literally need four icons
and therefore i'm just gonna go with a
first option so copy and paste this
command of course you can actually copy
here to the clipboard as well then
navigate back to your project stop the
server copy and paste again we don't
need to do anything in the gatsby config
and if you want to take a look how it
works let's just go back to the navbar
and i'll show you which icon we're going
to use so now of course we need to spin
up the dev server let's say npm start
and then we're looking for import and
then the icon name is f i
and then align
and justify
justify and this is coming from react
icons that's the main library and then
specifically the icon library is this
one the fi and like i said it is a
component so i can simply stick it in my
return and i'm going to be in good shape
so we just go here with f i online
justify and then once i save
and probably i'll have to refresh as
well
there it is that's my icon and again
what's really cool it is a react
component so if you want you can take a
look at the source code and you'll see
that we're getting a svg
and what's also really cool is that if
you want you can for example add a class
and then style it and all that cool
stuff so again a very very cool library
that i use not only in gatsby projects
because it's very easy to get up and
running it has tons and tons of options
for the icons and at the end of the day
they are react components so working
with them is really easy and finally
let's just go back to our localhost i
believe it's going to be 8001 right here
and i'll show you that of course you can
have a complete project so
8001
and there it is that's the complete site
so
if you ever want to compare your code to
mine
just get the complete project and you're
going to be in good shape
all right and our last simple component
is going to be a navbar component but
since it has toggle functionality we'll
split this up in two videos first i want
you to navigate to navbar.js and let's
just start from the scratch so remove
everything and we're going to return a
nav element then we want to right away
add the class so go with classname and
it's going to be a nap bar then inside
of the nav we're going to have a div
with a class of nav
center and then instead of this nav
center div we're going to have two more
we're going to have nav header 1 so this
is where the image
as well as the button with icon is going
to sit and then right next to it we're
gonna go with nav links and we'll add a
show links class as well so there's
another div with a class of nav links
and for time being since i want to
showcase how the links are going to look
like i'll also add this show links class
now eventually this is the class that
we're going to use to toggle our links
on a small screen so we have these
studios and let's start with a header
and in a header the first thing that i
want to do is add that image and as far
as this logo will do the traditional
react way just so you understand that it
is definitely an option and then in the
following videos of course we'll cover
how the gatsby image works and what kind
of goodies we get when we use gatsby
image for time being we'll just go the
traditional react route where we first
need to get the image so we need to
import it and then just set it up in a
source again a straightforward react way
so we go with import then we need to
come up with the name so in my case it's
going to be a logo and then we're
looking in the assets as well as images
and then finally we have logo svg again
it's not a javascript file so we need to
provide a full path and then inside of
this nav header i want to place my logo
now we can just place the logo
directly or we can place it in a link
and just to showcase that we're not
limited to setting up links with text
that we can also set up a link with
images if i navigate to tags and notice
if i click on my logo i navigate back
home so in order to do that we simply
need to go with link component then we
need to pass in the to prop so where
we're going to navigate and that's it we
just need to place our link so i'm going
to go with img and then like i said for
the source let's place in our variable
so our logo and then as far as the
alternative will just say simply recipes
let's save that one that should do it
now of course we have our header and
then right next to my logo i want to
have my button so i'm going to go with
button and then inside of this button i
want to place my icon so i'm going to go
with a icon name again align justify and
as far as the class is i'm just going to
go with class name
and we're going to go with nav
btn now eventually there's going to be
also on click but
not for time being so that should do it
for the header once we save notice this
is going to be our logo and if i click
notice how i navigate back home and then
also i have my button and now of course
i want to set up my links now as far as
the links you can place them in our list
if you want but the way i set up css and
everything i simply dump those links in
this div so here let's start with a link
component and to prop and we're going to
have a forward slash and then as far as
the text let's go with home let's save
it and then once i have my home link in
place now i just want to add few more
attributes first of all i want to add a
class name so we get the styling so this
is coming from my css i'm going to go
with nav link and then i also want to
add a attribute by the name of
activeclassname so this is coming from
the gatsby and what it's simply doing
notice how once we navigate to the page
well the link that represents that page
just changes the color now again you can
set up whatever css you want but
basically gatsby provides this active
class name attribute
and then whatever class name you pass it
in is going to be applied to the link
that represents the page so just to
showcase if again you navigate to
i believe which one was it main css
sorry got lost a little bit there if you
go to active and then hyphen link so
this is going to be the class that we
had notice the css again sky is the
limit you can add whatever css you want
but basically gatsby behind the scenes
the moment you'll navigate to that
specific page if you add the active
class name the active link it will
dynamically add this class to the link
so here whatever you set up is going to
be applied to the link so now let me go
back i'll close the sidebar and then i'm
going to go with active class name
that's the prop that you need to pass it
here and then we're looking for active
and then link and once i save notice how
it changes the color now eventually
there's also going to be on click
similar to what we're going to have on a
button but for the time being why don't
we just copy and paste the links and
we'll worry about the functionality in
next video so now just copy and paste
and the first one will be to the recipes
so we just need to change the two prop
of course and then the same goes here
for the value we go with recipes and
notice how this one doesn't have the
color but the moment we navigate the
recipes of course now we have that color
applied to this specific link
then we'll copy and paste
two more times i believe so we have tags
and about and the contact one is going
to be a bit different because if you
take a look at the complete project
it has a different styling so for time
being let's just copy and paste two
times
so we have one
two homepage
then the second one we have i believe
it was what it was for the recipes of
course and then we have one for about
and then we have tags as well
so let's scroll up so we have home
recipes
then let's add those tags
and then of course
the path also is going to be to the tags
and that eventually why don't we set up
here about
and then as far as the text it is also
going to be about so once we save there
it is we have more links now
and everything looks pretty cool and now
of course we just need to add that
contact link as well and i want to place
that content link in a div and it's
going to have class of nav link
as well as contact link
and again this is just for different
styling and then we're gonna have a link
and then again to prop so this will
still direct you the contact page so
we're gonna go to
and then contact now i do want to add a
class name of btn and then eventually
again there's going to be on click but
we're not going to worry about it right
now and then let's just add a contact
and that should do it now we have a nice
looking navbar and if you want to test
it out on a bigger screen
let's just refresh again custom page
okay awesome that's our error one and
this is the look on small screen again
we right away showcase them eventually
we'll have the toggle functionality and
then once the screen size gets bigger
now using css we'll hide the button and
we'll also change the layout of our link
so that's the look on a small screen
without the toggle and then this is
going to be a look on a big screen one
last thing that i like to mention
normally in my project i don't like
hard-coding my links so normally i set
them up as some kind of array
in a different file and then just
iterate over however for our first
project i thought that's going to be an
overkill so don't worry we will do that
in a later project but in this project i
just thought that it's going to be a bit
easier for all of us if we hardcode them
again biggest takeaways this is just a
straight up react approach where we
import a image and then we set up the
source for the image tag and then as far
as the icon i just placed the inside of
the button all right we're done with the
simple navbar return so now of course
let's set up the functionality and if
you take a look at the main css you'll
notice that for now links by default
they're actually hidden so the height is
zero and overflow is hidden and only if
we have this class of show links then we
add a height and of course at the moment
we're doing that manually
so for example if i remove show links
we're not going to see the links but if
i add them back up and of course we can
see them again
now the idea is that we'll set up a
state value here using use state and
then we'll just toggle it so based on
that value we'll either show links or
height links and before we continue let
me just stress something i fully aware
that this is technically cheating
because i'm hard-coding the height
meaning if we'll change the amount of
links we have of course css will also be
affected now if you took my react course
you probably worked on the projects and
you know that in one of the projects we
actually covered how we can make this
dynamic however
for the gatsby tutorial i thought that
it is going to be an overkill so i just
thought that this is going to be a
easier setup and back in navbar first i
want to get a use state hook from react
so we're going to go with use state and
then i just want to set up that toggle
value and i'm going to go with const and
i'm just going to go with show and set
show and that will be equal to use state
and then by default it is going to be
false and now of course i need to scroll
down where i have the nav links and i
need to make this dynamic so instead of
adding both classes right away i'm going
to go back to the javascript land and
i'll say if show is true and as you can
see i'm setting up the ternary operator
i'm going to go with nav links as well
as showings so if the value is true then
i have both classes if not then i'm just
going to have the nav links class so now
links class over here and then once i
save of course links are hidden so now
our job is of course to add on clicks on
the button as well as the links and i'll
show you why i want to add on the links
as well so here let's go with on click
click now we do need to set up of course
here the arrow function otherwise it's
going to run instantly so i set up my
arrow function and we go with set show
and then whatever is the value in the
state we'll just pass in the opposite so
i take my function and then whatever is
the current show value i just pass in
the opposite and that way we get the
toggle functionality so now of course
once i click check it out now of course
we can see the links so we check the
state value and if it is true then i
have both classes if not then there's
only one now why do i want to add on
click on my links as well well because
on a small screen what i want is the
moment i click on one of the links so
basically the moment i navigate to one
of these pages i just want to hide those
links i think that's a better setup so
here we simply need to copy our on click
keep on scrolling keep on scrolling and
then this is going to be our first link
the home one and then we go set show but
in this case i don't want to pass in the
opposite i simply want to pass in the
false because i know that
i can only click on those links if the
navbar is already open basically if i
can see those links so now of course we
grab this value
and just copy and paste so one by one we
just add it to all the links now
technically if you don't want that
functionality you don't have to add the
same click but in my case i'm going to
do that so let's keep on scrolling and
then all the way in the bottom we have
the contact one as well copy and paste
and we're in good shape where we also
have the toggle functionality so now
once i click on tags check it out
not only i navigate to the tax page but
i also hide the links and then if we
take a look on a big screen notice this
is going to be our navbar of course
notice how we're adding this class
dynamically
using the gatsby goodies and then once
we go to the small screen of course
there is our button and then like i said
if you want to take a look at the css
you can check it out how i'm hiding
right away button on a big screen and it
only appears on a small screen that
should do it for navbar and now of
course we can start talking about images
in gatsby all right we're done with the
simple components and next i want to
cover how gatsby handles images
and if we're being honest in a typical
web project images can be a real pain
and oftentimes are solely responsible
for slow load times and bad user
experience but fear not
gatsby is here to save the day and
before we start tapping away let me just
demonstrate some of the goodies gatsby
offers straight out of the box so i'm
currently staring at the complete
project
and i'm going to go to the dev tools and
more specifically network tab and you
know what i'm gonna make my sites lower
and i'm gonna go with 3g so i'll refresh
and you'll notice something pretty
pretty cool
where check it out gatsby actually
preserves the size of the image so you
don't get that annoying jump
because you know that if browser is
waiting for the image but there's some
content underneath it then the content
first is on top and then when the image
comes in then of course everything is
pushed down because now of course the
space is taken by the image so that's
number one number two
notice the nice placeholder that i have
40 images so i have this nice svg
placeholder pattern and then while the
image is loading the user sees the
placeholder
but then the moment image loads then of
course the image is displayed then if we
take a look at the elements
we'll see something even more nifty so
i'm going to go to the elements and
we're going to take a look at the page
and then more specifically section
recipes container so i'm looking here
and then recipes list so i just want to
showcase these three images so
this row
and in here you can see that okay all of
them are links that's fine but we also
can see this div now this is going to be
a wrapper div so effectively when we'll
work with gatsby image plugin that's the
plugin we're about to use
it wraps our images in this wrapper and
then if we inspect this wrapper even
more we can notice the picture tag so we
have this picture element and also we
have a source element and more
specifically source set attribute now if
you're not familiar with source elements
in short they provide different sources
for the browser to choose from so gatsby
created multiple sizes of the same image
we can see it over here again in the
source set notice this is the same image
but gatsby provided multiple sizes
then browser pricks whichever size makes
the most sense and a result we are not
forcing a huge images on smaller screens
so think smaller devices and what's
super super super nifty we get all of
these and other goodies with very little
config we simply pass a path to the
gatsby component and we're good to go
yes that's how easy it is and lastly i
just want to mention if you're
interested in learning more about
responsive images essentially all this
gibberish that is written here i highly
suggest this resource so go to your
search engine just type responsive image
mdn then follow this link and in this
well written article you'll find about
all the benefits
that the picture element the source
element as well as source set feature
provide okay in next video we're going
to install gatsby plugin image but
before we do that i want to create a
little sandbox where i can demonstrate
some of the features side by side now
this is optional
eventually it's not going to be part of
our project
and i'm simply setting this up so later
if you ever need to you can go back and
find the reference if you don't feel
like setting up the examples component
just kick back relax and watch me
struggle and since i don't want to over
populate our current project
what i'm going to do is just open up my
sidebar
and then in the examples i'll create
another one i'll create the
images component and then i'll render it
i guess in homepage because it's just
going to be easier as far as navigating
around my project and then once we're
done setting up the examples of course
i'll just remove it from the homepage
but the images component of course is
going to stay here so if you ever need
to you can go back
and take a look at the reference so
in the examples like i said new file
let me zoom in and i'll call this images
js
all right awesome then i'll create a new
component of course and it's going to be
called images
and for starters i guess i'm just going
to get styled components because i'll
add a little bit of styling over here so
i'm going to go with import styled from
let me close the sidebar and of course
style components i will call this
wrappers a const
wrapper is equal to styled and again it
doesn't really matter but i'm going to
go with section here and then let's just
add this wrapper like so and then let's
just add a text with i don't know
heading 2
and let's just say gatsby
image let's save this let's just list it
out whether we can see it in home page
so i'm going to navigate of course to my
index.js i'm looking for import one for
images from
and you guessed it of course we go to
examples then we go to images folder and
right below or above doesn't really
matter in this case we're just gonna go
with our images component okay we save
it and then of course i have my gatsby
images we are in good shape but i'm
gonna do something a bit extra where i'm
going to go to the pixels to one of the
awesome websites you can get nice images
and i'm just going to download a massive
image again
this is optional you don't have to do
that but i just want to demonstrate how
the typical project
is going to look like so let's go back
and i'm going to open up a new tab i'll
say pixels
and then once it finally opens for some
reason
it just decided to quit on me i guess
i'm gonna go with food
and then i'll pick any of these images
so i'll pick the first one and i
purposely go in with original size so i
want to get this massive image let's do
a free download
then i'm gonna go to my downloads and i
just need to find the sucker somewhere
here
and i'm gonna call this a big and then
let's just say big you can add image if
you want but i'm just gonna leave it as
big so i'll move it out
and then of course i want to place it in
my source in the assets and in the
images so and drag and drop
and let's just first right away check
the size for the sucker so i'm going to
go here and notice
it is
2.5 megabytes that's good to know and
now let's see how that is going to look
like in traditional project so let me
remove this tab i guess we won't need it
anymore we simply go to our images
since this is going to be our sandbox
and i'll say import big that's the name
and then i'm looking in the assets
then more specifically images and then i
go with big and i believe the extension
was jpg and now above the heading 2 i
just want to display that image so i'm
going to go here with img
source
and big
and as far as the alt let's just say
food
and once we save of course we can see
the image
but just to hammer my point home
i'm gonna go with image so i'm selecting
all the images that i have in the
wrapper and i'm gonna go with width of
200 pixels so technically using css i
will make it smaller correct so now of
course the size of my image is smaller
but here's the million dollar question
does that mean that we'll be sending a
smaller amount of bytes over the wire
since we know that our image is actually
massive or we'll be still sending 2.5
megabytes well i don't know let's test
it out so i'm going to go to the bigger
browser window and of course i'll
refresh okay first we definitely see
this jump we see that while the image is
still loading
we have this gatsby image underneath the
homepage but then once we're done then
of course we push it down so that's the
jump that i'm talking about and the
second thing well let's see the size of
it i'm gonna go with inspect then i'm
gonna go to network i guess i'm just
gonna right away go for images refresh
and surprise surprise so even though in
my css i set up my image to be 200
pixels
i'm still sending 2.5 megabytes over the
wire and i fully understand that you can
make a reasonable argument that it's
probably not the wisest choice to use
these type of images to begin with with
such sizes and i get it
understand this is just for
demonstration i just want you to see
the difference when we use gatsby image
plugin
beautiful once i have my image sandbox
in place
next i want to install gatsby image
plugin now if you were not following on
with the previous video
you do have to follow along with this
one so make sure you do install the
plugin otherwise
when we'll need to add the images to our
about as well as home and setting them
up with headless cms
nothing is going to work and of course
we already know where we need to go we
need to go to gatsby site then we're
looking for plugins but there's a major
major catch do not do not install this
one gadsby image because this one is
with version 2. so when the version 3
came out they rolled out a new plugin
and the plugin you're looking for is
gatsby plugin image even though this one
has more downloads again the reason for
that is because this was used in version
two now in version three they rolled out
a new plugin so bravely either search
for it here
or just click it it's going to be
probably one of the top plugins and once
we navigate here you can probably right
away open up the link the gatsby image
plugin reference so i'm going to open
this up in a new tab we will use it
quite extensively in following videos
and then let's start with an install so
i'll just copy this whole line of code
and then i'm going to go over why we
have that many plugins so let me go back
to our project and stop the dev server
clear everything copy and paste and just
like with our previous plugin the styled
components one we actually have multiple
plugins so basically we get the gatsby
plugin image okay
then we have two
that are providing all the goodies so we
have plugin sharp and transformer shop
and then we have one for the file system
now we'll cover this plugin more
extensively a bit later when we start
setting up the queries but this plugin
is responsible for interacting with a
file system and this is a pattern that
you'll see quite often
where just like npm dependencies they
have dependencies on their own so the
same works with gatsby plugins
effectively we have the main plugin
where we're going to get our components
that we're going to use but of course
this plugin depends on some other ones
as well so that's why we need to install
all of them and as far as gatsby config
like i said we will cover the source
file system
more extensively later so that's when
we'll actually set it up as object in
this case you don't need to even set it
up in gatsby config you simply want to
add plug-in image plug-in sharp and
transformer shop so grab all of these
suckers here one by one and notice how
none of them are set up as object
they're simply strings
we navigate here and then of course we
need to go to the gatsby config like so
and we already have plugin styled
components okay awesome
then just add a comma and copy and paste
so let's save this one and now let's go
with npm
and start let's spin up our project if
we don't have some massive red errors in
a terminal we are in good shape and we
have successfully installed gatsby image
plugin nice and once the plugin is in
place now let's take a look at our
options so if we keep reading the plugin
documentation
we can see that gatsby image provides
two components and those components are
static image and gatsby image now gatsby
image is used for dynamic images and
we'll use it later
when we fetch our data from the headless
cms and the static one as the name
already suggests
is used for static images so basically
those are the images that will be the
same each time the component is used and
a good example
is our hero so this one in home page
then the same goes for about but then
when we'll be fetching
recipes
from the contentful will be iterating
over our recipes and every time we'll
call that gatsby image that image is
going to be dynamic now don't worry the
setup for both of them
is extremely similar the only difference
is that with gatsby image we just grab
the data from the query something we
haven't covered yet but as far as the
customizations i mean the setup will be
extremely similar so for now let's put
the pen on the gatsby image
let's work with a static image but i can
guarantee you once you understand how
static images work you'll have no
problem switching to the gadsb1 instead
so again let's go back
this is the documentation and we simply
need to import static image from gatsby
plugin image so similar how we imported
link from gatsby in this case we have
gatsby image plugin or plugin image i
guess more correctly and we're importing
this component static image and then we
just need to provide a path
in the source
and what's interesting we have two
options
we can either provide a local file so
that's why under the hood it uses that
source file system plugin that we
covered in the last video or we can
actually provide the url so that's also
cool where we can provide an external
route but again the main idea with the
static one is the fact that the image
will be the same each time the component
is used so i guess the only thing that's
left to do is take it out for test drive
so i'll simply navigate back to my
project again i'm working in the images
example and then i want to import a
component again the name is static
and image
and then of course it is coming from
gatsby plugin image
and then i'm going to delete the big one
i don't think there's any need for it we
just need to go with static image
then the source prop and again we need
to provide a path to the image so since
i want to speed this up a little bit i'm
just going to copy and paste again this
points back to the same image
and then the second thing we need to
provide is alt prop and here we provide
a text explanation of the image so we
save and then check it out we right away
get this image however now it is wrapped
in that gatsby image wrapper with all
those goodies so if you want to test it
out we can navigate back to the big
browser and i'm going to be in the
homepage and notice how we don't get the
jump we right away get the placeholder
now we don't have the svg yet don't
worry we'll set it up in a second but we
already have all those goodies the
moment we provide the path and if you
want to see even more cool things then
just navigate to the network
again you're looking probably for the
images or you can look for all and then
just look for the image check out the
size
is this 2.5 megs no it's not of course
it is much smaller so right away without
doing any extra work just by passing the
path
into the static image component we are
in good shape we get all these extra
benefits and just to showcase that we
can use also external images
i'm gonna go to my course api site and
essentially this is the site where i
provide all the apis for my courses and
i'm gonna look for the slides this is
where i keep the external images
and again you can choose any of them
in my case i think i'm going to go with
this one then copy and paste the url
then back in the project copy and paste
the static image so let's set up two of
them and of course i'll provide that new
path and as far as the food well it's
not going to be food it is going to be
code and once we save it of course we
can see that we get our image and before
we take a look at the various
customization options we have
with the static image as well as the
gatsby image i quickly want to mention
that there are restrictions on how we
can use static image
and this is the case where we're going
to switch from the plugin docs to the
actual documentation so just go to the
docs and then we have to we have
reference guide as well as how-to guide
so in this case i'm gonna look for the
reference guide and then more
specifically we're looking for gatsby
plugin api and essentially it's gonna be
the same link that i opened when we
navigated to the plug-in dock so it's
the same place and basically keep on
scrolling keep on scrolling these are
shared props which we're going to cover
in the next video i just want to show
you the restrictions so notice where
they say this does not work and
effectively we cannot provide this path
as a prop so you cannot go back to the
images and then set up a prop where
you're going to be getting the path and
then pass it from the home page that
does not work that's not how you can
use the static image and also what we
cannot do is get some kind of prop value
because like i said in the next video we
will cover the props and how we can use
the props to customize our image
but as far as the values for these props
they have to be in the same file
so you cannot get them from somewhere
outside so basically both
the path to the image as well as the
value for the props need to be set in
the same component so you cannot just
randomly get this value from somewhere
else and expect that everything is going
to work now you can add some dynamic
features for example in here they say
how you can calculate the height yeah
that is allowed but notice all these
values are still here they are still
within the same file it's not like
you're getting them from somewhere else
and once we have covered restrictions
now let's take a look at the props we
can provide
and how we can customize our image
nice hopefully we are good with
restrictions
so now let's scroll back up
and first let's take a look at the
shared props and like i mentioned before
the following props can be passed to
both
gat the image which we're going to use a
little bit later as well as the static
image
and we may also pass just any valid
image that props that is also a option
because at the end of the day there is
the image element somewhere inside of
that wrapper and then as far as the
shared props we have alternative
actually e is required so if you won't
pass it there's going to be a warning
that's just for alternative text we also
have as
prop where we can change that element if
you remember initially when we set it up
it was a div that wrapper but you can
set it as a section as an article or
whatever we have a loading one by
default it is going to be lazy
now if you want you can set it to eager
as well then we have two class names
one is going to be for the wrapper so if
you set up class name and then i don't
know about img
that about img class is going to be
added to the wrapper
and then if you go with img class name
prop instead then of course this class
will be added to the image and
effectively that just allows you to
avoid all the hacking you simply add
those class names and then you can
target them from the css we can add
inline css again this is going to be for
the wrapper in line css
and this is going to be for the image
then we have a background color if we
ever want to which is going to be
applied for the wrapper as well as
object fit and object position okay
hopefully we're good with the props and
don't worry of course we'll use it in
examples as well so i'll just leave it
at that and let's just keep on scrolling
and now we have image option and like i
previously mentioned yes there are some
differences of how we can pass in those
options and it's simply because
for the static one effectively we're
hard coding we just set up the component
and we pass it in we as a dynamic one
will be getting that data using graphql
and of course it will make way more
sense once we get there and options
itself we have a layout which probably
is going to be the most important one
because with this option we'll determine
how the image is going to be resizing
basically we have fixed option we have
full width and we have constraint and as
you can see again we have some defaults
so the image that we currently have
is actually constrained because that is
the default now the only thing why
they're so small because if you remember
i added in a wrapper the css so that's
why the size of them is 200
and as far as the other ones we have
aspect ratio
we have width and height so of course
you can imagine that you can control the
width and the height of the image this
is the placeholder one remember
the svg pattern or dominant color or
there's also a blur option well this is
where we can control that and by default
it's going to be dominant color then we
have multiple formats and of course you
can experiment with that but in my
experience the default setup works
really well as well as transform options
and then if we keep on scrolling keep on
scrolling then notice we have the layout
one and again this probably will be the
most important one that's why they have
a awesome awesome visual representation
so notice the first one obviously is
going to be the fixed one and that one
stays fixed regardless of the screen
size but when we take a look at the
constrained one and full width the
difference is following where full width
is always going to be the size of the
container regardless
whether we're talking about the phone
screen or we're talking about the
desktop
now with the constrained one
yes it is going to be the size of the
parent container however
once the container gets bigger than the
image then of course it will just
maintain the original size
now that should do it for the theory
part
now let's apply this knowledge in our
sandbox
beautiful and once we're familiar with
our options now let's navigate back to
the images
and i think at this point i can just
remove big for good
so my big image
and then i'll do a bit more house
cleaning
where i'm going to go with different
image
just because i want to show you
something regarding the constraint
layout so you know what at this point
i'll remove everything i'll just set up
wrap or clean and instead i'm going to
go with static image i'm going to go
with the source and then pick one of the
recipes once so i'm going to go with
recipe 1 but just go with these ones
since they are not that big and that way
we'll see features of the constraint
layout so i'm going to go to source
again i need to provide the path i'm
going with assets here images and then
the file name is a recipe hyphen one and
a jpeg now as far as the alternative i
think we can go back to food
here
and then i'll save it for time being
okay notice if you get this technically
error once in a while don't worry about
it
just close it and then refresh now of
course we have our image
now i want to remove this css selection
and we're not going to use it and then
inside of the wrapper eventually we'll
set up a three column layout where i'll
show you the fixed one the full width as
well as the constraint one side by side
for now in this video we'll just work
with the constraint one and that's why
i'll set up here a heading four with the
text of constrained
and then default so we know that that's
the default setup so once i save check
it out
now of course the image is much bigger
because we're not targeting from the css
correct
and i guess let's start adding those
options to our static image and again we
simply need to provide them as props so
let's do it we can go with the height
and i can say
400 and the moment i set it up again
unfortunately there's going to be this
tiny error there for a while and then we
get the image so that works we know that
we can add the height now if you want
you can add the width as well
just keep in mind when you set width and
height for constraint you're actually
setting max width and max type
not fixed values
so if you want fixed values you might as
well go for fixed layout instead
but yes if you want i can add 100 pixels
here and save it now of course my image
is going to be
smaller like so so we refresh so now i
have a tiny image
that's good
i guess i'm just going to remove it and
then we have remember a placeholder
so this is the pattern that we can show
while the image is loading and in here
we have blurred we have dominant color
we have none
as well as traced svg and if you
remember dominant color was the default
one so in this case i'm gonna go with
traced svg don't worry we will cover the
other ones later as well
then i'm going to set up a layout just
keep in mind that constraint is already
default so i'll just showcase how that
works we're going to go with constraint
but as far as our logic well nothing is
going to change it's still constrained
so it doesn't really matter and then
eventually i just want to showcase how
we can add the class name and i'm just
going to go with example img and if you
remember
this class will be added to our
container and you know what why don't we
try one more
remember the as prop
let's keep on scrolling that was the
options one
and here we had as so why don't we try
this one why don't we say as and i'm
going to set it up as a section so we're
going to go here with a section so i
have an article inside of the article i
have heading 4 and then i have my static
image and as far as the styling well i'm
just going to add some border so you can
clearly see how the constrained one
works so i'm going to go with width now
this is for the whole wrapper and we'll
set it up as 70
of the screen width and we'll add some
margins here
zero auto so it's always going to be in
the center and then we're going to go
with article
basically i want to style the article
and for some reason it's just a tag
that's not what i wanted so i'm going to
go with article and then i just want to
add the border and then you'll clearly
see how the constraint
and full width option work
and we're going to go with two pixels
solid
and let's go with the red because why
not
and then of course i also want to add a
little bit of styling to this class
because remember we add this class to
the container so why don't we use it and
in this case i'm just going to add some
border radius to my image so let's go
with example and then hyphen img
and we're going to go with border radius
and let's go with one rem now i think
it's going to be easier
if we take a look at on a big screen
so let's navigate there localhost 8000
we can refresh now eventually i will
open up the devtools but i just want to
showcase how it's going to look like on
a small screen so on a small screen
notice how the image is spanning
exactly the size of the container let me
see my zoom number yeah it is 175
but then
the moment container
gets bigger than the max size of the
constraint image
so effectively once the container is
bigger than the image then of course we
just use the width of the image so that
is going to be the difference between
the constraint one and full width full
width is always going to be full width
regardless now the constrained one
unless you set up the width
it's basically going to be dependent on
a parent
but the moment parent actually gets
bigger notice of course at this point
the parent is bigger
then of course we just go with the width
of the image you can clearly see the
border radius which we applied using the
class name and of course we selected it
here
in the css and if you want to take a
look at the other options for example
placeholder i'll simply navigate back to
my browser i will refresh and there is
you can clearly see the placeholder
pattern more specifically traced svg
and what's more interesting
if we start drilling down we have a
section
now keep in mind this is my style
component one that's the one that i
created and we keep going down down down
and then of course we have the article
and then what do we have inside of this
article well we have a section now why
do we have it as a section
well simply because that is the value
that i provided
for my as pro
and then as you can see we have some
classes here we have gatsby image
wrapper and then we also have gatsby
image wrapper constraint so i guess they
add this class if the image is
constrained and then of course i have my
own one i have my example img and then
of course whatever css i applied
notice how it is added to my wrapper
and that's how we can set up options in
the gatsby image
beautiful and to really hammer this home
why don't we set up two more articles
with different layouts so that way we
can see them side by side and i guess
i'm just going to start with a bit of
house cleaning i'll remove the height
for the time being
from my static image
and then also
i want to add a little bit of css here
in my wrapper so width will stay the
same margin 0 auto that stays the same
or i'll set it up as a display grid so
display grid and we're going to go with
text line center as well so text
align
and we're going to align it in the
center
and then we'll also add some gap in
between our columns and rows and that's
why we'll go with gap and then two rems
and also at the very very bottom
why don't we set up a media query
media so once we get to the i don't know
so min with
992
i'm gonna go with a three column layout
so 992 pixels and then once we get there
grid template columns and let's just go
with one fraction one fraction
as well as one fraction okay awesome
that should do it for the css and now i
just need to copy and paste
and then like i said i'll change the
layout values so that way you can see
the fixed one you can see the full width
one and all that and also we'll change
the placeholder one as well so let's
take the whole thing so the article copy
and paste two more times now for the
second one i'll set it up as fixed
so i'll change the text as well now
alternative will stay the same as far as
the placeholder if you want to go back
to the suggestions just remove
everything and then once you add the
quotation mark notice again these are
the options i'm going to go with blurred
in this case now as far as the layout
well i don't want to constrain right so
that was my default instead i'm going to
go with fixed and then with fixed if you
add just width height will be
automatically calculated but if you want
to be more specific of course just add
the height and that value will be set as
the height for the image
so in my example i'm going to go with
200 just notice how you need to set up
the curly's here so that's not a string
that you're passing in here you're
passing in the number i'll leave the
class name as it is because i still want
that border radius and i guess it's not
going to be a section in this case we're
just going to go with div now i don't
know whether i'm going to go and check
whether i actually have the div but
hopefully you get the point now i think
i made a tiny bug where
fix one is actually all the way at the
bottom so let me remove and i'll place
it in between again it doesn't really
matter but i just like to keep things in
order so there we have fixed one and
then last one will be our full width
again same deal same image as far as
traced svg
or remember that by default we have a
dominant color correct so we can use
that one as well keep in mind
technically i can just omit it i'm just
showcasing what is the name of the value
here
and then as far as the layout well let's
go with full width so we're going to go
with full width example image class yep
that stays the same
and i don't know this can be an article
maybe
so let's save what we have
and then we're going to navigate to the
bigger browser window
and of course notice since i added the
article it also added right away the
border because if you remember
here i have a css selection for the
article so since i render this as an
article that's why we have that extra
border and then notice something
interesting so on a small screen
they're exactly the same right and by
the way i didn't change the text in this
one and just say full width here
basically they're the same they're
spanning
the size of the container but
if you keep making it bigger bigger
bigger at some point what is going to
happen
this one well the container is going to
get bigger now in our case we cannot
really see that because we have that at
992.
so why don't we change this around just
so you can see clearly so let me comment
this out for a second
and at this point i guess this one is
just spanning all across so let me make
this smaller and now you can clearly see
so this is going to be my image with
constraint and this is going to be the
full width so full width
always spans across
regardless of the screen size now the
constrained one again is going to be
dependent on a parent but the moment
parent gets bigger then of course we
just render the image as it is and fixed
one pretty self-explanatory notice
whatever size we pass it in the height
gets calculated and we're in good shape
now if you want to add the height as
well
let's just keep scrolling back and we're
going to go with height and i don't know
maybe 600 like so so add this one and of
course this is my image now if you
refresh notice this is going to be the
traced svg and as i said i think in this
case we'll have to slow down the network
a bit i'm going to go with three fast 3g
hopefully you'll be able to see all of
them
so we're going to go here
this is going to be i believe the
blurred one
and we already covered the dominant
color so i think we're mostly interested
in the blur look so notice this is going
to be that placeholder while the image
is loading so essentially these are our
options and as we're progressing with
the project of course we'll use those
images and now you already know what
options you have when it comes to props
so if you want to use different options
in your project so if you don't want to
follow along with my options feel free
to do so and you'll be in good shape i
think at this point we have good initial
understanding how we can pass props and
options into our static image component
but before we start setting up images in
our simple recipes project i also want
to cover width and height for
constrained layout versus the fixed one
and how we cannot pass the height for
the full width one
and what in my opinion is a niftier
solution when we deal with height for
constraint and full width now i know
that there's a lot to unpack so let's
start with width and height for
constraint versus the fixed one so if we
go to the gatsby docs and if we keep on
scrolling
notice here we have width and height and
what they're saying here that for the
fixed layout
these define the size of the image
displayed on a screen however when we
talk about the constrained one
these define the maximum size so that's
the biggest difference that's why i'm
saying that for the constrained one it
will be the size of the container but
once the container size gets bigger than
the maximum size that's why you see that
space in between so that's number one
number two if i go back and for example
add a height for the static image
everything is great and in my case i'm
gonna go for 300. now i'll remove the
height for the fixed one i think it's
getting quite busy in the browser and if
i'll try to do the same thing for the
full width one i'm actually gonna have a
big fat complaint
in a browser so let me navigate back
this is my local
and then once i refresh
check it out i have a error basically
tells me that failed prop type height
300 may not be passed when layout is
full width so that's something to be
aware of yes you can pass in the max
height for constraint one remember for
constraint one width and height are max
values yes we can do that however for
the full width one well
that's not allowed so what would be a
solution if i want to have height for
both of them for full width as well as
the constrained one well a niftier
solution in my opinion is using this
example img because in here i can kill
two birds at the same time first
if i add here this max height i cannot
really control it when i add this height
4 constraint i add 300 and that's it
essentially it's set in stone however if
i add the height for my class for the
example image
not only i can control it depending on
screen size but i can also control my
full width so let's keep on scrolling
i'll add my media query back up and then
notice this example mg why don't we set
it up this way where i'm going to go
with height and then
300
that's gonna be on a small screen and
then once we get to the bigger screen
i'm gonna make it smaller so i'm gonna
go with height and we'll set it up as
200 pixels so let's save the sucker and
then once we move to a bigger browser
window notice the difference and as a
side note this one is just lower because
of the text so let me go back
and fix it because it's important that
you see
that both of them actually behave
exactly the same way
so notice the difference
yeah of course on a small screen size we
have the height correct we have the
height that we set over here and that
one was 300 but then the moment screen
size is gonna get bigger notice how
we're gonna have this 200 now i'll zoom
out so you'll definitely see so this is
going to be the 200 one
and then once we go to the smaller
screen size of course the height is
going to be 300. again that's just my
approach of fixing the height issue
where once you add the height to the
class a i can control it on multiple
screen sizes so depending on the screen
size i can control that value and you
can also add that height to the full
width image because notice without using
that prop i can actually control the
height of the full width one as well
nice i think we have a solid
understanding of how static image works
and now let's put it to good use by
adding some images to our simple recipes
project
and i guess i'm going to start with
about page so if we navigate to complete
project we can see that this probably is
going to be a static image
as well as in the about page so where do
we start here and then next video we'll
work on homepage
now i do want to keep my project
somewhat clean
so in the pages
i'll start by removing the images
component again you always know where to
find the reference
and i'm not sure maybe later i will get
the link back but for the time being i
don't want that warning in a console in
the terminal so remove it as well and
then of course we want to navigate to
about page and first i guess let's start
by changing the name here
and what i mean is i want to capitalize
it because that's the proper setup for
react component
and then we're going to go with our
static image of course we do need to
import it so we're going to go with
import and then i'm looking for static
and image and that is coming from
of course
gatsby plugin image
so we have our static image
then i want to import link because we
will set up a link to the contact page
and eventually we'll add some more
imports but not for time being so we're
going to go with import then we're
looking for a link and again this is
coming from
gatsby this time so we go with gatsby
here all right that's awesome
then inside of the layout we will set up
main so let's go with a main tags we'll
add a little bit of css so add a class
name of page here and then there's going
to be a section with a class of about
page so let's go with section and then
the class is about
page and effectively we'll have two
articles one for the text and then the
second one
is going to be a static image now when i
say articles i mean two columns so one
column is going to be an article and the
second column will be my static image so
again if we navigate to a complete
project i'm going to say that
this is going to be the text side of it
and then on the right hand side we
basically have the image and again i can
always make it smaller and you'll see
that this is going to be look on a small
screen
and then this is going to be the look on
a big screen let's navigate here and i
guess let's start with the text like i
said i'll just group everything in the
article in this case there's going to be
a heading 2
and also i'll add two more paragraphs
now i'll copy and paste the text to
speed it up but i'm just showing you the
structure so heading two then two
paragraphs and then like i said i also
want to make a link
to a contact page so link to
and then as far as the address well we
go to the contact page so i pass in the
path here correct and then of course i
want to have some kind of text so
contact and then let's also add a class
name so let's write here button again
this just comes from the css i just add
a little bit of styling to my link so
i'll save it here and probably
it would make way more sense if in the
browser i would be in contact page and
there it is now as far as the text like
i said i'll just speed this up i don't
see
the point of typing everything together
i mean you probably have way better
things to do so copy and paste
and the last one as well okay
that's awesome i mean we have the text
and now like i said two column layout
this is important because i already have
the css of course so i have article this
is where the text is sitting and now of
course i want to set up my static image
okay
so side by side with my article i'm
going to go with static image and now
first we know that we have a source prop
correct so we go with source and as far
as which image i want to show well i
want the about
jpeg that's it now if you want a
different one if you want to download
your own i mean feel free to do that so
we're going to go with source
and again i'm navigating to the assets
now i guess one annoying thing here
is that it doesn't show any suggestions
you know that when you're working with
imports here it right away auto
completes it for you in this case it is
not happening so we go with assets then
forward slash then we go with images and
then the image name about
jpeg
now as far as the alternative i just
took the info from the image so it says
there person pouring
salt
in ball that's it again i didn't make
this one up
that's in the info of the image and now
let's close our static image
and then eventually we'll add two more
class names so let's save it for now we
should have this giant image okay that's
good
and if we can see it in a big browser as
well
then we are in good shape so we do have
the two column layout but as you can see
we do need to apply a little bit of css
because it's probably not the look that
you're shooting for yes
looks somewhat okay on a small screen
but once the screen size gets bigger
then of course we just have this giant
image and we already know how to do that
we know that we can apply a class name
right and the way i set up the css there
is a class by the name of about img so
in this case i'm going out class name so
remember we're adding this class
to the wrapper
not the image to the wrapper and we go
with about img and then as far as the
placeholder well why don't we try out
the blurred one again my favorite
is the traced svg but once in a while i
like the blurred one e instead so
let's navigate now to the bigger browser
and what do you know of course we nicely
have two column layout where we have the
text and image side-by-side again i can
make this smaller
and you'll see how it looks on a small
screen and then once i make my screen
says bigger
we have our two column layout and then
as far as the css it's pretty typical
css
and probably the fastest way how you can
find the styles
is by navigating to main css and then
again the command is command and f
and you get the search window and then
just look for about and probably the
most interesting thing here is the setup
for the about img since we just covered
how we can add those classes to the
static image so notice how i have this
about emg and first let me just showcase
that is going to be added of course to
my wrapper so there it is once i
navigate here notice the class names i
have about img so that's for my wrapper
and then i set up the height for the
small screen in this case i go with 500
pixels i also add this border radius
and then if you keep scrolling notice
the media query so my about page so the
parent for both
for the text article as well as my
static image
it's actually a grid so we set it up as
display grid and then once we get to 992
i set up two column layout
and then i set up the height for the
whole about page as 400 pixels and then
for my static image i just say height
100
meaning set your height based on a
parent so if this parent is going to be
i don't know 800 then of course my image
is going to be 800. now if the height is
going to be smaller then of course my
image is going to be smaller as well so
hopefully you get the gist unlike the
previous video where i hard coded based
on a screen size so remember i set one
pixel value for the smaller screen size
and then added media query and set the
pixel value for the bigger one in this
case yes i hard code for the small
screen
where it is 500 but then once i have
that two column layout i want to set my
height based on a parent and if we
navigate back and in this case i'll zoom
out just so you can see better
and i guess i'm gonna look for my about
img and then notice what happens if i
remove that height of 100. so of course
now this image is bigger now it is that
500 correct and then once we remove the
500 as well now it's even bigger again
that's something nifty you can do it's
not part of official gatsby
documentation
but again the idea is that instead of
adding that prop you can simply set up
the class on the wrapper and then that
way you can control it way better
because you can add all kinds of nifty
css and then in this case we are
actually setting our image height based
on the parent and once we're done with
about page why don't we tackle the home
page as well now eventually there are
going to be more things in the home page
if you take a look at the complete
project you can see not only we have the
hero image with some text but of course
we'll also have the tags for the recipes
as well as the recipes itself but for
the time being let's just focus on this
image and then of course once we learn
how to fetch data and set up that data
in our headless cms the contentful in
our case
then of course we'll knock out these two
suckers as well so
i think i'm gonna clean my workspace
first
and i'm just gonna close all my tabs
okay that's good and then in the
index.js
okay i have the react i have the layout
that's good i think i can close the
search for now and then as far as the
imports
well
i just want to get my static image right
so i'm going to go with import and then
i'm looking for static
and image again it's coming from
and gatsby plugin image
good and as far as the return yes i'll
still have the layout that stays the
same and again i want to go with main
tags and i want the class name of page
and then inside of the main i'm just
going to go with my header and the class
name will be hero so header and a class
name is hero now instead of this hero
i'm gonna have two things i'm gonna have
my static image with a layout on full
width so we can keep on practicing and
then the second thing is going to be my
text let's go first here with a static
image and then as far as the source well
i need to go to my files
and let's see i think i want to go with
the main one here so this guy
and again the path is following where we
go with two dots and we're looking in
the assets
and more specifically images and then we
go with
and jpeg
now that's good then i want to have the
alternative one and let's see what it is
i guess i don't know a flower
and eggs so let's just write eggs
so let's go here with eggs and then i
want to add a few more props so class
name again added to my wrapper we're
going to go with hero img
important for the styling then as far as
the placeholder i want to go with my
favorite one with traced svg and then as
far as the layout now i'm going to go
with full width one instead let's save
this one here
and now i want to test it out in a
browser it looks pretty good and then
like i said i also want to set up that
text and as far as the text
how i was able to set it up here in the
center well i'm doing that using the css
so first let me set it up and then i'll
go over what's happening in here so
we're going to go div with the class of
hero container
and then instead of it there's going to
be another div with a class of hero text
and then instead of this div this is
where we'll place a heading one with
some kind of text in my case simple
recipes
and then heading four and we just say no
fluff
no fluff
just recipes let's save that one now we
have a little bit of styling as well as
the text is sitting in the center so
let's take a look at the css
i'm going to go to main css again i'll
look for my dot hero
and then first of all notice how the
height is right away 100 percent so i'm
adding this class on the wrapper the
hero amg
and then i right away set the height to
be 100
why well because hero
my parent has the height of 40 percent
of the screen size so again
in this case i'm using the parent to
control the height of my image because i
add the class on the wrapper
and then i just set it equal to 100
now as far as how i was able to set this
text
on top of the image well the hero
container here is actually position
absolute so i take it out of normal flow
and i just set width and height equal to
100
and then since hero is a relative
essentially it's spanning all across the
hero and i add a little background
that's why you can see that it is darker
so if i remove it notice of course it's
going to be lighter now the reason why i
add that background is because i want to
see that white text better
and then of course you can also see that
we add a little bit of border radius so
we match to the one we have for the
image
and as far as how i was able to place
the text in the center well the hero
container is actually a display flex and
i just set my text e in the center by
using align items and justify content
that's about it if you want you can go
here and by the way i'm showing you the
complete one this is how it looks
currently in our project again if you
want you can inspect and you'll see all
the properties in action for example if
i remove my height now of course i have
this massive image that's the reason why
we need to set this height as 100
and then it depends on the parent and
the same goes for hero if you remove it
of course now just have this massive
image now if i'll set back my height to
be 40 percent of the screen size or if i
want it i don't know 30 then of course
it is going to be smaller hopefully this
makes sense i know
that i covered quite a bit of css but in
this case it is very important since
setting them up in the layouts is a big
part of working with images and i just
wanted to cover clearly my approaches
when setting up layouts using gatsby
images
awesome work on setting up the images
and next one up we have graphql or how
to work with data in gatsby
you see up to this point we have been
using standard react practices to access
our data in our gatsby project and while
there's technically nothing wrong with
that particular approach in essence
we're not utilizing all the awesome
features gadsby offers in order to
change that we will have to understand
how the gatsby data layer works in a
nutshell we'll learn how to load our
data directly into our components using
graphql if you are new to graphql i
fully understand that syntax might seem
a bit foreign and intimidating at first
but believe it or not once we'll get few
graphql queries under our belts i doubt
you'll want to go back to good old rest
api and actually at least in my opinion
gatsby makes it very easy to start with
graphql since a lot of complexities have
been removed and we really need to worry
about writing the queries since it is a
major major course on overall gatsby
topic here are a few of my suggestions
of how to tackle it and i guess i'll
start with this one whatever you do do
not throw in a towel or in other words
give up
and yes it is that simple look you can
only get better if you practice and
sometimes it just takes a bit of time to
get used to the syntax and logic behind
it second if my explanations are not
good or clear enough try gatsby
documentation like i have mentioned
already a few times they have awesome
and comprehensive docs so if necessary
try to utilize them i would also suggest
spending some time in graphical
just writing some queries and testing
results
and you can think of graphql as it is
also called as a sandbox for your
graphql queries since graphql is such a
major gatsby topic we will spend
multiple videos just practicing writing
queries testing results and only then
proceed to cover multiple ways of how we
can render our data also starting from
this video we spent a lot of time in our
sandbox and the url for this sandbox is
going to be http then localhost 8000
underscore underscore underscore and
then graphql now you can easily find the
url if you run gatsbydevelop and all the
way in the bottom you'll have two urls
one for the 8000 which of course
displays our project in the browser and
then the second one for the sandbox and
at this point you have two options we
can either command click which will
right away open up in a browser or we
can copy and paste the url now my
problem with command click is the fact
that it will open up the sandbox in a
smaller browser window and in my opinion
it's kind of hard to work in a smaller
browser window as you're working with a
sandbox i think you have a much more
clearer view of what is happening if
you're doing that in a bigger browser
window so in my case i will copy the url
like so
and then i'll navigate to my bigger
browser window open up a new tab
copy and paste and there you go now we
have our sandbox and we can start
writing queries and getting data into
our components
whenever dealing with complex subject it
always helps to keep things in
perspective
so let's give it a shot in this case as
well since gatsby is built on top of
react we know that our project will
consist of components now those
components could be small components big
components at this point it is
irrelevant at the end of the day our
project will have a bunch of components
in some of those components maybe in all
of them we would want to render some
data now that data could be really
anything
external apis local files and images
markdown
site metadata just to name a few
in order to access that data we'll
utilize graphql and in a nutshell
graphql is the syntax that describes of
how to ask for data it allows us to
specify what data we would need and uses
the type system to describe that data
in gatsby we can create and test our
queries in the graphical ide or simply
sandbox and once we are ready to display
or render our data we can do that with
the help of static or page queries
static query could be used in any
component including the page component
but when it comes to page query we can
only use them in our page components
what makes page query so special is the
fact that unlike static query it can
also accept variables so nutshell we
have components that want data now we
use graphql to get that specific data
test our queries in sandbox and render
it using static or page queries
since we'll spend a significant amount
of time in our sandbox let's get
familiar with an interface
now please keep in mind that it is just
an intro video and i fully understand
that a lot of things might look sketchy
confusing and even flat out scary i hear
you
don't worry when it comes to writing our
actual queries we'll start very nice and
easy i'll probably repeat the same thing
20 000 times to the point where you will
scream at the monitor but hopefully by
doing so you won't feel overwhelmed and
will be able to set up your own queries
in no time as far as the interface on
the left hand side this is where we'll
set up our queries and then on the right
hand side we'll have two options either
we'll get a result for the query we just
set up and of course we can just copy
and paste that query into our project
and we're good to go essentially we will
get our data or we'll have an error so
if we will have an error of course we'll
have to troubleshoot
now later as our queries get more
complicated we'll also have to set up
query variables and this is exactly
where we'll set them up as you can see
we have a name here query variables but
at the moment we don't have to worry
about that just remember later that's
where you can find your variables as you
can see right now on the left hand side
we have a bunch of very useful comments
and as a side note even though some of
it might not make sense i would suggest
just kind of skimming over it just so
you understand the main idea now when it
comes to running our queries we have a
few options either i click on a play
button right here hard to miss or we
also have an option of shortcut and that
shortcut would be control and enter
then as we're setting up the query there
might be a time where you'd want to
format it because as you're writing the
query it might get messy
it is much more easier to see if
everything is nicely formatted and in
order to do that we just click on
prettify and that one would be shift
control and p
then we have a history which should be
self-explanatory as you can see these
are the queries that i wrote in your
case if you just open it up probably it
is blank and then we have your next
future best friend why am i saying that
because even though as we will set up
our first queries we will write them out
manually because i would want you to
struggle i want you to understand how it
works all the nuts and bolts but
later we will use the explorer and
what's really cool about the explorer is
the fact that the only thing you really
need to do
is check off boxes so for example i have
a query with the name of all site
these are the options i have for example
i'm looking for the edges and again i
fully understand that none of this makes
sense right now i'm just showing you
what is going to be our future so edges
then we have node and then these are all
the options that i have and you can
notice that without typing anything i
can pretty much set up my query and once
my query is done i can run it i can get
back my results and i'm good to go
now the explorer is awesome because it
allows you to set up the query by just
clicking on the check boxes and you're
ready to go in no time
code exporter allows you to save on
typing out depo elephant so essentially
as you can see it prepares the code that
you would need to use in your component
of course there's going to be some
modifications and we'll add some more
code and delete some of the options that
they provide but in general again it
allows you to save some time in the
beginning we will type all these things
manually because i think that is the
best way to learn but of course later we
will utilize our code exporter as far as
the options we have page query static
query hook that we'll cover a little bit
later and static query so for example if
i would go with static query option
notice my code would change but again it
is generated for me i will close the
code exporter for the time being as well
as the explorer and then we also have a
docs now i want to cover docs right now
because i think they will bring
unnecessary level of complexity so i
think it's better if we cover them once
we have some basic understanding of
graphql and the last thing that i want
to do in this video is to go over the
basics of graphql and in order to do
that i'm going to look in my history so
in your case you'll probably not have
this query
and when it comes to graphql the setup
is following so we have a query in this
case we're looking for the products but
unlike the rest api which essentially
just dumps all the data and then you're
the one who is stuck just coming up with
which property and value you're looking
for
when you're setting up the query you are
right away being asked to be
very specific and in graphql we have
fields now when we talk about fields
think of them as properties on the
object so for example these nodes
represents all the products that i have
the thing is though right away as i'm
setting up my query i need to say which
fields and am i looking for in the
specific product because i cannot just
say okay give me all the products
graphql is like nope you need to be
specific of what you would want to get
back so if nodes has more subfields
which in case it does so fields within
the fields then you need to say okay i
want title i would want url i would want
size but then as you notice if the field
has its own subfields then we need to
drill it down even more and as a result
we get only the specific data that we
were looking for and one more thing that
i really like about gatsby is that i can
only set up these queries if i have
installed the plugin and what that means
is that i don't have to memorize 10 000
queries so only if i'll install the
plugin
then i'll have access to that specific
query and only then i'll have access to
that specific data by far the best way
to learn graphql is by writing queries
but here's the kicker first we have very
limited amount of actual queries
since we have very few plugins installed
and second at this point in time we have
a very limited amount of data as well
and i guess let's fix the data issue
first
and we're going to do that by adding
some site metadata in our gatsby
and you can think of site metadata as
info about our site and once we set it
up we can pull that info anywhere in our
project so basically we can access it
and do something useful with it for
example later we'll use it to set up
search engine optimization component or
seo for short
let's navigate to gatsby config
probably want to start the server right
away meaning stop server my apologies
then i'll close again all the files that
i'm currently working in and of course
i'm looking for
gadsbconfig
then
above the plugins i guess i'm gonna go
with a property name of site
meta
and data now please please please please
keep the same syntax i know looks a bit
sketchy but yes you need to write it
site meta data like so and i'll talk
about it at the end of the video
basically why it is important as far as
the syntax and then inside of it
we can go really wild and crazy and we
can come up with whatever property names
we want so in this video i'll just set
up a bunch of them
so we can get a good practice when we
set up the query and then eventually
we'll remove the unnecessary ones so
let's start with the useful one not is
going to be the title of our site and
yes i'm going to go with simply recipes
because why not then i'll add a comma
again this is normal object so make sure
that you follow all the proper rules
then i'm going to go with description
and we'll say nice and clean
recipe site recipes site
then i'm going to go with author
and in this case i'm going to go with at
and john smilga if you want you can add
john doe
or susan though whatever and then i'm
going to set up some properties for
practicing graphql query so start with a
person property which actually is going
to be an object and then instead of that
object i'm going to set up a few more
properties one will be named and the
second one will be age
awesome then i'm going to go with simple
data
and in this case it's going to be an
array so simple data that is equal to an
array and we'll just go with item one
and then item two you guessed it item
two and then let's set up also a complex
data it is going to be an array but it's
going to be an array of objects again
the reason why we do all of this
is because i want you to get a good
practice when we're setting up our first
query
let's write here complex
data
and like i said it's going to be an
array of objects so i set up the array
and i'll simply copy and paste just so i
can speed it up a little bit name john
age 32. let's leave it the way it is and
then copy and paste one more time and
let's change it to good old susan
and she's gonna be
21. so let's save it make sure you save
the gatsby config i suggest always
stopping the server and then restarting
the gatsby config so i'm going to go
with npm start or i'm sorry it's a
gatsby config i'm mad gatsby dev server
and let me stress something
when it comes to site metadata property
you need to use the same exact name
if you want you will get a big fat error
in your terminal since it's a property
on this export object
now on the other hand the properties
inside of it that's a different ball
game you can name them however you like
whatever makes the most sense to you and
just so you don't think that i'm making
this up let's navigate to gatsby docs
let's use their awesome search option
and then we can type gatsby config here
gatsby
config and let's just go with api option
and then once we navigate here keep on
scrolling keep on scrolling and there it
is we have configuration options so we
have options available to set within get
b config and then notice
these are our options so we have plugins
which is an array then we have plags and
all that so obviously you can read them
and site metadata is that object so if
you'll go with your own name
gatsby is going to spit back the massive
error because
you're not supposed to add your own
properties on that object there's a
reason why they set up that object and
on that object you're only allowed these
properties now if you're interested in
learning more about site metadata or the
plugins and all that
feel free to read the documentation in
my case we're going to go to the graphql
now and actually practice setting up the
query similarly how we always should
restart the server
when we make changes in get bit config
or gatsby node you also want to always
restart the browser when it comes to
sandbox so the moment you make some kind
of change as far as data in our case we
added that site metadata if you want to
have access to it make sure that you
restart it otherwise you might have the
scenario
where you do make some changes you come
back to the sandbox and unfortunately
you don't see that query now i'll remove
the comments just keep in mind that
we'll use this guy often
at least while we're writing everything
manually and then of course eventually
once we learn how to work with explorer
then i guess we'll do that a little bit
less but again in general this is a
very very good helper so again the
command is control space so now let me
remove everything so i'm going to go
with command a i'll remove everything
and of course i'll zoom in so we can see
a bit better now the way we set up the
query we just start here with the curly
braces now there is a query keyword and
also we can name them and we can pass
some more options and yes we'll cover
that but as far as the basic query let's
just start with simple curly braces
that's all we have to do and then like i
said our best friend is going to be the
command of control and space and there
it is so these are all the queries we
can set up and you're looking at it and
you're like well wait a minute that's
not that many and not to be redundant
but again the reason for that is because
we're using bare bones gatsby
application so of course we have no
plugins so we also have no queries once
you install the plugin then you'll get
the query that's how it works and again
in my opinion that's a very cool setup
because you don't need to memorize 20
000 queries if you have the plugin
then you have the query that's all there
is to know so in my case i'm looking for
the site query
and then the moment i type site notice i
get this red squiggly line
and i have the error field site of the
type site must have a selection of
subfields did you mean site blah blah
blah and in simple terms what graphql is
saying hey listen buddy you're looking
for the site
but site has more subfields so more
options
and you need to be more specific again
it's not like rest api where we hit the
url and then server just dumps all the
info no with graphql we need to be
extremely specific of what we're looking
for and in order to get those subfields
we simply need to add the curly braces
and the moment i add those curly braces
again i can check for suggestions so
essentially i can see what subfields i
can access and what do you know what do
you see over here no i see site metadata
why well because we just created that
object so i go with site metadata and
again i have this red squiggly line
again i have this error but at this
point we already know why because site
metadata is the object so now we simply
need to start pulling these properties
one by one now at minimum you need to
provide at least one
but then if you want all of them
just add them to the query so again we
need to go with a curly braces and then
again we can use our suggestions so
control space i have my title i have my
description i have my author and on and
on and on so i just go with my title i
run it and what do you know of course
now i have my title
and if you notice as far as what
response we're getting back we have this
data object so that's going to be the
wrapper around our response and then we
basically have this mirror image of our
query now let me run right now the
prettify here just so it looks a bit
nicer and then notice of course i'm
requesting the site so i'm getting back
the site i'm requesting site metadata
and hopefully you get the gist now they
also dumped this extensions on us but at
this point in our gatsby journey we're
not really concerned with it so just
focus on this data object so that is
going to be our response and again
whatever is going to be sitting inside
of the data object is going to be mirror
image of your query now let me showcase
what happens if we run with that red
squiggly line and effectively the
graphql the sandbox does nice
suggestions so if i run it notice it
right away pulls some default one so for
example title description and author so
that is also a case but once in a while
you might run into some errors so of
course it's always better if you're
explicit of what actually you're looking
for and again your best friend is going
to be control and space to see the
options so now let's take a look at our
options one by one i'm gonna look for
the title i'll go to the next line i'll
look for description of course and again
if we want we can run prettify just so
our code looks clean and then of course
i can go with author and now we come to
the person so let me run before the
person
as you can see as straightforward as it
gets we have the property and of course
inside metadata we have the value so i'm
looking here for the property and i get
my my response so here i say title
description and author and i get back
the properties with the values and of
course in our code we'll access those
values and do something meaningful now
what happens with a person well
person is an object right and since it
is an object we shouldn't be surprised
if i type here person and i get this red
squiggly line because again we need to
be more specific we need to say hey get
me the person but more specifically
since it is an object get me such and
such property
what are our options we have
name or age so again we go back to the
suggestions and we can clearly see that
we have option for name as well as age
again i run it and beautiful i get my
person with both values now we have the
array i believe it was simple data
so let's just go here with simple data
and if the array just has simple item
like we have with simple data we'll just
get the array with those items so let me
type simple data let me run it and there
it is now of course i have simple data
and whatever items i have so of course
in our code we're going to access the
array and then we can iterate over the
items now what do you think is going to
happen when we try to query complex data
and not to be redundant but we'll have
to be a bit more specific where we go
with complex data like so so let me run
here for some reason it just gives me
that annoying suggestion so complex data
and again the issue here is simple where
each item is an object so in graphql we
cannot just say hey get me the array of
objects no you need to go with okay get
me the array of object but from that
object
this is the property that i'm looking
for and i know that i keep pretty much
repeating the same thing but this is
crucial for understanding graphql since
in my opinion if i really need to
oversimplify everything this is the
biggest difference between rest api and
graphql as far as working with it again
i'm not comparing them as technologies
don't get me wrong what i'm talking
about as far as the user biggest
difference you need to be extremely
specific so we need to go again with
suggestions and check it out now i have
name and age why well because these are
the properties that i have in my object
so if i go name
and also if i go age and if i want to
make everything pretty
i just run prettify
and then of course at this point i think
i can zoom out a bit and then if we run
not only i get the simple data so if we
have single item array essentially where
the items are not complex structures
whether that's number whether that's
string or whatever then we'll simply get
the array and we'll have to iterate over
and in this case though we need to say
well what are we looking for so for
example if i want complex data but i
don't want the age i say get me the name
just always remember if you have more
subfields you need to request at least
one otherwise you'll get an error and
once we have a solid understanding how
we're gonna set up queries
now let's take a look at the explorer
and how it's gonna make our lives easier
just to showcase how much faster we'll
be able to set up our queries using the
explorer why don't we try to recreate
the same query using the explorer option
instead so i'll remove everything just
so you don't think that i'm doing some
blackmagic there it is must provide a
query string so obviously we have some
kind of error
now i'm going to click on the explorer
and then again we just need to look for
the same query now what was the query
that we used because that was the site
one so i click here and basically if the
query or a field is going to have more
options you'll have essentially here
this triangle on left hand side so i
click on the query now up on the top
these purple ones are going to be
arguments and we're not going to talk
about them right now because i don't
want to dump too much stuff on you right
from the get-go but if you notice we
have these fields so this build time of
course doesn't have any subfields so i
simply can click it and again i get some
arguments and all that but as far as the
value i can simply click it and again
this returns the data object and then
instead of the data object i have a site
and build time so essentially i was
looking for this build time field and i
got the value back now i'm going to
unclick the build time and of course
we're looking for what we're looking for
site metadata now of course i have
author i have description i have simple
data and title all the fields that have
no
more sub builds
we can write a way query and then the
same goes for complex data and person we
just need to click on the triangle so we
open this up of course in this case we
just need to be more specific okay i
want age from the complex data and then
when it comes to person i'm going to get
both
and hopefully it is clear that we can
set up the same query within a matter of
10 seconds and that's of course why
throughout the course we'll use the
explorer option instead
congrats on completing your first query
and now let's talk about our render
options
and in general we have two we have
static query and page query and the
setup for both of them is very similar
so once you grasp the setup for one
you'll have no problem implementing the
other one as well
in general static queries are intended
for
regular components and page queries are
used in the page components with that
said we are allowed to set up a static
query in the page component but not the
other way around
so you're not allowed to use page
queries in simple components and the
reason for that is because unlike static
queries page queries do accept variables
which makes them dynamic
and later in the project we will
implement the page query variable
feature when setting up our pages
programmatically
lastly for static query we have two
syntax options one using render props
and one with use static query hook
provided by the gatsby team and since
the react hooks have become pretty much
a standard and most likely that's the
syntax you will encounter when working
in gatsby we will use only the use
static query hook for all our static
queries just remember they both
accomplish the same task just the
implementation is a bit different
all right and once we know our options
let's pull data using use static query
hook
now in the next video we will set up
everything from scratch since in my
opinion it's important to understand how
stuff really works
not just blindly copy and paste the code
but in this video since i want to
showcase how fast we can get something
on a screen we'll cheat a little bit and
use code exporter option e instead
so back in my query i actually want to
add the other property in complex data
as well so i'm just going to go with my
name i'll run it and that is my result
and like i said we'll use code exporter
and once you open up the tab
notice we have these options we have
page query static query hook as well as
the static query now since we'll
practice with static query hook of
course pick this option and then you can
just select it here notice they provide
this option
of copying this to the clipboard and of
course that's what i want to do so once
you have this code just navigate back to
our project and again i'll set up some
examples just so you have a reference
for later and we'll just call this fetch
and then data js you can simply copy and
paste the whole code
like i just mentioned we will set up
everything from scratch
so you have a better understanding how
stuff actually works but for now i just
want to get something on the screen so
let's save
now you'll notice how they set up
component name and then right away
export as default
and that just means that they can keep
this generic name meaning since we're
exporting as default it doesn't really
matter what we call it here inside of
the file that's just a side note and of
course i can navigate to index.js i
think is just going to make a bit more
sense if we do it there and then i'll
import my fetch data so import and i'm
guessing i'm going to call it the same
way i'll say
fetch
data and that is coming from and of
course i'm looking in the examples and
the file name is
fetch data
and then right below the header
but still within the main i'm just going
to go with fetch
and data
and if you see this string on a screen
which you should let's see yeah there it
is now of course i can see this giant
string everything works now at this
point it's not particularly useful i can
clearly see the same info here in my
sandbox now what's more interesting is
the fact that i can access this data so
i'm going to go back to the fetch data
and then remember
this is a giant object now at the moment
we use json stringify and all that
that's good but instead what i want is
to set up some kind of div here and then
instead of this div why don't we set up
a heading 2
with a person name
and in order to practice a bit why don't
we iterate over the complex data and i
don't know show multiple people again
just a small practice of how we can
access data and don't worry of course
since it is an object we can destructure
it and we'll do all that cool stuff
later for now
let's just do the old-fashioned way
where we'll literally drill down to the
necessary property so for example if i
go with heading 2 i know that i can go
back to the javascript land and i have
the info inside of this data so we set
up the query and then notice this result
will be in data just like in our sandbox
so what we're looking for of course is
this data variable and then i need to go
site site metadata and more specifically
i'm looking for the name of the person
correct so
let's set it up we're going to go with
data since that is the name of the
variable then cite then site meta
and then data
make sure that the property name is
exactly the same
then of course we have the person
and of course i'm looking for the name
so i'm going to save it and the moment i
save i see john now if you have
different value of course you'll see the
different value and just to kind of
hammer this home
notice the complex data i want to do the
same thing where right below the heading
2 now i just want to iterate over that
array and display a paragraph with both
values the name and the edge and we're
going to go with another div and then
inside of this div i want to look for
the property by name of complex data so
in order to speed this up a little bit
i'm just going to grab site metadata
again
later we'll take a look at the better
options instead for now let's just copy
and paste
and let's do it the long way and of
course i'm looking for complex data that
is my array so i can use the map method
and then i'll just reference each object
as the item and then as far as what i'm
returning well like i said i'm just
going to return a paragraph and in this
case since i'm returning an array i need
to add my key of course that is just a
reacting when we have a list so keep
prop and we need to pass in something
unique so in this case i'm just going to
grab the index and then as far as the
values well i have the object correct
and i have two properties age and name
and it's represented by my item so here
simply i can say
item dot name and then colon and then
another set of curly braces and i'm
going to go with item and age and once i
save i see john 32 and susan 21 so
that's how easy we can set up the query
and then once we have the data we could
pull it in our components using gatsby
beautiful we were successful with
getting the data on screen
so now of course let's recreate
everything from scratch and
in a process we'll cover what is graphql
what's the deal with use static query
and all that good stuff so i'll remove
everything
and i'll just create a new component
using my snippets and as you can see the
name here is fetch data but i purposely
created with a lowercase because i want
to showcase what giant error you're
going to get if you'll try to use the
use static query hook
with a component that has the name with
lowercase so for time being let's just
write heading one and we're gonna go
with hello
from
fetch
data let's save that one and of course
at the moment
i have this again annoying thing there
and then once i refresh
everything is correct so go with hello
from fetch data and then in order to use
use static query hook we need two things
we need a hook and we also need a
graphical tag template now both of them
are named exports so when we import we
definitely need to set up the curly
braces and then we say use static
query and also comma and then graphql
now
since i'm using the snippets once in a
while it spits back the snippet for
something else so in my case i'm just
going to go with graphql and then from
academy so once i have these two imports
you need to invoke use static query but
then it's looking for an argument of
graphql
and then since it is a tag template you
pass e in the query and if you take a
look at their example so if you take a
look at the code exporter notice how
they pass graphql with a query right
away in the use static query
my preference is always to set it up
above here so above the component
because that way i believe
my component code is cleaner so i'm
going to get back and i'm just going to
simply create a variable and again name
is really up to you but i'm going to go
with get data and then we go with this
graph
ql and like i said this is a tag
template and this should actually ring a
bell why well because if you remember
when we were setting up the button
what we were doing
well we had styled
that button so we're creating an element
and again i was setting up the tag
template and the only difference is the
fact that in style components we pass in
the css in the tag template and then
those styles are applied to the button
now in gatsby case we pass in the query
so again under the hood gatsby does
something with the query that we provide
but it doesn't change the syntax again
we're using this tagged template
basically a
javascript thing where we just go with a
template literals and then we pass in
some data so in our case what is our
data well of course that is the query
now where we can get the query well we
need to go back to the sandbox and then
we have a few options either you can
just grab the whole thing but since i
haven't covered the query keyword as
well as the name and what gotcha you
should be aware of i'm just gonna take
everything starting with the curly brace
and including the closing one and i'll
navigate back copy and paste and we'll
save
now once we do that
we get back some kind of value that will
make sense to
use static query and that is the hook
that we need to invoke now since it is a
react hook
all the react hooks rules apply meaning
we can only run it in a functional
component okay
that looks about right then
we can only run it inside of the
function so you cannot run it outside
here and lastly we can only run it if
the component name is uppercase
and you'll see that in a second if i
just go with cons data and don't worry
we'll recreate everything from scratch
one more time in a second and if i just
invoke this one we'll have a big fat
error right now and the reason for that
is because use static query is called in
function fetch data that is neither and
you're not i think at this point i'm
just gonna go to the bigger screen sorry
my apologies so we have here uh if we
refresh
we're gonna have this react hook use
static query is called in function fetch
data that is neither a react component
nor a custom react function now again
the reason why is that happening because
the name here needs to be with a upper
case so once you set it with a capital
case now of course we're not going to
get that error so let me set it and then
i want to pass in that get data variable
again
if you don't prefer setting up this way
of course you can just directly pass in
with a query so i'm going to go here
with get data and actually first i just
want to console.log it so i just want to
see what i'm going to be getting back so
i'm going to go with console.log and
notice i'm just going to cancel log the
result
that i'm getting from my use static
query and then once i save
and i guess i'm just going to do that on
a big screen because
i think you'll see that way better and
then once we refresh we should see the
site
now what does that site represent
well that's the object that we're
getting back right
this is the object that we're getting
back that's it and of course since we'll
assign it to some kind of variable the
value data will be assigned to that
variable and then inside of that
variable we'll have site site metadata
and of course then we already know the
drill then inside metadata we have
author we have complex data and all that
good stuff and at this point it is
really a javascripting
whichever method you prefer using
when you're pulling the data out of the
object well that's the one that you're
going to use
so for now what i'm going to do is
simply go with const and data again some
kind of variable and this is going to be
equal to that object that i'm getting
back and then if i go the long way i'm
going to go with heading 2
and let's just say name here
so right here name so again i go with
data i go with site
and i'm going to go with site meta
meta
and then data and then i'm looking for a
person
and more specifically i'm looking for
the name and then once we save and once
i refresh my
name is john so that's definitely one of
the options that we could use so i'll
leave it for your reference and i'll
just comment it out
and then another option we have is of
course the structuring so since i know
that i'm getting back the object i can
right away destructure it i can say you
know what in the object get me the site
property now the thing is
if we take a look site property is an
object itself right so what are we
really looking for well we're looking
for site metadata so i can just say all
right so get me site
meta and then data okay but that is the
object itself so i can keep on
structuring this way and since i don't
want to keep on doing this i'm just
going to go with title which is a simple
property so i'm going to say title now
title is not an object it is just a
value so i can simply save it and now
instead of doing this whole dance of
data sites and metadata each and every
time you can simply go with a heading
two
and i can just write site title
is and then colon and then i can just
access the title like so so save it and
there it is i have site title is simply
recipes again at this point it's really
just javascript so it really comes down
to your preference some people find the
structuring confusing
and therefore they're used either the
long way of accessing the value or you
can also set up a variable assign it to
data site site metadata and then instead
of accessing all the time using this
long way you can just access the
variable and then for example look for
the person and don't worry throughout
the first project and the other ones as
well i'll try to switch it up so we're
not using all the time the same syntax
but of course in my case
for the most part i always go the
destruction route instead
and one more time let's go over the
setup where we do need to have a
component
and then we import use static query hook
and all react hooks rules apply as well
as graphql tag template
now in the graphql tag template we pass
in the query
and then we can either
place it right away as an argument in
the use static query or we can just
assign the value that we're getting back
to some kind of variable and this one we
can do outside of the component but
the use static query we need to invoke
it inside of the component and per react
hooks rules the component names must
start with a uppercase letter and then
once we invoke use static query with our
variable or with graphql with a query
we're just going to be getting back the
object now which object well same one
that we can see here in our sandbox
basically this is what we're going to be
getting back
the data object and then we have
multiple ways how we can pull that data
out either destructuring either
assigning to variables or we can simply
drill down to the property we're looking
for and then we'll just display that
data on screen
as you are setting up the first query
i bet you found one thing extremely
annoying and that is a simple fact that
each and every time we were setting up
the query or we were accessing the data
we had to use this site
metadata
and trust me this is not even a long
name once you start working with images
once you start working with headless cms
these names will get even longer it's
not like i can just randomly
start typing something else right i need
to be specific of what i'm looking for
however there is a way around it where
basically in graphql we can set up
aliases so before we cover keyword as
well as the name why don't we take a
look at how we can add alias because i
think it's just going to make our lives
much easier and we simply need to go
back to our query here and we need to
come up with a name so call it bugs
bunny call it bobo it doesn't really
matter and in my case i'm just going to
go with info and then the syntax is
following where you need to add a colon
now keep in mind one thing
we're still looking for this property
it's not like i just randomly came up
with a name what i'm giving here is the
alias so when i'm going to be accessing
this data then instead of using this
site metadata blah blah blah
i can simply run it and notice my
response i have info so nowhere in my
response i have the site metadata so
when i'm setting up the query i'm saying
yeah get me this field but from now on
i'll access using this name instead and
now of course we want to test it out in
our project and please be aware that the
moment we'll change it just in a query
we will have a big fat error and i'm
doing that on purpose so let's go back
over here and then inside of this site
metadata like i said i'm going to go
with info instead we will save but there
is going to be a big fat error now can
you guess why we have that error well
let's scroll down let's scroll down
let's scroll down
now is anywhere in our response the
property by the name of site metadata
since i'm trying to destructure it and
keep in mind
even if you're using this long way
you'll still have the error y because
site object does not have the site
metadata property anymore in response
what name we have
well info since that's the alias so
instead i'm going to change this around
and i'm going to say info
and we'll do it over here as well it's
all right info and then once i save
again it's annoying but we'll have to
refresh and now of course everything
works site title is
simple recipes so that's how we can add
alias in our graphql query if we have a
long and annoying name or we just simply
want to be hipsters as you're going to
be progressing with your gatsby
applications and setting up more and
more complex queries
eventually you will come across the
syntax where query keyword and query
name e is used
like i mentioned at this point in our
journey it's optional but later once
we'll work with more complex queries we
will use query keyword now few gotchas i
like to mention are following
query names must be unique and once you
start tinkering with query data
in the file you might need to run gatsby
claim to clean the cache and restart the
server so let's start with a query name
please understand one thing where yes
you can run the same query in multiple
files
you're not limited one query per one
file no that's not what i'm saying what
i'm saying
is that if you're setting up
multiple queries with the same name yes
you're going to get an error so please
be careful basically every time you use
the query name make sure that it is
unique that's first second if i navigate
back to my project and if i simply write
a query keyword
everything should work
now i emphasize the work should
unfortunately you'll see
this error and even though i keep on
refreshing well i can clearly see that
in the cache
there is some kind of bug
now again in order to avoid it because i
know that this syntax is correct i just
use the query that's it nothing else so
i shouldn't be getting this bug
now in order to avoid it i simply need
to clear everything i'll run gatsby
and then clean and of course we'll run
gatsby build
or i'm sorry what built develop so we're
going to go with gatsby develop and
you'll see
when the dev server spins up that we
won't have that error anymore so now let
me just wait a little bit
and then once the dev server is going to
be up and running you'll see that our
query is going to be correct so let me
go back and there it is as you can see
it wasn't the query that was causing the
issue it's basically the cache so if you
run into that problem where you can
clearly see that the query is correct
but you're still getting some kind of
cash bug then make sure to run get be
clean and one more thing i want to
mention
if you just use query keyword you're
going to be in good shape meaning i can
grab the whole file copy and paste and
everything is going to work again we're
just talking about the name so the name
that comes after the query keyword
those ones have to be unique so if you
go with first query and then select the
whole file and again since i made some
changes there's going to be this bug but
if you just grab this whole query
and use it in a different component yes
you will get an error because query
names must be unique
all right and once we have covered use
static query hook now let's take a look
at our page query option and for this
temporarily i will create a page but
eventually it's not going to be part of
our project so i'm going to go to new
file and i'll just call this testing gis
now same rules apply of course we need
to export as default okay that's good
and then i'll right away rename it even
though in this case it's not really
going to make much difference and then
we're going to go with heading 2
and then we're going to go with testing
and the way it's going to work we'll
again import graphql
tag template
but in this case the setup is going to
be a bit different so let me close the
sidebar and first i just want to check
whether i have the page to begin with so
let's say testing and for some reason i
cannot see it okay that's interesting
even though i saved it and again i have
these weird bugs okay and now everything
works so as you can see i just needed to
keep on refreshing and now i can see my
testing all right so that's a great
start
and then yes we will import our graphql
tag template and then of course it is
coming from the gatsby and then i'll use
the same query just because i don't want
to over complicate things but in this
case we're going to be exporting the
variable
and we'll be able to access this data in
the props now just so you don't think
that there's some black magic i simply
want to show you that by default every
time you create a page gatsby will
provide already a bunch of props so if i
look for props and then just console log
the props just like in any normal
component
if i go to the bigger screen and again
if i go with testing
i'll see in the console that gatsby
already provides a bunch of things so
notice that's my prop object and notice
all the cool things gas b already
provides now the kicker here is
following that once we set up our
graphql tag template assign it to a
variable and export that variable
the data that we're getting back so
again we're talking about this one
whatever we have access over here
that one will be available in the data
property in our props object now as you
can currently see
there is no data property so of course
we do need to set up that query so let's
go back to the testing site and i'm
going to do it over here so we do need
to export that's a must for the syntax
to work then we go with const and in
this case i'm just going to call this
data and then we go again with graphql
so graphql that's our tag template that
is coming from the gatsby and then again
we just need to pass in the query so i'm
just going to go back to the fetch data
and in a second i'll show you what error
we're going to get if we run with the
same name
just to hammer that point home but for
the time being i'll just take everything
apart from the query and first query so
let's take this one let's copy and paste
let's save it and then we'll see whether
we need to refresh or not so in this
case i'll refresh and now notice
something interesting where now we have
the data one right so
once we set up our variable once we
export this and of course once we pass
in the query in a tag template
then we have access to the data in the
data property in the props again i know
for some students this is a bit
confusing where they're like wait a
minute so i'm just setting up the
variable here and then i have the value
in the props yes behind the scenes at
the build time so when our project gets
created gas be smart enough to read this
value and then just provide the data
that we're getting back
in that data property
and then from that point
again it's just simple javascript of how
we want to access the property values so
in this case we know that we can
destructure right away in function
arguments
so i can simply say you know what
instead of looking for the whole props i
just want to get that data and just to
showcase another way how we can access
the value i can simply go with const and
author
and that one will be equal to my data
and then of course i have the info since
i use the alias and i'm sorry i need to
go with cite my apologies since i'm
getting back the object that is in my
data and then of course i have site i
have info
and then of course i have the author as
well so some people prefer this syntax
instead again
that's really up to you if you like to
the structure everything
you can do that if you like to do the
long way where you drill down the
properties in the return that's also an
option or you can assign to a variable
instead so here let's just change the
round to author
and that one will be equal of course to
my variable
and we're in good shape so once we save
of course i have arthur johnsmelka now
just to showcase what happens if we use
the same name well let me copy and paste
the first query
and i'm going to go back to the testing
one okay i know that this syntax should
work but i right away have this error
and basically this error is just to tell
me that we have multiple queries so
notice here multiple root queries found
first query and first query only the
first first query will be registered so
again if you just remove the first query
if you just leave it as a query
everything is going to work so there is
no error if you just keep using query
keywords however the moment you add the
name
make sure that that name is unique and
let me also just emphasize the fact that
yes
you can't use the regular use static
query hooks in the pages
you can do that however you cannot use
page query
in the components you can only use it in
the pages so essentially in the files
that are sitting in the pages directory
because in the page queries we can also
pass in the variables which we're going
to do a little bit later and effectively
that way we can make pages
programmatically again something that
we're going to do later and don't worry
if at the moment you're a bit iffy on
any of this stuff remember as we're
going to be progressing with a course
we'll write more and more queries we'll
set up more and more use static queries
page queries and all that and the more
practice you'll do the easier is going
to get i think at this point we're more
than comfortable with setting up the
queries and display the results in the
browser so let's give it up a notch and
start interacting with our file system
in order to do that we'll have to use
yet another gatsby plugin and plugin
name is source file system if you
remember we actually already installed
the plugin it was one of the
dependencies of the gatsby plugin image
but just to repeat the steps and since i
have nothing better to do i'll install
it one more time
also we'll set up the plugin as an
object so in the video i'll set up the
code first and then explain it in detail
as a side note if you ever want to check
whether you have a plugin installed just
go to the package.json and then
look for dependency name and then if you
have it in dependencies then of course
you are in good shape but then like i
said i have nothing better to do so i'm
just going to stop the server and then
we'll navigate back to the plugins and
the plugin name is source file system
now it's definitely going to be one of
the top plugins so you can just find it
here or of course you can use the search
box and then navigate to the docs the
command that you're looking for is this
one so copy and paste like so
now i'm going to close the sidebar for
the second and then we're going to
navigate back to the docs the first
sentence says it all a gadsby source
plugin for sourcing data into your
gatsby application from your local file
system
now as far as the config let's keep on
scrolling keep on scrolling we need to
set it up as an object and at this point
you have two options you can either type
everything in the gatsby config or it's
always my preference when i work with
the docs just copy and paste
and of course once i do that i just
modify the code
so it matches to whatever i want to do
but that way i just avoid the
unnecessary typos so just grab this
first object again
make sure that the syntax is correct
though make sure that you get both curly
braces the opening one and the closing
one and all that so make sure you copy
that
then navigate back and of course we need
to work in the gatsby config so let me
navigate to this file and for time being
i'll close the terminal
and of course just remember that we'll
have to restart it copy and paste and
now i just want to change some values
around and then once i change the values
then of course i'll go over
what is happening as far as the logic so
in my case i'm going to go with name of
images and then instead of looking for
the pages directory i'll remove that
sucker and then i want to go to assets
and
of course in the assets i do have the
directory for the images
so i'll say images instead let me save
it and now let me restart the server
just so i can see that everything works
because if you'll provide a wrong path
it right away will spit back the warning
and the error that basically the path
that you provided does not exist now
since i don't want to restart your
server i'm not going to show you what is
the warning just trust me that's the
case now
what is happening here as far as the
config well we have this resolved
property and here we just pass in the
name of the plugin so in our case it is
gatsby source file system now let me
quickly double check yep notice there
are no warnings so i'm in good shape and
then we have this options object and
then for this particular plugin we have
two properties we have a name property
which is just your name for the resource
that you're providing so for example if
you don't like my name you can simply
set up here as photos
and yes in a few videos i'll show you
where we use that in the graphql but
again keep in mind this is your name for
the resource so sky's the limit you're
not limited to using the same name as
the directory name and then we need to
provide a path
and here we need to provide a absolute
path and a node we have this underscore
underscore their name
so what underscore underscore their name
is doing it sets up a absolute path to
the directory where the file is sitting
so in our case we have gatsby config
this is in a root correct so we get the
absolute path
to the root and then we just point to
that specific folder so in my case
source
assets and images
if you have a different folder of course
you set up a different path for instance
if you didn't
set up a asset if you just went with
images of course you just go with source
and images and of course we need to do
that because eventually we will host the
application
and it's not like the same path is going
to be for example on nuttlefy as it is
on my computer okay hopefully that is
clear and the way it works is following
so essentially we come up with the name
we come up with a resource so now when
we'll be using our queries
we'll have access to all those files but
just keep in mind
that as far as queries are concerned
we'll only have access to the images
directory meaning whatever files you
have in this directory
those ones you'll be able to access so
it's not like
as a magic you just access all your
files no on purpose you are setting up
the options where you say okay so get me
only the images and the name for this
resource is going to be images now what
is the benefit of that well the benefit
is the fact that we can have multiple
instances so for example i can copy and
paste and i can say you know what
this is going to be a instance for my
css so call this styles
and then of course i'll change the
directory because it's not images
anymore
if i remember correctly it was css and
then once we save and then once we spin
up the dev server one more time
now i'll have both of these directories
available
now i'll have nine files at my disposal
because if i remember correctly i think
i had eight images and then i have one
four main choices and then of course if
i want to have access to the data then i
can add the data as well so every time
you'll need to access another resource
you'll set up another instance and of
course you'll add your own name now why
do you want to add the name and actually
a name that makes sense at least to you
well it's simply because when you'll be
setting up the query of course if you
have two of these instances now you're
getting all the files
but imagine the scenario where you're
like okay you know what just get me the
images i want to do something with
images and then you have this one lonely
css file in the middle of it so of
course when you'll be setting up the
query the graphql query you'll
explicitly say hey
i want to do something i want to get
those files but only get those files
where the source instance name and that
is just a official name for this one in
graphql is equal to images or it is
equal to styles and i'm not sure whether
you're expecting a mine grenade but i'll
throw it anyway
and first i'll just start by copying
pasting and then we'll just comment out
and i want to showcase that technically
we can
get all the files so for instance here i
can just say project and then instead of
assets instead of css so for example i
can just get all the assets that's also
allowed or i can simply get the whole
source folder that is also an option and
you're looking at it and you're like
okay weirdo
then why we're not doing that
why we did this whole song and dance
where you showcase the images then you
show these files i just want to get my
entire project
yeah
but keep in mind that there are
trade-offs at this point i'm getting all
the files
all the files that i have in the source
but imagine the scenario where in my
project
i'll only be working with images
that's the only need that i have for
source file system so every time i'll be
setting up the query
i'll have to jump through the hoops just
to get to this one and at this point it
really comes down to your preference
and what you're trying to do in your
project
if you just need to access to this one
resource whether that is images whether
that is styles whether that is markdown
posts or whatever
then you just set up this one instance
where you point to that folder and trust
me it's just going to be easier to work
with those files
because you don't have to spend that
much time in a graphql basically
filtering out the images now if of
course for some reason in your product
you want to have access to your entire
file pool of course definitely just set
up the source and you're in good shape
just keep in mind that when you'll be
setting up those graphql queries you'll
have to do way more work
just to get to a specific file compared
to these two options
that's why i'll remove my last example
and you know what i'll add the styles
but we'll do that in a few videos
so i don't overwhelm you
and now of course i want to uncomment
everything and again i'll save it and
just stay on the safe side i will stop
and start one more time of course you
don't have to do that if you are not
adding these changes here and once the
server is up and running then of course
we can navigate to the sandbox and see
what fields we have with this plugin all
right and once we have our plugin in
place we have access to two fields we
have access to file field
and we have access to the all file
now the difference is that with a file
field we'll be working with single file
node
now if we work with all file this just
means that we're working with collection
of data and this is going to be the same
with our future source plugins as well
so for example when we'll be setting up
the recipes for recipe there's going to
be a single query there's going to be a
recipe query now for all the recipes if
you want to work with collection of that
data then of course we'll work with all
contentful recipes or all strappy
recipes so get comfortable with this all
that just means that you're working with
collection of data now it doesn't mean
that it magically creates that data if
in the images i'll have only one image
it will treat it as a collection
basically we'll get back the array but
of course there's going to be one item
so hopefully you get the gist and we'll
start with all file so i'm just going to
show you how we can work with collection
and don't worry of course we'll practice
with file as well and as you can see of
course i have more options i have my
triangle and once i click it here at the
top i have my arguments which we're
going to actually cover in the next
video and then we have quite a few
fields here and as you can see we have
more options
and all the way on the bottom we have
this field by the name of total count
and as i can clearly see with my lonely
checkbox that effectively it just
returns a value so click it here and
i'll run it of course i get back my data
okay that makes sense and then i have
this all file and total count now total
count is eight which again just
underscores the point that i was making
in the previous video effectively we're
pointing to the images folder
so if i were to go back and then in the
source
and in the assets i'm just going to copy
one of these images i don't know which
one doesn't really matter so i'm just
gonna make a copy here
and
if i navigate back now and if i refresh
the browser and then run it one more
time
what do you know
of course the value right now is nine
why well because i increased the amount
of files that i have in that resource so
again hopefully it is clear that we have
that one resource we have that images
and this is what we're working with okay
that's a great start now if you want to
interact with the list of those assets
meaning if you want to interact with all
of those files you need to look for the
nodes now the old way was doing edges
and then the field name was node inside
of it but i'm not going to show it i
mean it's been already a long time since
we're using nodes so i'll just stick
with nodes but again just remember
maybe in some old source codes you might
see the edges and then more specifically
node and the way it works when we run
nodes for every instance of course in
our case what is our instance that is
the file we're getting back to node
and in that node we have more options
that's why again we have this error
where graphql is complaining that
there's more sub builds now why is that
well because each instance is
represented by the node what is a node
well if we navigate back to our gatsby
config remember the complex data
and remember i said this is an array and
then each item is an object and node has
the same structure basically it is an
object with bunch of properties now of
course their setup is way more complex
where they have properties that are
actually objects that have more
subfields and all that but the idea is
exactly the same and if you remember
what steps did we need to take in order
to access name or age essentially to
avoid that error when we were working
with complex data well we needed to be
more specific correct so in the nodes i
can see these are my values and
effectively these are the subfields that
i have access to now again some of them
just return a value correct some of them
like for example child image sharp
something that we're going to work on
when we set up gatsby image well that's
actually a pretty complicated object
where we can drill down multiple levels
and as far as what values i want to see
well i at least need one correct so i'm
gonna go with i guess relative path here
and then once we run it notice these are
going to be all my files again i have
the nodes like i said each file is
represented with this node so eventually
when we work with recipes each recipe
will be represented by that note in this
case it's a file so it says relative
path and here it says logo svg now i can
just look for the name for example we
can run it and now of course not only i
have relative path but i also have the
name we can also check for the size we
can check for absolute path again bunch
and bunch of cool stuff
so run it i'll close the explorer for
now and notice this is what we're
getting back again we have all file to
work with all the files in that source
and then we have the nodes field and
that nodes field just represents that
list and those items are going to be
coming back as nodes and in those nodes
you have the subfields that's why when
you set up the nodes field you'll have
to be more specific hey
what do you want back
as far as data so again they're not
dumping the whole thing on you they say
okay you want to have access to all the
files great but you need to be more
specific you need to tell us well what
properties are you actually looking for
and that's why you drill down you say
okay i just want a name or i want a size
or absolute path or whatever hopefully
it is clear and now of course we can
move on to our next topic beautiful once
we have covered all file field now let's
see how query arguments work we'll use
query arguments with the same all file
field just keep in mind that the idea is
exactly the same with other fields as
well and basically query arguments allow
us to be more specific of what data we
are going to be getting back and syntax
for the query argument is following
where we go with a field name and then
we set up the parentheses and then of
course we get the suggestion whether we
want to filter a limit skip or sort and
you can also see that of course we can
access those arguments when we're
working with explorer
and for this all file field notice these
are my arguments effectively everything
that is in a purple color
those are my arguments so again if you
want to type it out you can definitely
type it out but in my case we'll set up
everything using the explorer now since
my response is somewhat busy i'll also
remove
these two fields
these two subfields and essentially i'm
just going to be looking for
name and size so notice these are my
file names of course and then those are
the sizes and let's start with the most
straightforward one and that one is
limit so basically we're limiting amount
of nodes that we're getting back and in
order to use this argument i simply
click on limit like i said you can type
it out if you want and i'm gonna go with
three
and then once i run it check it out here
i still have a total count nine since
that tells me how many
nodes i have in the source and then this
is my response now keep in mind two
things first we can combine these
arguments and later once our queries get
more complex we'll definitely do so and
second if we're just using the limit
technically these items are random
meaning we say graphql get me three
items and graphql just dumps three items
so at this point we're not specifically
say what we're looking for we just say
hey in my response just limit this to
three so of course when it comes to
limit in most cases you'll use it in
combination with one of the other
arguments because in that case it is
just going to make a bit more sense but
the whole idea is that we're limiting
the amount of nodes that we're getting
back so for example if i'll change it to
five again
i just get two more items okay hopefully
that is clear then we can skip and this
is going to start skipping from the
first item in my response i run and i
get back nine and if i'll go with skip
and i'll skip the first three you'll
notice how
logo about and main
will be missing so once i run notice i
right away start with the recipe and
then all the way to the big copy
hopefully that is clear
then we have filter and sort and as far
as the sort notice how sword has more
options so it has this triangle
and then it will still return
all the items because in a second we'll
take a look at the filter filter
actually limits the items that we're
getting back with sort effectively we're
getting all nine items but we'll just
sort it in type of order so we go with
sort then we can check which field we
want and literally here sky is the limit
notice this source instance name we'll
work with this one in few videos however
once you click on it notice these are
all your options so you can go here as
wild as you want so in my case i want to
sort based on name and size i think
those are going to be two good instances
so let me just check the size first and
then we have the order and then as far
as the order we have ascending so start
with the smaller one or we have the
sending where of course we'll start with
the bigger one so once i run it check it
out logo is the smallest one that's why
it's the first one and then of course we
get the big copy which is going to be
the biggest image okay then if i go with
descending of course the order is going
to be the opposite where again my total
value did not change i'm still getting
back all nine however i'm sorting
and now the two biggest ones are first
and of course we can sort based on name
as well so if i'll change this around
and if i go with name and of course if
we go with ascending then we'll start
with about and then two big files will
be next and hopefully you get the gist
so effectively we sort our response in
alphabetical order so that's sort and
then finally we have a filter and for
the filter i'll make some changes in my
images
so i'll go here with the source
i'll zoom in
and then again we're looking for assets
images and i'll create recipes folder
and i'll place all of these suckers in
there so go new folder and i'll call
this recipes and then all the recipes
images
i'm just going to move into the recipes
folder and once i do that you'll notice
something interesting where once you run
it i still have nine so i'm still
pointing to the same source so that did
not change however if i use filter i can
say hey listen get me only the recipes
ones and hopefully i named it recipes
let me double check because for some
reason i think that i named it product
so not assets images yep recipes good
awesome
uh sometimes i do the weirdest stuff
when i'm actually recording so it's
always good to double check
and as far as the filter same thing
notice we have multiple options and as
you can see since we have a triangle
these ones have more options themselves
and what is a relative directory
well that is going to be a directory
that is sitting in our instance correct
so in this case i'm going to go with
relative directory and then i have these
options starting with equal and we have
non-equal
as well as the rejects so in my case i'm
going to go with relative directory is
equal to and then i just need to provide
that value so in here i go with recipes
and notice the syntax that you have to
write so again you start with an
argument name
then you go with a colon then you go
with a object because again you have
more options here right in the filter
and then since the relative directory
has more options
that's why again you go with one of the
options and then you provide the value
now the reason why i'm showing you right
away the explorer because
in my opinion that's probably the option
you're going to choose yes previously
before explorer was available
you just had to type out the arguments
but in my opinion with explorer there's
very little use case so in this case i'm
going to run it and now notice how my
total count changed and now i'm getting
only the nodes
that are in that folder and like i said
we can combine them so we can combine
these arguments for instance i could
sort them based on the name or size
whatever so i'm going to go back to the
sort and you know what i'll go with size
and i'll say that i want to have the
biggest ones first and notice again the
syntax where we have filter here
that's our one argument and then we have
the second one where we go with sort
again we run it and now of course not
only i get only the four recipes but i
get the biggest one first then smaller
smaller and eventually i get the
smallest one hopefully it is clear and
you're not overwhelmed don't worry
the more practice will do the easier
this stuff is going to get
as a quick side note if you're following
along with the videos you'll most likely
get this warning in a console simply
because in the images component remember
that was the first component we set up
in the examples as far as the images
where we were testing out the static
image component we provided a path where
we say acids then images and then recipe
one now since we copy and pasted all the
recipes into recipes folder of course
now this path returns nothing
so the gatsby is complaining that could
not find the image for assets images and
then recipe one jpeg so at this point
either you can change the path where you
include the recipes folder as well so
we'll need to go with assets images and
then recipes folder and then recipe
number one or we can simply go back to
the file system
and then i'll grab my recipe number one
and then just copy and paste back in my
images folder so i'll still have my
recipe one jpeg directly in my images
folder i think this is going to be the
approach that i'm going to take so again
i can restart the server
and
if everything is correct there should be
no warnings in terminal
all right that should do it as far as
the arguments so now let's take a look
at file field
and what i'm going to do is just delete
everything here notice i just go back to
this nice clean layout and then like i
said when we work with all file we work
with collection we work with all of our
nodes now when we work with file we work
with that one specific node so for
example i could go here to the file and
notice how we're getting
all of these arguments
and you're probably okay why is it so
many why for all file we had only four
and now i have this huge list well let's
see when we set up the data for example
i'm gonna go here with a name and i'll
run it and it's beautiful i'm getting
back my logo and if i really want to
double check of course i can go with i
don't know
relative path and i'll see that of
course the name is logo svg and that's
awesome because now of course i can
access the same fields like we did
with all file field when we're iterating
over those nodes
however there's one gotcha
i mean i'm getting a logo file right
but what if i don't want the logo
because i can clearly see that
in my project in the images folder well
i have about i have big copy big or
maybe even i want to access one of the
recipe images how can i do that
because this logo svg is awesome if i
want that logo svg but if i don't want
it it's kind of useless correct
and again we have to use the arguments
that's why we have so many of them here
where essentially we say yeah get me
that one file but with the help of
arguments we specifically say which file
we're actually looking for and again you
can use any of them over here but the
one that i'll use is going to be
relative path and again we have more
options here and i'm going to go with
equal and once i have this in place i
just need to provide the name of the
image for instance if i'm looking for
big jpeg i go with big
and then jpeg and if i run it of course
now i have this file now if i want to
access the recipes one of course i need
to point to the folder
and then the file name
so if i go here and if i say a recipes
and then if i try to look for big well
of course that file is not there that's
why i get back the null just keep in
mind that when we're talking about a
relative path we're already pointing to
the images
correct
and then relative path just means well
once we get to the images
relative to images where do we want to
go
and in this case i want to go to the
recipes and then of course the file name
is a recipe
for example one and i believe it was
jpeg so we run it and now of course i
get back that single recipe and again
from here once you get to that
particular file
same thing again you have
all of these fields that you can choose
and of course you can just do something
with that data
in your application
and since i promise you that i'll show
you an example where we'll use this name
property in our query in this video i'll
set up another instance and we'll just
set up the query using the arguments now
this video is not intended as a code
long
if you don't want to you can just sit
back and relax
so at this point i want to copy and
paste and since i have examples folder
right next to the assets well i'll
simply set up another instance pointing
to the examples as far as the name i'm
going to go with the same as the folder
and of course i'm not looking in the
assets now i'm looking in the examples
like so so we save it and then of course
we need to remember that we need to
restart the server so i'm going to go
with npm and start now once we navigate
back
then i'm going to set up all file query
one more time so let me delete
everything here and then i'm going to
look for total count and you'll notice
something interesting where now the
total count is 14 because now of course
we have two instances
not only we're sourcing the images but
we also have access to the examples but
if i want to do some work with examples
and if i don't want to deal with images
i simply need to add my argument and in
this case i'm just going to say you know
what get me only the file whose source
instance name is equal to examples so we
go to the filter and then we keep
scrolling keep scrolling and this source
instance name represents the name that
you have in gatsby config so we go
source instance name we have more
options again and i'm just going to go
with equals and then i just need to type
the same name so i'm going to go with
examples and now of course once we run
it the total count is 5. and if you
don't believe me i can show you that if
i take a look at the nodes and then we
keep on scrolling keep on scrolling and
for example we can go with a name option
so i click it here and there it is these
are all the files that we have in the
examples all right and up next i want to
work with gatsby image remember when we
set up the gatsby plugin image we had
two options
we had a static image and gatsby image
and i said that the only difference the
biggest difference
is the fact that when we work with
gatsby image it is expecting a dynamic
data and we provide that using graphql
and that point of course didn't know
nothing about graphql well now we do and
i just want to create a simple gallery
where essentially there there's going to
be a component
where we'll set up the query
we'll look for all our images since we
know how we can do that and then we'll
iterate over and then of course we'll
provide that dynamic data
to the gatsby image component and of
course in the process we'll learn how we
can work with gatsby image component
first i want to do a little bit of setup
where i'm going to navigate back like i
said this was just for your reference i
don't want to deal with the source
instant name and all that so i'll just
remove it
and then i'll restart the server i'm
going to go with npm start
then i'm going to keep on scrolling
and in the examples i want to create a
new component by the name of gallery so
let's go with gallery js and then inside
of it let's go with a component and by
the name of gallery of course all right
and we'll just say simple
image gallery and you're not why don't
we place this actually in heading 2.
so we'll go with simple
image gallery now i'll render this
component in the test page just because
it's easier but of course you can do it
anywhere in our project now i do want to
clean out a little bit our index.js
because i don't like that it is getting
so busy so remember the fetch data i'll
remove it and i'll remove it here as
well
that's an awesome start then i'll
navigate back to the testing one now
since i want our gallery to look a bit
nicer i'm also going to look for my
layout
that is coming from the components if
you remember so we have a layout
component
then we'll remove our current query
because essentially we'll just render
our
gallery one so there is no author of
course
and of course i'll remove the page query
as well again don't worry there's going
to be plenty of practice
for the page query so i'll remove it
here and then like i said i just want to
wrap everything
in the layout
and then i want my gallery again the
reason why i'm doing that in testing
because i'll remove the whole testing
one so then i don't need to hop around
my project and just remove them one by
one so let's go here with import we're
looking for gallery one from and in this
case we're looking in the examples and
of course the file name is gallery and
then it's not gonna be an author we'll
simply go here with a gallery so now of
course we should see the heading 2 but
of course i do need to restart i guess
or i guess refresh and there it is now i
have my simple gallery component now
since i want to have a bit better css
i'll also set up a page here so i'm
going to go with main with a class off
page again that's just a css class that
just makes sure that we have now bar on
top and the footer is all the way in the
bottom and once we have this setup in
place now of course we'll head back to
the sandbox and see how we can get that
dynamic data that the gatsby image
component is looking for all right and
once we have our setup in place now
let's set up the query
where we'll get the data that the gatsby
image plugin is looking for and as i
know i'm not going to need this graph
url here
so i'm going to delete that one
now as far as the setup once again
select everything
and just remove because i want to start
from scratch
and then we're looking for all file okay
and in this case again gives me all
these suggestions that's not what i want
and i don't want the filter yet don't
worry in a second we'll set it up and
then i don't think i'll need the total
count so the only one that i'll leave is
this one the name so basically i just
want to showcase what we're getting back
we get all these files great
now what well now
if we drill down we can see that we have
this child image sharp
and i know that the field name is
somewhat interesting i get it i was also
surprised the first time i saw that one
but
this is where we get the info
and if we open this up
then we notice that we have fixed and
fluid so these ones we used in the
gatsby version 2 and now we have this
new one so this new one is gatsby image
data now notice how it has way more
arguments and we'll cover them in a
second just keep in mind that
effectively this is a object that
provides all the data
that the gatsby image is looking for and
if you remember
when we talked about the images
i said that the setup is almost the same
meaning for the static image and gatsby
image and the difference is simply how
we pass in this data for instance when
it comes to source placeholder and all
that
now we're going to do that here in a
query
for instance source is right away
provided notice how we look for gatsby
image data and we're good to go the
source is provided but notice our
options here so for example i can go
with a layout remember that was one of
the options
when we were setting up of course our
static one and what do you know
i have fixed there i also have full
width and constraint so hopefully you
get the gist where again the setup is
the same
in here i'm hard coding that for every
static image in here i just say all
right
get me all the images then specifically
get me this gatsby image data and that's
a must you must provide this one
and then if you want to provide more
options you can definitely do so so in
this case i'm going to go with fixed
layout as far as the placeholder i'm
going to go with the blurred one and
just to showcase that we have more
options i'll also go with transform
options and that's something we didn't
cover in the static image because i
didn't see the point of covering all the
options that we have
and then we can just go with a grayscale
and we're going to go with true and
you'll see once we set up the gallery
how it looks like so once we run it now
of course we provide those options
not only we provide the basic setup
because remember
when we set up the image whether that's
static or gas b of course there's going
to be some defaults that's what i
mentioned before when it comes to
options there are some defaults that's
why if you just run gatsby image data
yes you will get some data the correct
data but of course with just some preset
options in this case i'm more specific
i'm saying hey get me the layout and i
want layout fixed get me the blurred one
and hopefully you get the gist so
everything is nice we're getting this
data basically we just need to set up
the query in our gallery
and we're going to be in good shape
but there is a catch and if we go back
to our project and if you open up the
terminal you'll notice you can't use
child image sharp together with logo svg
so effectively we need to remove our svg
file from the query and that's a bummer
but that gives us a option to practice
on our arguments
if i scroll up i can filter i can say
you know what get me all the images
apart from the ones that have the svg
extension we bravely click on filter
then we keep on scrolling keep on
scrolling
and of course we're looking for the
extension
there it is that's our extension and
then we say the extension
is not equal and we simply go with
v
and g
and then once we run it notice how our
first image is actually about
so it's not svg like we were getting
before now it is about and then at this
point
you have as always multiple options you
can go with code exporter
and then look for the static query hook
but again my issue with this code and i
really appreciate the fact that they
provide this code don't get me wrong i'm
not complaining but my issue is that
they again set up everything here in the
component
and in my opinion it just makes those
components bloated
so that's why even if i go with a hook
option i always go for page
and then
i grab everything apart from the export
that is just my preference you don't
have to do that if you are okay
with this setup where basically
everything is in a component feel free
to do so at the end of the day you'll
have the same data
now in my case i will always use the
page one and then i'll just grab
everything here like this so copy this
one then i'll navigate back to my
gallery
like so now of course we'll have to make
some imports of course so let's copy and
paste and of course we need to have a
graphql that's a must and also we need
to have our use static query hook so we
go with import then use static
query hook of course and then the second
one is my graphql
tagged template
and then this is coming from and of
course the gatsby one now i also want to
get that gatsby image correct because
remember we cannot use the static image
with dynamic data because again keep in
mind we're iterating over the nodes so
as we're iterating each and every time
we'll pass different data and that's
essentially why we need to use that get
the image plug-in so we go with import
and instead of the static one we go with
gatsby
image
and then of course this is coming from a
gatsby plugin image so once we have all
the imports in place i just want to see
whether i'm getting the data
i want to do a console log and if i have
the data then the next video will work
on the return so let's go with const and
let me scroll down
data is equal and now i use my use
static query
what is the name of my variable it is
simply query here
and then let's log the data if we have a
massive massive massive
object then we are in good shape so
let's go back and of course this is
going to be my testing let's spin it up
and if we inspect and in the console i
see this object we are in good shape so
notice we have all file and we're not
surprised because that's the query that
we set up and then i have the nodes and
of course nodes is my array and we know
the rest so in the next video let's
iterate over our data and display
something meaningful on screen
all right we're done with our query
and before we go any further let me just
showcase where we can find useful info
about the gatsby plugin image so
remember previously i showed you
the reference guides well now let's take
a look at the how to guide
and then
we're going to keep on scrolling and
we're looking for adding images and
media and more specifically how to use
gatsby image plugin
now they start here from the scratch of
course we already covered that one we
know about static images
we keep on scrolling keep on scrolling
and we come to
dynamic images so like i said in order
to set up dynamic images we need to go
with gatsby image data that's the field
that we're looking for and as a setup
i'm just looking at this width and i
just remember that i forgot to add it so
let me quickly go back my apologies i
know that some of you are probably very
annoyed by this but let me
close my exporter for a while
and then i'm gonna go back to explorer
and then of course this is my filter
that's not what i want i'm going to keep
on scrolling and remember we had options
for height and width and in this case
since i'm getting fixed it only makes
sense if i'm going to go with a certain
width and in my case i'm going to go
with 200 keep in mind that yes
technically you can run it without width
it's not going to break but of course
you'll have to do more work in the css
and since i want to avoid that i'm just
going to add that option here instead
and let me quickly swing back to the
code exporter
and then like i said i'm grabbing
everything here
as far as the page query
the only thing that
i'm avoiding is that export and then
i'll copy and paste again you can simply
add here the text i just wanted to go
through all the steps so you're not
surprised where i'm getting this info
from all right that should do it
now let's swing back so we have this
gatsby image data and this is what we're
going to pass
into our component and we keep on
scrolling blah blah blah we have display
the image and again the difference here
is that we grab
gatsby image component and there's also
going to be a helper function which i'm
going to cover in the next video for now
we just need to grab this gatsby image
and the way it works again in their case
they right away showcase with a helper
function but the idea is that we just
drill down to that gatsby image what was
the name gatsby image data this is what
we need to pass in in the prop by the
name of image in the gatsby image
component
so
we're going to go back we have our
gatsby image but since i first want to
test out how we can iterate over our
data why don't we simply
set up some kind of array list or
whatever where we just iterate over and
display the name and once we understand
the name then of course it's going to be
much more easier to add that gatsby
image now i might need to add a little
bit of css so i'm going to go with
styled components in this case and of
course i'm looking for my styled
components i'll quickly set up my
wrapper
and we're gonna go here with a const
wrapper again this is optional you don't
have to do it styled and i'm going to
say section
and eventually i might add some styles
for the css flexbox and here i'll just
wrap everything with my wrapper and then
as far as well how we can access those
values
well remember
that of course data is a massive object
so in my case
i'm going to set up nodes so this is
going to be in the data and then we just
need to scroll up and see okay in the
data there's going to be all file and
then i have my nodes so that's going to
be that array that i'm looking for so i
simply go with data
all file and then nodes and now of
course i assign this to a
node variable and then inside of the
wrapper
let's just set up the curlies and we'll
iterate over the nodes
and for time being let's just set up map
and i'll call this image like so so that
represents that individual object and
i'm just going to go to return
and let's set up the article now i'll
use the key here
meaning i'll use the index for my key
because i don't think that i query for
any meaningful id so i'm going to go
with key index because again we're
returning a list so this is a must
and then as far as the data for time
being let's just go with the paragraph
and we'll say single
and image now the reason why i'm doing
all of this because i want to showcase
what we're going to have inside of this
image so i can see the list
that's an awesome start and now let's go
to the bigger browser window and see
what actually we have inside of that
image an image
is an object and it has a name property
and child image sharp and again we
shouldn't be surprised
we're iterating nodes we're getting back
for every item that node and in that
node these are the fields we have name
field which just returns a value and
then like i said there's going to be
more complicated fields that have the
subfields themselves and of course that
is the child image sharp so for time
being i simply want to access this name
and here i'm going to switch things
around
and i'm just going to do a bit of the
structuring where i'm going to say that
i'm looking for the name that is sitting
in my image object
and
instead of single image
let's just look for the name now of
course we have all these names okay we
are moving in the right direction and
now of course we just need to see well
where is our gatsby image data well that
is sitting in
child image sharp correct now what
gatsby image was looking for was looking
for gatsby image data so now again we
scroll back down
and right above the paragraph i'm going
to go with my component gatsby image
here and then remember the prop name was
image and now in this image we want to
pass in that gatsby image data so again
if you wanted to structure it you can do
so in my case i'm going to go to image
child image sharp and of course get the
image data now if you want to add
aliases feel free to do so in my case
i'm just going to go with image
then child image
and sharp and then of course we're
looking for gatsby and then image and of
course the data one now i want to close
my component
and then i'm going to save it and what
do you know we have all the images that
we currently have in the images
directory even the ones that we have in
the subdirectory
and you're probably wondering okay but
why they're black and white well because
we have these transform options
grayscale if you remove this one then
you'll see that they have their color
now this case i'll add manually here the
height as well so go with height keep in
mind we're not using the sandbox here
and we're going to go with 200 we save
and of course it's going to split back
me the error but eventually i should
have the height as well
now of course all my images are 200 now
if you don't like the grayscale which i
do
but for example if you don't
you can just remove it
again
it's annoying i understand but that's
how it is we just have to refresh and
now of course we have
all of these images and then why don't
we set up a nice column layout so in
here i'll say wrapper and then pretty
much every article is is going to be
placed in the line
with the help of flexbox so say that my
wrapper by default will be display
flex here then flexwrap will be equal to
wrap that just means that if there's not
enough space we'll wrap to the next line
we'll say wrap
and then if we navigate should get the
size by side now of course it's not
going to be on a small screen because we
have 200 by 200 if you go to the big
screen and if you refresh
and yep
of course we have the gallery displayed
now what's missing is the alt problem so
it's complaining that we don't have the
alt prop okay
let's do that one let's say that for the
gatsby image we'll add alt as well and
in this case i'll just pass in the name
so i'll say name and once we add that we
scroll back
notice how we don't have any warnings
now also let's remember
that we have shared props meaning if i
want i can add the class on this gatsby
image as well
for instance in here i can go with class
name again
this name is exactly the same
like we had in the static image so in
the static image we have this class name
and remember we were accessing it well
this is going to be the same the
difference of course now i'm adding to
all of the images the same one so
i'm not doing that manually i'm adding
to all of them and i'm going to call
this gallery
img okay now i'll also add a class here
with a item
just because i want a little bit of
space in between so i'm going to go with
item and first i'm going to say that
every item class is going to get a
little bit of margin to the right again
we're not worried about css i just want
a little bit of space in between so my
apologies if you're not a fan of my css
and you're not actually instead of all
margin i'm just going to go with margin
right
and then remember
now we have gallery img so i can simply
add for example a border radius so i
have that class on my wrapper so i can
simply say gallery img
and here i can say border
radius
and this one will be equal to
one rem again we'll have to go back to
the big screen now we have ourselves a
nice gallery i guess the key takeaways
here are following
where we're iterating over the list
and then we need to look for
child image sharp
and more specifically gatsby image data
and then inside of this gatsby image
data these are all the options we can
set up
just like we did with the static one the
difference is that of course here we are
doing that using
graphql then of course we just need to
pass this in into a gatsby image so we
import gatsby image
then we need to set up the component and
then we have image prop this is where we
pass in that data with whatever
configurations you have again you can
technically leave this open just deal
with a default setup and then of course
we have alt prop and then rest of the
shared props that we covered with a
static image and if you do that you'll
display all your list images using
gatsby image and while we're still on a
topic of gatsby image i also want to
cover this awesome helper function that
they provide and the name of this
function is get image
now what this get image function is
doing it basically provides a path
to the gatsby image and if you're
looking at it you're like well what's
the big deal
and just type out the path myself
i'm gonna go back to the plugins or i
guess not plugins i'm gonna go back to
the reference guides in this case and
again we're looking for gatsby image
plugin we'll scroll all the way down
and then we'll look for the function
and notice this get image right
now
why is a big deal
that we have this function it is a big
deal because it uses the conditional
training where essentially we need to
understand that at the moment yeah we're
iterating over our list
and i know that all my list items
are images however
please understand that we are accessing
here the object property but if that
object doesn't exist in this case if the
child image sharp does not exist we're
looking for the property on and all and
as a result we're going to get a massive
error and the way the previous setup
worked even if one of the items was
missing that image
your whole site broke
that's it it just broke because it was
iterating over the list it was looking
for the object and then instead of the
object it was getting null
i literally cannot stress how many
questions i was getting from the
students where they were like hey listen
what's wrong my data is technically
there i mean my code is exactly the same
and the only difference was that one of
the items was actually just missing that
image
because keep in mind again we have image
object then we have child image sharp
and then we have gatsby image data for
instance if this child image sharp does
not exist we're looking for a property
on a null and you cannot do that so if
there is no object then how you can
access the property on that object you
cannot and that's why this is really
cool because now of course you can just
set up that function
and effectively if there is no object
then it's going to return as undefined
and again it doesn't probably seem like
that big of a deal right now but yes i
can tell you right away that once you
start working with headless cmss i mean
mistakes do happen
and then if that image is going to be
missing
then of course your site will break your
whole site just because of one image
and now let's go back and test it out so
i'm gonna navigate back to my
project i'm looking for get image
function
and then we keep scrolling down
and of course i just want to use it
somewhere and the way we set it up we
just go with some kind of variable now
in their case they just name it image i
guess in my case i'm going to say path
to
image and then we go with our get image
function and then you need to provide
the path
all the way to the object where the
child image sharp is setting so in our
case of course that is the image itself
so i can simply pass here the image
and then instead of writing image prop
is equal to image i can just say that
i'll have path to the image so we save
it here we refresh and if we don't have
any errors we know that this is going to
work again you need to provide path
all the way where the child image sharp
is sitting so if for example you have a
different structure and i believe they
showed that different structure here
where notice how they're querying for
the blog post
and then there is this avatar property
and then as far as what data you pass in
you pass in data
blog post and then you're looking for
the avatar okay so make sure that you
provide a path down to the object where
the child image sharp is sitting again
in our case that object is a image
itself because we're iterating over
those objects but there's going to be
some cases where you need to provide a
different path hopefully that is clear
and now we can move on to our next topic
when it comes to data in gatsby
effectively we have these two options we
can keep it locally
basically store it in our project
or store it in the cloud
when it comes to local data at the time
of this recording
these are our choices json format
markdown or mdx
mdx is a very cool option that allows us
to combine a markdown and react
components and as a quick side note we
will make an interesting project later
in the course using mdx
and as far as storing data externally
most likely you'll use something called
headless cms or content management
system for the most part the setup for
both options the local one and external
one is almost the same
first we need to create data
so think data first then set up query so
of course we need to pull it in and
lastly render it in the component
so either in a page component or a
typical react component now the major
difference between the two is the fact
that most likely external option offers
a graphical interface for data entries
so think nice gui and in most setups you
can add or update data later without
actually touching your project and don't
worry we will implement that in our
project as well and because of those two
reasons we'll take an external route
right from the get-go now once we have
established that we will use headless
cms for our gas b project it would
probably be very useful to learn what it
actually is
so headless cms is a concept of
decoupling your data
from your project
so if you think of traditional cms aka
wordpress the moment you want to use
your data separately
you will face many challenges and hit
numerous roadblocks and the reason for
that is very simple because it is meant
to go hand in hand with your project
now the way headless cms works is the
opposite
in most cases you'll get a gui more
graphical interface where in a matter of
few minutes you can set up your data and
then consume that data the same data in
literally any front end so of course in
our case we will use gatsby but the same
way we just as easily could have used
react svelt or even vanilla js
as far as the choices at the moment
headless cms space is a wild wild west
and if you don't believe me just visit
headlesscdms.org
and be prepared to spend the remaining
of your afternoon scouring through your
options but the two major types of
headless cms are open source
meaning in most cases it's free and i'll
talk about it a bit later what i mean by
in most cases and a closed source
basically where you pay some monthly
fees for using their service in most
cases paid options do provide a generous
free tier
so you can sign up for free and unless
you're building the next facebook it
should be more than enough now let me
also point out that while i myself
use free tier options when it comes to
headless cms open source does not does
not always mean it's completely free
once you introduce a dynamic element to
your app
for example users you'll have to host
that back end somewhere and at that
point standard hosting rules will apply
so which headless cms option did i pick
for our tutorial well that would be
contentful
before we go any further
let me just clarify they are not
sponsoring this video and i don't have
any affiliate program with them the only
reason why i picked this particular
service
is because i use it myself
i find their service really good and in
my experience you'll be up and running
in a matter of few minutes which at the
moment is probably the most important
thing
they do offer free tier
so you will not have to pay anything
they do host your data so that's taken
care of as well and their interface is
as straightforward as it gets
in order to sign up just visit
contentful.com and just keep watching
the videos since we'll set up the
account together all right and why don't
we kick things off by creating a free
contentful account
and in order to do that we need to
navigate to
contentful.com again the url is
contentful.com
then look for this get start option
and then specifically go for sign up for
free
then you'll need to provide your data so
in my case i'm going to be peter smith
as far as the company i'm gonna go with
coding
and addict as far as the email i'm gonna
go with one of my dummy ones learn code
at mail.com
as far as the platform javascript job
title other
job function other
and just get creative with your password
so it's hard to hack
and then once we set up they will send
us a confirmation email so make sure
that you wait for the email and click on
a link
and then once you get the email like i
said
click on confirmation link beautiful and
then they will ask you this question how
do you usually work with content and
essentially
they're just giving you a free trial to
one of their services so in my case i'm
just going to go with explore content
and then they will be setting up the
trial space for you and eventually
you'll get the second email where they
basically just say that you're getting
that 10-day trial now don't worry the
way we'll set up everything you won't
have to pay a dime because we'll go with
free option then we can navigate back
once everything is in place this is
going to be our dashboard
and mostly we'll work with content model
so this is where we'll set up the
structure for our data and this is where
we'll set up a content now as you can
see
when they set up this example space you
have all these entries as well as
content model however i want to start
everything from scratch and in
contentful they basically set up
something called spaces and you can
think of it as your databases and in a
free option you get only one
so that's why we'll have to delete the
example one that they just set up and we
can do that if we navigate to the
settings
then more specifically we're looking for
general settings and then notice that's
our space
and we're going to go with this delete
space option so now let me just grab the
text because that's what you need to
provide
and then once we remove it then we can
start from the scratch
and in this case we go with add a space
then we want to go with the free one
here and web app only
because as you can see rest of them will
have to pay so monthly total
is going to be zero like so so then we
click on continue and we just need to
come up with a space name so in my case
i'm going to go with gatsby tutorial
and again you can go with the example
space where they already provide a
content type as well as some entries but
in my case i'm going to go with empty
one and i strongly suggest you do the
same so we're gonna go with create space
and then once everything is in place of
course we go here and once we're done
setting up the new space we'll be back
in our dashboard however notice the
space name of course now it is gatsby
tutorial and since i went with empty
space option i have no data in here so
i'll start everything from the scratch
all right and we're going to start by
setting up our content model
and you can think of content model as a
structure for our data
so we'll be setting up the recipes
correct
now what do normal recipes have we have
title they probably have description
prep time cook time servings maybe an
image as well so of course we just need
to set up that structure and then later
of course we'll be able to add our
entries we'll be able to add our data
but we always always need to start with
content model where again we set up the
structure for our data and we go with
add content type now you can add as many
content types as you like but in my case
of course we'll have only one we'll have
one for the recipe so just go with the
name and of course the name will be
recipe now once i set up my content type
in the content model then i just need to
add those fields so we click on add
field option and notice these are all
the types that we can have so for
example for title we're going to use a
text
for the description we'll use text
however we'll use long text just so you
can see how we can fetch that data on
the front end for images we'll use media
and hopefully you get the gist so now
let's start setting up our fields and
we'll have i believe
eight or nine
and we'll start with a title so i go
with text like i said there are two
options short text or long text and i'll
show you the long text when we set up
description and for time being let's
just go with the name and that will be
title now we can go with create or
create and configure and as far as
configuration options
well you can modify the field for
example you can set up the validation
where the field is required but just
keep in mind that even if you go with
create option you can still
get to the settings of this particular
field but in my case i'm going to go
right away with create and configure
and even though during the video i'll
not set up all the fields as required
just so i can save some time
it is my strong belief that you'll avoid
a lot a lot of unnecessary bugs if you
do set them up as required because that
way when you're adding the data you can
right away see like okay i missed this
field because trust me it is much harder
to find it on the front end later so you
just go here with validation and then
for the title
i'm gonna click on required field
and in this case since we'll be setting
up the pages based on title i'll also go
with unique field and lastly i'll also
limit the character count just because
when i'm displaying them in recipes or
in home i'm displaying that in cards and
i just don't want to have long titles
where they're spanning e in two lines
again that's just my preference
technically you don't have to do that
and i'm going to go with max of i don't
know
25 characters like so
so let's save this one and there it is
now we have our first field then we'll
have a cook time so let's go with add
field
and in this case i'm going to go with
integer so notice we have this number of
course and then more specifically we can
go with decimal or integer so
essentially in this field we'll set up
how long it takes to cook the recipe and
i'll call this cook
time so i'm going to use this capital
casing again normally i would configure
where
the field is required but in this case
i'm just going to skip but i do want to
showcase that if for instance you don't
click on create and configure right away
you can still access it in the settings
so go to the settings and basically
you'll have the same models available
then we're looking for description and
again it's going to be a text however
we're going to go with long text just
because there are some differences when
we access it and i'm going to call this
description
okay we create then again how many
servings that's going to be an integer
so servings here we'll keep it as an
integer awesome
then we're going to go with our image
and if you want to add an image we go
with media and then we have options of
one file or many files
now of course the difference is when
you're accessing it the data structure
is going to be different if you go with
many files so that's why in my case i'm
going to go with one file and if you
want to follow along exactly like i code
in the videos i also suggest using this
one file now again you can use many
files just keep in mind that you might
need to do some hacking later since when
the data comes back from the contentful
the structure might be a bit different
so in my case i'm going to go with image
and i'm going to go with one file and
this is going to be the case where i'll
definitely set up my validation and i'm
going to go with required because keep
in mind that images are always a pain if
they are missing then we have featured
and essentially this is going to be the
setup where some items are going to be
displayed in recipes and home
and for about on the contact page will
only display
featured items so only the ones that
have feature property set to true and as
far as the field type well this one will
be a boolean so we go with add field and
then i'm going to go with this boolean
option and the name of it will be
featured
and then we just create here and then we
have one more integer at this point we
have cook time and servings and i'll add
one for the prep time as well so again
we go with number and more specifically
integer and then we go with prep time
here we create this one and last one
will be our content where i want to
showcase how we can set up a json object
in contentful and effectively the reason
why i want to set it up as a json object
is because if i take a look at the
recipe notice i have these tags here
which is going to be an array then i
have instructions which is also going to
be array ingredients and tools and all
of them effectively are arrays
and just to showcase how we can work
with
json data in contentful i'll set them
all up in this one field so i'm going to
go back and i'm going to go with add
field in this case i'm looking for this
json object
and i'm just going to call this content
here let's create this one
and then once we're done setting up all
the fields we just bravely click on save
and we're good to go and once we have
our content type in place now of course
we just need to
add some content i do suggest adding at
least four items
so three are gonna be featured and one
not featured because that way you can
have the same setup where basically will
display all the recipes in home as well
as the recipes but when it comes to
about
as well as contact we'll just display
the featured ones now if you want you
can set up one as featured
and then maybe the second one has not
featured that's also an option but i'm
gonna go with four and three
and the way we add the content instead
of content model where we were setting
up the structure for our data now of
course we just need to add those entries
so i'm gonna go with add recipe
and then notice what happens if i try to
publish without the title which is
required as well as my image well i'm
going to get the errors i'll have
required here
as well as required for the title and
that's why it's so important to add
those validations because that way you
can make sure that you always provide
the data because i don't want to repeat
myself but it's much harder to later
find it on the front end and in order to
speed this up i'll use the values again
from my complete project and i'll also
open up the hip sum
where i can get my dummy text
i'm not going to start with i'm baby
and then let's go back
as far as the title let's see what is
the first one
in home page we're gonna go with this
one
here so let me copy this one
copy and paste as far as the cook time
i'm gonna go with 10 minutes then for
description like i said
i'm just gonna grab from the hipster
ipsum
like so so we're just gonna copy and
paste when it comes to servings i'm just
gonna add here four
now for the images these are our options
so i can go with add media now
eventually once we add already some
images of course we can choose from add
existing but at the moment we have
nothing here so i'm just going to go
with add new
and then we can either
get it from our file system we can get
it from the search and of course you can
see all of your options now in my case
i'm gonna go actually with the file
system and then more specifically i'm
gonna look for my project because if you
remember in the assets i had the photos
for my four recipes so if i go to the
assets and then images and then more
specifically now recipes since we set up
one more directory i can easily access
them so i can say open here and of
course i'm going to get my recipe
and
with images you'll have to publish the
image first make sure you do that
and then of course you can just navigate
back now as you can see once the image
is published we are in good shape and
next one is featured so like i said i'll
set up three items with a feature of yes
and then one is going to be with
featured of no now for the prep time
i'll simply go with value of four
and up next we have the content field
where if you remember we went with json
object type
and therefore of course
whatever we set up over here we need to
follow the typical json rules for
instance all the properties must be in
the double quotation marks so for
example here i can say items and i can
set it up as an array now in order to
speed this up just so you don't have to
watch me
type the json object as well as for your
own use i provided already a dummy data
for you so if you navigate back to the
project and look for data in the assets
so first assets and then data directory
more specifically look for recipe json
and this is the example one
that you can right away use
notice this is an object i follow the
json syntax and
all my four properties
are arrays so one for tags one for tools
ingredients as well as instructions so
if you want to speed this up just grab
everything here
and then navigate back
clean out and copy and paste
now i do suggest changing at least the
tags
because if you take a look at our
complete project i'm using those tags to
showcase
how many recipes i have for one tag and
notice how this value is changing and
then we're querying
for that specific tag so we get all the
recipes that match that tag so what i'm
trying to say here is that once you save
as you move from one item to the next
one
try to change these tags around now i do
suggest keeping this food because that
will make sure that we have one tag that
has all the items but you don't have to
and of course if you want to change
these values around for example
instructions or ingredients you already
know what to do just go into the
quotation marks and just change the
value now please keep in mind you have
to have a proper jsons index so if i'll
remove this comma notice i'll get this
this is not a valid json so we always
always need to follow proper json rules
now before we continue let me stress
something
where of course this is not the only way
how you can set up the content type for
this particular project case in point i
could have just set up four different
field types one for tags one for tools
and all that and then again just set
them up as arrays
why i went this route first i wanted to
showcase
how flexible the json object is that
pretty much we can set up as complicated
as we want and second well
that way i can just provide the entire
object and my opinion it just speeds up
the data entries for you as well as for
me and as far as the tags for my first
item i'm gonna change them around and
i'm gonna say beef
and then i'm gonna go
with lunch here and again i'll keep the
food tag for all my items so all my
items will have the same food deck just
so we can see the functionality in
action and once i'm done setting up my
json object of course i have all my
fields in place so i can just publish my
entry so click here and then once it's
published if you go back to your content
you'll see that you have
one item in place
and now of course i'll stop the video
and i'll add the rest of them just
because i don't see the point of you
watching me add all my items and then
once you're done adding all of your
items then of course you can move on to
the next video where we'll connect our
gatsby application to our contentful
i successfully added the rest of my
recipes
so i have four total
and just to showcase how we can add an
existing image i'm just going to create
one dummy one so if i go with the recipe
and then if i find my image like i said
we have two options add new media where
we can get from the internet or from our
computer and of course once we add some
images of course i can click from the
current assets as well these are my
images i can just select from one of
these ones and i'm good to go and then
i'm not going to save this one so i'll
just say delete
and we're going to go with permanently
delete i guess like so and once i remove
that dummy content let me just showcase
that
for greek ribs
i went with featured false so rest of
them have features set to true but this
one has it as false so this one won't
show up in the about page and contact
page and second as far as the tags
try to set up some repeating tags
because that way you'll be able to see
better our tags functionality in action
now we have the data how do we get it
into our gatsby application well we'll
have to use a plugin for that
and i'm going to navigate to my docs and
more specifically i guess i'm looking
for gatsby and i'm going for plugins and
we're looking for content for one so gas
b source contentful we keep on scrolling
we can see that we need to install the
package and of course we need to stop
the server for that so clear everything
copy and paste okay we install the
package then we keep on scrolling and
we'll have to set up our plugin as an
object because of course we need to
provide
those options and in this case we need
to provide space id
as well as the access token now in this
video i'll just copy and paste them just
because i quickly want to test whether
we get some errors or the connection is
correct and then in the next video i'll
show you how we can work with
environment variables in gatsby so
please do not push this up to the github
after this video because if you'll do
that you'll just expose your api keys in
your source code so i'll grab this
object so i'm looking for this gadsby
source contentful
and of course i need to go to the gatsby
config i'll go below the file system one
copy and paste
and notice this is the name of course
for our result and then in the options
as you can see for a different plug-in
we have different properties so here we
need to provide a space id and the
second one will be our access token and
like i just said in the next video we
will set up proper
environment variables but for time being
we'll just pass in our values directly
in the gas b config and where we can get
those values well we need to go to our
content for one and then look for the
second ones and more specifically api
keys
and of course we haven't set up any yet
so we need to go with add api key and
i'm going to call this one gatsby
tutorial if you want you can add
description but you don't have to and
you just save it here so we save and
then this is going to be our key
and then this is our space id and as you
can see they're not hiding the space id
so we can simply copy
and then go back and again make sure
that you copy and paste correctly
within the template string
and then in this case we'll do the same
thing with our api access token but just
make sure that you get the content
delivery one so the preview one is
different
then we go back again copy and paste we
save and then once we spin up the dev
server if we don't have any errors in a
console we are in good shape trust me
if you provided some invalid values then
you'll have big fat errors in your
terminal when the gatsby application is
trying to connect to the contentful and
if you scroll up here you'll notice that
process data and then we're creating
four contentful recipe nodes so we're
fetching data we are in good shape
because i can see that i'm getting four
entries
all the four recipes that i just added
and once we have successfully connected
gatsby application to the contentful
before we take a look at the graphql so
how we can set up our query i want to
showcase how we can hide these sensitive
api keys all right so we're successfully
fetching data from contentful however
there's a major issue in our current
setup
you see the moment i'll push this up to
the github
anyone who looks at my source code can
just take my api key and that's
something you want to avoid at all cost
and in order to hide this value you will
have to use env variables now env
variables are not unique to gatsby in
fact they're part of node and then since
gatsby is not application of course we
have access to env variables as well now
if you want to see the whole setup
how it works just follow this link so in
my case i'm going to go here just
because i want to showcase where you can
get more info so keep scrolling keep
scrolling and we have two options
we have
one file the environment variables file
for development and one production now
i'll right away set up both
because you want the production one if
you run the gatsby build locally
now there's two options when we push
this up to the netlify we can either
drag and drop which is going to be a
local build option or we can do the
continuous deployment and in that case
we don't care about the production one
since we'll have to set up those values
on metal files separately anyway however
i'll right away set them both the
development one as well as the
production one so let's keep on
scrolling
again they just mentioned how you can
create these two files one for
development and one for production
and the syntax is following where for
env files we need to go with dot emv
first and again in gatsby it's
development and production keep
scrolling keep scrolling and in order to
access those values you'll have to
require the package now the package
comes already as dependency on gatsby so
we don't need to install it or we'll
have to add this line of code whenever
we want to use those values so whenever
we want to use the values that are
coming from the development or the
production one and then we just keep on
scrolling keep on scrolling and notice
in order to access we simply go with
process env and then whatever is the
variable name so let's go back to our
project
and i'll open up the sidebar
and then you want to create both of
those files
in the root and you'll for sure need a
development one but i'll also right away
set up the production one so when we
perform a local build we don't get the
errors again you create that in the root
not in a source that's extremely
important and we go here with dot env
and we're gonna go with development like
so and we'll right away set up another
file
and here we'll say production so we're
gonna go with new file and dot
env and
production
now in development one
i'll set up my variable
and i'm just going to call this
contentful
contentful api key api and underscore
key and now of course you want to go to
gatsby config and take this value now
you don't need to set it up as a string
you can leave it the way it is
and if you're wondering how come the
colors in my development file meaning in
my env file are different for the
property and the value well because i'm
using this extension let me make this
one bigger
and let me
see okay so i'm using this one this dot
env so that's the one that makes the
color values different
and then i'll save my development of
course and then back in the gatsby
config remember in order to access those
values
we need to require that package the one
that comes with a
gatsby as dependency and the package
name is dot interview so just take these
three lines of code
copying them here as well
navigate back and somewhere here
top of the gatsby config of course we
want to invoke this one so we want to
save it and then scroll down and then
simply just write process env and then
whatever e is them so in this case
contentful api key
so navigate back and save it and of
course i want to do the same thing in
production where i'll take my variable
my contentful api key and i'll just copy
and paste so now we'll save gatsby
config and again this is going to be the
case where once you restart the server
if there's something wrong with the
setup you'll right away see the errors
trust me there's going to be big massive
errors in the terminal if you don't that
means that the setup is correct and now
it's really cool
is the fact that once we'll push this up
to the github
then
these values the api key values will be
hidden because if you take a look at the
git ignore you'll see that we're
actually ignoring all the env files so
keep on scrolling and notice
dot env all of them are going to be
ignored keep in mind that if you're
setting up your own project
and if you don't have the git ignore
it's crucial that you also add all the
env files otherwise whatever we're doing
over here doesn't really matter because
it's going to be pushed up to the github
anyway now if i check my terminal looks
like everything went correct again we
can scroll up and we can see that we're
fetching data from contentful and we're
successful we're getting four entries so
now of course we just need to go to the
graphql and figure out how we can set up
the query for our recipes all right and
once we're done setting up our env
variables next i want to set up a query
where we fetch all the recipes
now in order to do that we need to go
back to the graphql and if you don't see
these fields for example all contentful
asset or the contentful recipe make sure
that you restart the sandbox and then of
course you'll see all these fields and
the ones that we're looking for is the
all contentful recipe as well as the
recipe one so we have contentful recipe
why do we want these fields well because
this one we'll use to get all the
recipes and this one we'll use later
when we set up our pages
programmatically and again not to be
redundant but what's really cool is that
the moment we install a plugin
then we have access to those fields so
it's not like you have to memorize them
or remember them they're only available
once you
install the plugin
and then of course in order to set up
the query i need to pick a field and in
this case since i want to query all my
recipes in this case
well i just need to go with all because
remember that was the rule if you want
to work with list you go with all and in
this case since my content type
is a recipe since i named my content
type recipe that's why i need to follow
the same name
and then if i want to get one specific
recipe of course i'm going to go with
content for one
now in order to set everything up we
just click on the triangle for all
contentful recipe
and then if you remember if we want to
work with that list we just need to go
with nodes
and of course as you can see we get
all the fields so pretty much
everything that we just set up in
contentful we have access to and of
course at this point we just need to ask
ourselves so for this first query
do i really need all the data
or i simply need my image i need the
title i need the prep time as well as
the cook time
and of course the answer is i only need
these four values plus the id because
we'll be setting up a list and if you
remember in react we need to use key
prop and we need to provide something
unique so we might as well
use the id that is coming back from the
contentful now later when we'll be
setting up individual pages yes of
course we'll grab not only the
instructions ingredients tools and tags
but also servings as well as description
but for time being
we really need only these four things
plus the tags so something i forgot to
mention we'll also need to get those
tags out of that content
because side by side i want to set up my
tags with my recipes so let me stop
talking and we'll just navigate back and
get those fields now where do you see
the id here so we click on id and notice
i can run it and i right away get my
array
that's my node and then in there i have
four values why i have four values
because i have four recipes and at this
point we simply need to provide which
fields we want to query so i click on a
title and in my response i'll see all
the titles
if i want to have a cook time then of
course i just need to look for that
field
and add it to my query
now i also want to have a prep time and
like i said i also want to have access
to the tags so i'm going to go to the
content if you remember content was an
object but then inside of the content
i have the tags correct so we go with
content since it's an object we're more
specifically looking for a tags which is
an array and that should get us back our
tags and lastly of course i also want to
get my image now in order to get the
image first i need to look for the field
name which surprise surprise is an image
and then if you remember in order to set
up gatsby image component we needed to
provide this gatsby image data now
something important i want to mention
you will only have access to gatsby
image data if the people who built the
plugin
made it available to you
and in fact that's one of the reasons
why we picked contentful because they
made it available
since gatsby image component comes with
version three
you might run into some plugins
that do not support that yet
and if they don't support it then your
only other option is building a plugin
yourself
where effectively you do provide that
gatsby image data now again that is
definitely out of the scope of what
we're trying to do just keep in mind
that again if you use some plug-in that
doesn't support gatsby image data then
there's no way you can use it unless you
build your own plugin now in our case
people who built the plugin for
contentful were nice enough to provide
it so of course we just need to go with
gatsby image data and then if you
remember we can run it as it is
or we can provide the options and in my
case i'm going to go with layout one and
i'll say that the images are going to be
constrained and also i'll use my
favorite placeholder which is going to
be the traced svg so once i run it
we're going to get back these giant
response with all this data i know that
it can be a little bit overwhelming
because once we add that image data i
mean the response is just going to be
massive that's why i was starting with
simpler ones like id and title and again
the main idea is following where we'll
only have access to the fields
once we install the plugin
then the field name will correspond to
our content type which in our case is
recipe now since i want to work with the
whole collection i'm going to go with
the field that starts with all
and then i can access all the fields
that i set up in my headless cms
and i just need to check on boxes and
i'll get back the values and you know
what before we go
why don't we make things a bit more
interesting and also sort our response
based on a title so essentially i want
to sort my response a to z so i'm going
to look for my sort argument and then as
far as the fields i'm going to go with
title and
when it comes to order i'm gonna go with
ascending and then once i run it notice
how we're sorting our response a to z
and once we have this setup in place now
of course i just need to go back to my
application and set up a component that
takes advantage of this query beautiful
once we have our query let's navigate
back to our project and in the
components i want to create a new
component and we're going to use that
component in two pages we're going to
use it in the recipes
as well as the home
now inside of our component there's
going to be two more components because
if you remember
i mentioned previously that
one of these components we will reuse
all throughout our application in about
pages as well as the template pages so
that's why first i'm going to go to the
components and i'll right away create
all three of them now the main one where
i'll get all the data is going to be all
recipes js and the other two are going
to be tags list and recipes list so
we're going to go with tags
list js
as well as the recipes list
recipes
list and we go with js
now in all recipes for time being
let's set it up as a component
and then we can right away import our
tags list and recipes list so for time
being we can set up a heading 4
and we can just say all recipes just so
we can see something on the screen and
then let's set up these two components
so again i'll use my snippets tags list
and we'll say this is
tags
tags list okay awesome and we're going
to do the same thing here
so this is going to be our recipes list
recipes list we save and of course in
all recipes i want to import both of
them so first i'm going to look for tags
list
and that is coming from the same folder
so i simply say tags list
and we're going to render right after
our heading 4. so we're going to go with
tags list and then we're going to copy
and paste
and we'll set up the recipes list so in
here i think i can just go
with multiple cursors
and we'll remove and we'll just say
recipes list so we save it and now i
want to navigate to both of my pages to
the index one as well as the recipes one
and just grab my all recipes component
so import we go with all
recipes from and of course we're looking
in the components
and we have all recipes component so
right after the main but still within
the layout that's important
render the all recipes
and we should get the text once we
refresh there it is all the way at the
bottom we have those this is a tags list
and you know what actually it should be
here in the main my apologies yep now it
looks better so we have all recipes this
is tags list and this is a recipe list
and the same thing we want to do in the
recipes page as well so navigate to the
recipes page
and simply go with import and then the
same import we go with all
recipes
from um we're looking in the components
and then we're looking for
all recipes and then as far as the
return
we'll have a layout then we'll have a
main with a class of page and then
inside of it let's just render again all
recipes
and then let's see what we have in the
browser so i'm going to navigate to the
recipes
now i have my component there as well
and once we have the setup in place now
let's navigate to all recipes
and set up the use static query hook so
we can pull that data so we can pull
that data into component
and then we'll pass it in into the tags
list and recipes list again why we're
doing that because recipes list will
reuse throughout our project
so set them up separately
and then we can reuse this sucker in
different pages as well
remember this is react so
you can set it up in all kinds of ways
this is just one of the ways how we can
set it up and in order to use the use
static query hook we need to have two
things from gatsby graphql first and
also we need to have this use static
query and we just need to import from
the gatsby
and after that i want to set up my query
however
i think i will use the code exporter
option because i think it's going to be
faster so again my preference is using
the page query even though i'm not going
to be setting up a page query of course
we're working in a component so i'll
just omit the export and i'll take
everything after that so i'll take const
and all the way to the closing tag
template and i'm going to copy and paste
that's my query and in order to invoke
it i just need to go with some kind of
variable and i'm going to go data and of
course i'll use my use static query and
i'll pass in my query and for time being
i just want to check whether i'm getting
back that object if i do then i'll pass
my nodes array down to tags list as well
as recipes list
so in here i'm going to go simply with
data and i'll cancel log it
just so i can see that i have something
on the screen i can refresh testing
that's where we were setting up the
gallery in this case i want to go to the
home one
and i want to take a look at my devtools
so console and of course i have my giant
object and then instead of that object i
have property by the name of all
contentful recipe and then that property
is an object and inside of that object i
have those nodes and again at this point
it is simply javascript if you want
you can destructure it here
you can say that inside of this object
i'm looking for all contentful recipe
and then more specifically nodes that's
definitely an option or just drill it
down to the nodes so first let's do the
second option where i'll still call this
data and then i'll come up with a new
variable i'll say recipes is equal to
data and then
remember the property name all
contentful
and
recipe
recipe and dot nodes
and of course if you want again you can
console log it and yes in first examples
we'll do quite a bit of console logging
and then later of course we'll do that
less and less if i refresh notice now of
course i have access to the array
and the way our functionality is going
to work we'll pass this recipes variable
down to both components to the tags list
where we'll set up some functionality as
well as the recipes list so in the
recipes list we'll just iterate over
that list and display those nice cards
now in the tags list yes there's going
to be a different functionality at this
point i simply want to showcase that
both of them effectively do the same
thing so if i'll comment this out and if
i go this route where i do the
destructuring all content full
and recipe which is an object and then
we just look for the nodes and i can
give it an alias and i can just call it
the recipes please try to understand it
both of them do exactly the same at the
end of the day you just have access to
the array
and really comes down to your preference
some people prefer
the destruction like so and some say
that this is more readable and
understand that there's no way for me to
please everyone
and therefore i'll go with whatever i
prefer the most
and in most cases here is going to be
setting up the destruction but just so
we can start nice and easy i'm going to
go back to the first option instead so
i'll set this up as data and again in a
console we'll see the four recipes and
then like i said in order to set
everything up
we'll have to pass in this recipes so
our
nodes array down to the tags list
component as well as the recipes list so
i'll set up props on both of them i'll
call it recipes and i'll set it equal to
my recipes variable and the same thing
you want to do here so we can just copy
and paste and now both
tags list and recipes list has access to
the array
and in one component we'll just iterate
over them
and then in the second one in tags
there's going to be more functionality
not bad not bad we have all recipes
component
in good standing so now of course we can
work on the other two as well
and i think since i want to get
something fast on the screen we'll set
up the recipes list first
and then we'll work on our tags list
and as far as the recipes list
well let's start by removing this
heading 4 in all recipes
and you know what as far as the return
why don't we also change this div to a
section and we'll add a class name just
so we can get a little bit of styling so
we'll go with recipes and then container
okay
awesome and then i'm going to navigate
to recipes list and we want to do some
imports first now what are we going to
be looking for i want to get a link
since cards are actually going to be
links and they will navigate to that
single recipe page and don't worry
for time being we'll have some errors
because we haven't set up those pages
yet
that's still coming up but i still want
to link right away so i'm going to go
import link from and of course i'm
looking for gatsby and i also want to
have a gatsby image because of course
now i want to display those images but
for dynamic data we need to use gatsby
image component so we go with import
we're looking for gatsby image
that one is coming from gatsby plugin
image
those are our two imports and now of
course we just need to set up the
functionality now i know that i'm
getting my recipes prop correct and
that's where i have my recipes all right
so i'll simply destructure it right away
in the parameters and since i will use
it all throughout my project i might as
well set up a nice default where i say
that if recipes are not provided
then the default value will be empty
array so again that way you just avoid
some unnecessary errors
then as far as the return
i want to iterate over my recipes
so the list that is going to be passed
in and for return we're going to go with
div
and we're gonna add class name so we get
a little bit of styling recipes list
and now let's iterate over our array so
inside of this div
i'm gonna set up recipes that's the name
of course for my prop and i know that it
is an array and as far as the parameter
i'm just going to use the name of a
recipe and what i want to return for
each and every recipe well let's just
start very simply
by saying return
and we're going to go with paragraph and
i'll say
recipe title just so we can get
something on the screen and of course
then we'll work on more meaningful
return and how do i know that the title
property is there well i simply know
that because when we take a look at our
graphql what do i have there i have the
nodes and then inside of this node i
have my tile property and don't worry we
can also cancel log here and you'll
definitely see that as well you'll see
that object and then once we save we
have banana pancakes and rest of them as
well and again if you want to double
check where we're getting this info now
again there's going to be some warnings
because we're not using the key prop yet
don't worry we'll do that but take a
look at our console we have four objects
so we have an array and i'm just
iterating over that array and then for
every item i'm getting back this object
so now of course we just need to
construct
our return
so it looks more like this
like these cards here
and the way we're going to do that i'll
write away the structure those
properties out of my object so we go
here with id
we also want to get a title we want to
get a image and we're going to go with
prep time
and cook time cook time here and all of
that is coming from my object and as far
as the return i'll right away wrap it in
a link and i'll provide a dynamic value
so the way it's going to look like i'm
going to say link and then we need to
add a to prop so where we're going to
navigate once we click on this link
however in this case i want to set up a
dynamic value so unlike the previous
cases where i was hard coding i said go
to the forward slash home or about or
whatever we need to keep in mind that
eventually there's going to be a page
for every item and the url is going to
be forward slash and whatever is the
name of my recipe now there's going to
be some magic
where we'll add these hyphens in between
as well and when i say we of course i
mean gatsby but we don't need to worry
about that just worry about the fact
that we need to set up our links with
forward slash and whatever is the name
of the recipe just keep in mind that we
have four so that's why we access this
variable name where we say okay so we're
going to navigate to
and we'll set up here a curly braces
because we want to go back to the
javascript plan and since i want to
access a variable i'm also going to set
up right away a template literal i'll
say forward slash
and then whatever is my title so we're
passing in this dynamic value for our
url okay let's save that one so now of
course we have them as links but like i
said we haven't created those pages so
of course the moment you'll click on it
you'll have the error page because
notice these are all the pages we have
and we don't have one for forward slash
banana pancakes or greek cribs or
vegetable soup we will create those
pages later but i right away want to set
up these dynamic links where the values
depend on the title
that we get out of the recipe
let me just navigate
back to the home page or recipes it
doesn't really matter
and then inside of the link
why don't we also right away set up a
gatsby image and so i want to set them
up as cards now i do want to add a
little bit of styling here and i'll say
recipe that's the class that is coming
from my main css and also since i have a
list in react i need to add a key prop
and something dynamic now in this case
something dynamic and unique is going to
be my hedi something that the contentful
already provides for me and then inside
of the link i right away want to set up
my images so i have the card
and each card has the image and of
course that represents that particular
recipe and i already imported a gadsby
image component since i have dynamic
images the value of course is changing
from one recipe to another one so it's
not the same so it's not static and here
we go with gatsby image component we
have image prop and initially
i will drill down to the property by the
name of gatsby image data
and then later we'll use
the helper function as well again if
you're a bit lost of what's happening
remember we are querying
for the image and then inside of that
image we have gatsby image data object
this is a giant object that provides all
the necessary values to our component to
our gatsby image component and this is
also where we passed in our options so
now we simply need to go with image
that's the name of the property and
inside of it we have this gatsby
image and data property that's all we
have to do now i have some css in place
so we also want to go with class name
and recipe hyphen img and also as far as
the alternative we can simply pass in
the title so whatever we have as a title
value we can just simply pass it here
i'll close it
and then once we save notice we have our
nice images displayed on screen as well
and then right after the gatsby image
i'm going to go with heading 5 with my
title
so i'm going to go back to javascript
plan and i'll access the title variable
and then we have paragraph with two
values we have one for prep time and
second one for the quicktime so let's go
prep
and colon and let's access
the variable so prep time here
and then second one will be cook time
and you know what let's also add here
min
and i'm going to add that vertical bar
and i'll say cook
and of course this one will be cooked
time so we save it
and if we navigate to the bigger screen
there should be no warnings in the
console okay that's good
and we can also see the prep time as
well as the cook time now as you're
hovering
notice these errors we'll have them for
time being so these are different these
ones are because gatsby is trying to
prefetch that page which will eventually
set up and of course at the moment the
page doesn't exist so don't worry about
it we'll fix it later now one thing that
is missing here is cook
and i also want to add a min
and then let's also utilize our helper
function so at the moment i'm accessing
my image property and gatsby image and
the way i set up my contentful the image
field is required but just in case the
image is missing so there is no image
property but i'm still trying to access
a property on that image since i don't
want to get that big fat error i can go
with my get image remember that was my
helper function
and simply
we can set up a new value again i'm
going to go with path to
image
and that will be equal to get image and
then i simply need to provide my image
property so i go here and instead of
image we simply go with path to image so
once we get to the object
where the
gatsby image data is sitting we are in
good shape notice we provide that one
and everything works now if you'll mess
this up nothing bad is going to happen
so if by mistake i type here recipe
that's not going to be a direct parent
of my gatsby image so once i save notice
my images are just missing but i don't
have those errors so this bug does not
break my application which is super
super cool and that's why
the get image helper function is very
useful so i'm going to go back to my
image again that's where the
gatsby image data is sitting and once i
provide that i get a proper path and
we're in good shape where we have the
recipes list in two pages we have it in
homepage as well as the recipes page and
since we can access recipes as props
that's our setup in our recipes list
will just provide different value for
recipes so in this case i'm providing
all my recipes whatever i have currently
i have four but if i'm gonna have four
thousand then of course i'll provide
four thousand in the all recipes however
you'll see how in different setups we'll
provide different data
and while we still have our query in
sandbox
why don't we do just that why don't we
worry about rendering recipes list with
different data in different pages and
then we'll switch back to the tags list
because there's also a bit more
functionality we need to do in order to
showcase the tags like i have
in the final project so first
i want to go back to my sandbox and now
let's think about the changes we need to
make
first i don't need to have tags here so
i can simply go back to my explorer and
remove the tags so i'm not looking for
them i also want to change little bit
images so they're a bit different so
instead of the placeholder option i'm
going to go with a blurred one and
probably the most important part is the
fact that in this case i want to filter
my response i want to get only the
recipes which have featured set to true
and remember we can combine
all these arguments so i simply go back
to my filter argument
and then i'm looking for the featured
one where it is where it is where it is
yep there it is that's my featured and
i'm going to go with equals option
and notice how it right away tells me
that it is a boolean so either i can go
with true or false and in my case i just
want to set feature to true so only the
items
who have featured set to true so in my
case three items those ones will be
returned again it's going to be very
hard to see
in our response because of course we
have that gatsby image data now if you
want you can just scroll down
and you can take a look at the total
count that's one of the options let's
scroll down and in my case it's going to
say 2 which is weird because i told you
that i set three of them so let me
quickly fix that i'm going to go back
here
and
let's say greek ribs
okay that one was for sure no
and let's see vegetable soup and this
one i just didn't set up so by default
it is going to be just false so
something to keep in mind but then
remember two things first every time you
modify data in contentful make sure that
you publish the changes otherwise you
won't access the latest value so make
sure the one that you just modified you
also have it as published not just
changed and second
we need to restart our project because
we want to get the latest data so i'm
going to go with clear npm start i'll
spin up my dev server and then i'll just
have to wait a little bit and then once
i have the latest data my total count
should be equal to three and once the
dev server is up and running if i
refresh
and if i run it
and if we take a look notice of course
now the total count is three which is
exactly what i was looking for so now i
can remove that total count
and i'll simply use my code exporter in
this case i do want to use the page
query because we'll be setting up this
query in the about page then we want to
navigate back to our project and i'll
start with about page
where below my component
i will set up my query okay awesome
that is working then we want to make
some imports here as well so at the
moment we have a link we have static
image but i also want to get that
graphql from the gatsby so make sure
that every time you set up the query you
also import this graphql that is a must
and then of course i want to get my
recipes list again keep in mind
something we're not talking about all
recipes all recipes has both it has tags
list and recipes list in this case i
just want to grab the recipes list and
we'll provide the value
that we're getting back from our query
so that's how we can reuse it in
multiple parts of our application and
every time we'll pass in different value
so every time we'll just change what
recipes are rendered so
in the about.js i'm going to go with
import and i'm looking for recipes
and a list from and i'm looking in the
components and then recipes list i
scroll down
and then
right next to my first section i'm going
to create another one now there's right
away a class
so i want to add a little bit of styling
and therefore i'll go with featured and
then
recipes like so and then inside of this
section let's start with a heading 5.
and let's just type look at this awesome
sauce
awesome
sauce exclamation point and then let's
go with our recipes list and what's
really cool since i have in a recipes
list this default value if i don't
provide something by mistake for example
then nothing bad is going to happen so
if i navigate back to my project and of
course i want to take a look at the
above notice how nothing bad is
happening right so everything still
works so if i take a look at the console
yeah i have these ones but they have
nothing to do with my current setup but
if you go to the recipes list and if
you'll remove this one then you'll right
away have the big fat error because
you're trying to render a component and
that component is looking for a prop
it's looking for a recipes prop however
in the about page we're not passing
that's why it's always nifty if you add
those default values and again this has
nothing to do with gatsby or react it's
just straight up javascript where i say
you know what if the recipes are not
provided well simply treat it as an
empty array and that way of course we
don't have anything on the screen
but what's important is that we also
don't mess everything up and before we
deal with the recipes if you ever have
this type of situation where you can see
that the image is not loading try
running gatsby clean so i'm going to go
back i'm going to stop my server and
then we simply run gatsby clean
and then we're going to go with gas b
develop
and you'll see that everything is going
to work once in a while you might have
something all stuck in a cache
so
that's the reason why you have this bug
so if i navigate back and if i refresh
notice how everything works smoothly and
of course i have my heading 5
and
at the moment i don't see any recipes
because we're not passing them in and if
you remember the difference between the
component query and the page query is
the fact that with a page query we don't
need to use our hook we simply can
access it if we take a look at the data
property and in order to check that we
simply go with data as you can see i'm
right away structuring and i'm going to
go with console.log and data
so once i navigate back once i refresh
and all the way in the bottom i have my
object and then inside of it again i
have all contentful recipe and nodes and
all that now the difference of course in
this case is that this nodes array is
smaller because we're only
getting the items
who have featured set to true and again
if you want you can assign it to a
variable
just like we're doing in all recipes but
in my case i'm going to go with the
structuring in the function parameters
so i'm going to go back to about.js
and then here i'll say that instead of
the data there is a object by the name
of contentful recipe
and then inside of that recipe object i
have nodes and i'll right away give an
alias of recipes again at the end of the
day
the functionality is exactly the same
where now i can scroll down and since
the recipes list is looking for recipes
prop i can simply pass in my recipes and
now if you navigate to about page and if
you refresh
by the way
here i guess i'll have to save it one
more time and there it is now of course
i have my recipes however these ones are
the featured recipes and i know i said
this before but what's really really
really cool
is the fact that we can reuse this
component so i can do the same thing in
a contact page i simply need to go there
and first i guess i want to start with
my imports and you know in order to
speed this up i will copy and paste so
i'm looking for these two suckers
and we're gonna do copy and paste okay
awesome
that will do the same thing with a query
okay awesome and then all the way in the
bottom in the contact page we'll set up
our query and then the same thing we
have access to the values in the data
and in this case again let me switch
back to the drilling one where i'm gonna
go with recipes is equal to data
and then the value was all
contentful
and recipe
and then nodes correct and of course i
just need to scroll down we're gonna go
with the same section just like we have
in about.js so i think it's gonna be
faster if i just navigate back here
select my whole section and render it in
the contact page as well and now if i go
back to my big browser i can clearly see
that i have my featured ones in the
about page as well as the contact page
again
main takeaways are following
where we change our query a bit so we
look for different fields and i removed
the content one then i added another
argument in this case we're filtering
for the recipes that have featured set
to true and then we just set up two page
queries one and about and one contact
and in the page queries we access it
directly in the component so we don't
need to use the hook
and we need to look for the data
property and from there the setup is
exactly the same where we have the
component which is looking for the
recipes and we just render the recipes
list component and provide the value for
the recipes prop
not bad not bad i think our project
looks nicer and nicer
the moment we can display the recipes as
well
and up next i want to work on a tags
but there are two major issues
you see unlike the recipes
we're not going to be able just to
iterate over tags
why well because tags are actually an
array e inside of the items so we have
array within the array and moreover
there's a content property as well
that's number one so our data structure
is more complicated for the tags and
second
check out this is the result that i want
so i want tags
i want them in the alphabetical order
and i want to showcase well how many
food items i have
with that tag for food i have four and
then for beef i have only one
so it's not like with recipes where we
just took the array iterated over and
then displayed the image title and all
that unfortunately we'll have to do a
bit more work and if you don't believe
me
we can just navigate back to the project
i'll close everything here
i'll close the sidebar
and here as well and let's just simply
go to components we're looking for the
tags list here and then remember we're
passing in the recipes right so i'm
going to go with the recipes and then if
we cancel log
you'll see that of course the structure
is more complex so i'm going to navigate
to the home page
or recipes page it doesn't really matter
since we render in both pages in the
console and i guess i'll have to refresh
in a console eventually i should see the
tag list and that's again one of the
unfortunate things where you need to hop
back and forth just to get the latest
results
and as you can see so that is my array
those are my four items
and then those tags
are inside of it
so we have here a content property
and then inside of it we have that array
of tags
and that's why we'll set up a separate
function now why are we setting up the
separate function to pull out those
particular tags well because there's
going to be more functionality and i
want to reuse that functionality in the
tags page so i don't want to set it up
here and then copy and paste we might as
well then just set up a separate folder
and
call it utils and then reuse that
function so here's what i want to do
i'm going to go back to the source i'll
create a new folder and i'm going to
call this utils
once i create that folder then i'm going
to create a new file and i'll say setup
tags set up tags and it's simply going
to be a function so i'm not going to set
it up as a component i'll say const and
then set up
tags and it's going to be looking for
one thing as an argument it's going to
be looking for my recipes array so i'll
just name my parameter recipes
and then for time being i'll just return
the recipes
i mean we don't have any functionality
yet and then of course i want to export
it
and since i'm not going to have more
functions here i'm just going to go with
export
default and then
setup tags and now of course i need to
go back to the tags list
and then import the function correct so
we're going to go with import and you
know before we import one and we also
cancel log just so we can see that our
import works because
it's the worst thing ever if you spend
half an hour on functionality and then
something doesn't work but it's not the
code it's actually the fact that you
messed up on the import so i'm going to
go with hello
from utils here just so we can see that
our stuff works and back in tags list
again i'm going to go with setup
tags from and of course i'm looking in
the utils
and more specifically setup tags and
instead of console logging the recipes
why don't we go here with setup tags and
i'll pass in the recipes
and eventually we'll get some new tags
back so i might as well come up with
some kind of variable there
and i think i'm going to go with new
tags so i'm going to say const new
tags is equal to a setup tags and then
we pass in the recipe so once we save if
everything is correct
then in home page
or in recipes page it doesn't really
matter we should see hello from utils
and that's awesome that means that our
function works at least the initial
functionality and now we can just head
back
and pull out those tags
from our array and before we continue
let me just stress something this is by
far not the only way how you can do it
i set up my functionality in a certain
way just because i thought that it's
gonna make way more sense for gatsby
tutorial and if at any point
you get stuck and you need more info i
suggest referring to the javascript
nugget series that i have mentioned
already quite a few times because in
there i cover the topics that i'm going
to use to set up the functionality and
also eventually i'm planning to add a
video
where i specifically tackle this topic
and i try to do in multiple ways
and lastly if you have a better approach
don't be shy to share it and i'm going
to start here by just looking at the
recipes and we need to understand that
of course recipes is an array correct so
my approach was following where i'm
gonna create a new empty object so i'm
gonna go with const
all tags is equal to an empty object and
then i'm gonna set up a for each
and i'm actually gonna iterate twice
i'm going to iterate over recipes but
then remember
since tags was an array itself i'll also
iterate over those tags so every time as
i'm iterating all the recipes i'll set
up a forage inside of that recipe over
the tags as well so go here with recipes
then for
each
and then
we need to set up some kind of parameter
that will reference the item and in my
case i'm going to go with the recipe and
then instead of my function body like i
said tags are sitting where
they are sitting in the content correct
so we need to go with recipe not recipes
but recipe so that's that individual
recipe then we have content property and
then we have the tags property which is
an array so again we can use the for
each and in this case i'm going to call
my item a tag and inside of this
function well we can start simply by
console logging the tag so you can see
what is happening again i'm going to
navigate back and then notice in the
console so these are all the tags i have
and first i just want to add them to an
object
and not only i want to add them to the
object i want to make sure
that i add only the unique tags that's
number one because if you take a look at
the complete project i only have the
unique ones so they're not repeating
and second
i want to count them
i want to know well how many food i have
how many i don't know dinner or whatever
so how many similar tags i have so i'm
going to go back and remember we have
all tags object and here i'll simply set
up the functionality where i'll say if
all tags object
has this particular tag
then i just want to add plus one
basically i want to add one value to
that tag because if i have four foods
then of course i want to count them now
if the item is not there if there is no
property on that object then of course
i'm going to create one so i'm going to
go with all tags and tag
so if the property already exists i'm
going to go with all tags and
tag plus 1. initially it's going to be 1
and then every time there's a repeating
tag we just add plus one now if the tag
doesn't exist which can be our second
option we're gonna go with all tags
and we'll create that property and we'll
set that property equal to one and in
this case i'm not gonna cancel lag tags
anymore i just want to console out the
alt tags just so you can see what is the
result of our iteration and as you can
see we have a object and we're counting
the tags so for beef we have one for
breakfast we have one like i said in my
case i set up
four food tags just so the functionality
makes sense and of course i have two for
lunch as well as soup and actually we
are in pretty good shape we have the
unique tags we have the values and all
that but there's two more things that i
want to do i want to turn this back into
the array that's number one
and second i do want to perform sort one
more time to always make sure that we
definitely have our values
based on the alphabetical order so
they're always sorted so i'm going to
navigate back i have all the tags and
then i'll create a new variable i'm
going to go with const new tags and that
will be equal to the object and then
entries and if you're not familiar with
this method it returns a property and
value
in the array and i guess the easiest one
is to showcase by actually console
logging
new tags and if you go back to the
console notice now i have array of
arrays each item is set up as an array
like i said property and the value
and then that is all sitting in one
giant array and once i have this one in
place now i want to error proof it by
running sort on this array so i'm going
to navigate back and we're going to go
with sort method
now sort method iterates over array and
we can access every item on that array
and they're represented by some kind of
parameters and in my case it's going to
be a and b
now since we're sorting based on the
alphabetical order we need to keep in
mind that of course i want to access the
string
not the value because at this point i
have an array as an item not just one
simple string and in order to access
that string i'm just going to go with
const and then i'll rename it first tag
and that is coming from the a now this
is actually arrayed structuring the
first item is going to be an array and
then from the array get me the first
item and again if you want you can
cancel log it and you'll see that we're
getting both strings so we're going to
go with second tag is equal to b and
then lastly
as far as the functionality for the
sorting i'm just going to go with the
return
and then first tag and then we have this
awesome method in javascript where we
can right away compare strings based on
their text i can say locale compare
that's the function name and then i pass
in the second tag so not set up tag
sorry second
tag as a result you'll see that we are
comparing those string values and we'll
always make sure that they are in the
alphabetical order and of course
eventually i just want to return the
tags so i'm going to go with return and
instead of recipes we're going to go
with new tags so if we go back to the
tags list
and if you console log
new tags
you'll see that again we have this array
of arrays
and these items are always going to be
in the alphabetical order and each item
is going to be array and then inside of
that item we have a string so that's
going to be the value and then we have
the actual number so this represents
well how many tags with this value we
have and from then of course it's the
same thing we just need to iterate over
and then display
the links to the tags pages awesome and
once we have our array in place now
let's just iterate over it
and then set up the links to the tags
pages again we do not have those pages
yet we don't have for example page for
the carrots and in that page we display
all the foods that have a carrot stack
now we don't have it but eventually we
will set it up
and therefore we'll have right away
links to those pages
and the way we're going to do that in
tags list of course we're not going to
cancel log anymore that's it we have all
the tags and we just need to work on the
return
and here simply we'll say that we're
returning a div with a class
of tag container tag
container and we're going to start with
a heading 4 here
so say
heading four and we're going to go with
recipes
so we save it because now we have the
heading four and then there's going to
be another div
with a class of tags list
so let's go with tags
list and then instead of this div
now i want to iterate over the new tags
array so we're going to go with new tags
and we'll map it over and then instead
of the callback function i'll reference
each item as a tag and we also need to
get an index because of course we have a
list in react and then as far as the
return let's just simply start by
returning a link and then we'll add all
the necessary data so i'm going to go
with link now that is a named import and
it is coming from the gatsby like so so
for time being let's just display
all the tags here
so i'll simply say
that i'm displaying a tag yep there's
going to be some errors and all that
don't worry about it and as i said no
for some reason i have here a template
string so these are going to be all my
tags okay
that's good but just keep in mind that
this is an array
so it's not a string or number it is
actually an array so again we'll have to
do that array destructuring just like we
do with use state i'm going to go with
const and then the first item i'll name
it as a text and the second one will be
value and again both of them are coming
from the stack because it is an array
and as far as the link first i'm going
to set up the key prop because of course
i have a list in react and i'll pass in
that index that's number one then inside
of it i'm gonna go with two values i'm
gonna go with tag value and then the
actual value as well however i'll place
this in parentheses now again this is
just for
display i mean doesn't do any
functionality as far as these
parentheses and we'll say a value so
again we'll save it one more time now
you can see that these are all my tags
okay nice and then lastly i just want to
set up a to prop and it's going to be
based on tag name now i notice here that
i messed up a little bit it's not a tag
should be here a text now of course
it's going to look like it should and
back to the prop we're gonna go with two
and again we're not hard coding this
value because eventually there's going
to be a page for every tag and therefore
we go here with the curly braces we will
set up a template string because i want
to access the value here and we're going
to go with forward slash and then we're
going to go with text so again the
moment there is no such page so once you
save and then once you navigate to a
beef page of course it doesn't exist
don't worry we will set up those pages
shortly and once we have our tags list
in place
we should see that in home page as well
as the recipes page and while we're
still on a topic of tags why don't we
set up a tags page now the only thing we
need to do here differently is setting
up a graphql query so i want to get a
query where i specifically only get the
tags now keep in mind that the structure
actually is going to be exactly
like we have in all the recipes so if
you go back to this component notice of
course we have the query we get the
recipes of course we're using nodes and
all that now in the tags page though
we're only interested in this content
property with a tags property because
keep in mind that we'll still get back
the array so we'll be able to pass the
array into our setup tags function and
of course we'll get back that array of
arrays and if you want to see how the
tags page is going to look like in
complete project we have the tags here
and then once we click on it we just
navigate to that specific page where we
get only the food items that have that
tag that's it that's all we have to do
and i guess first let me start here by
setting up my query and simply i'm going
to be looking for contentful recipe and
you know what i'm just going to remove
everything and i'll start from scratch
and i'm going to go with explorer of
course i'm looking for all contentful
recipe i still want to get the list i
still want to get all my recipes then
nodes but in this case i just want to go
with content and then tags that's it
that's all we have to do we run it and
notice again i'm getting back this array
of actual recipes
of course and instead of that recipe i
have content property with a tags so the
functionality in our utils function will
still work so that doesn't change we're
just not grabbing the rest of the items
in the object
and in order to export it i'm going to
go with code exporter
i'll grab here my query of course now i
just need to navigate to the tags page
so let's go to the pages directory there
it is we have a tags
below the component i'm going to copy
and paste okay awesome then i'm going to
have to set up some imports so i'll go
with import then graphql
that's for my query and then the second
one is of course link because again
they will be links both of them are
coming from the gatsby and also i want
to get those setup tags so in here i'm
going to go with import setup tags and
it's coming from my utils so let's go to
the youtubes folder and setup tags and
then instead of the component we're
going to do the same thing where we go
with new tags is equal to a setup tags
and now of course remember with a page
query
where we can access this value so where
i can get the nodes
and of course the answer is in the data
property so we can destructure the data
property and then pass the value into
the setup tags now of course i need to
pass in the nodes because setup tags is
looking for that array so we simply go
here with data dot
all contentful again
all contentful and then nodes and as i
said note i need to add here a recipe
recipe like so and now of course we just
need to iterate over that array and
display something meaningful in a tags
page so for them being i'm just going to
go to the tags page
and then as far as the return
i'll still go with a layout okay that
still stays the same i'm gonna go with
main
tag here so let's set up a main tag and
we'll also right away add a class name
of a page
so let's save that one and then instead
of this main tag we're going to go with
section and we'll add a class name of
tags page
so a little bit more styling and then
again the same deal we'll iterate over
those new tags and then for every tag
we'll display a link
to the tags page so let's go here with
new tags then map again i'll reference
each item as a tag and then we need to
have a index
and in here i'm going to go with const
and again i'm looking for text
and value that is coming from my tag
and then as far as the return well we'll
simply go we return
and then we're going to go with link
here
and we'll close it out and inside of the
link in this case i'm going to go with
heading 5
and as far as the value i'll pass in the
text and you know there's also a tiny
bug i just need to add here a
parenthesis and then right next to the
setting five i'm gonna go with a
paragraph i'll pass in the value
value here and i'll say a recipe and
then the same deal as far as the two
prop it's going to be a dynamic one so
therefore we're gonna set up template
strings we'll say two and then i want to
access my
text value
now i do need to add a index so we're
going to go with key and we'll pass in
the index again we have the list in
react that's why we need to do that and
lastly a little bit of styling so add a
tag class as well and once we save we
have ourselves a nice tags page and this
is going to be the look on a small
screen
and this is how it's going to look like
on a big screen
and once we're done with our tags next
we're going to cover extremely important
and interesting topic and that is going
to be how to set up pages
programmatically beautiful our project
looks pretty nice but every time a user
clicks on the tags or the recipe he or
she
sees the error page why well because we
haven't set up those pages
and so far in the course every time we
needed a page
we rushed over to pages directory and
then created either a folder
or a file
and then the moment we created that file
of course we have the page
but before we do that with tags and
recipes we kind of need to think about
it is this really the best approach
am i really going to go over all my
recipes and create those pages manually
and the same with tags
and what for example if i change the
name for the tag or name for the recipe
am i really going to hop back and forth
and then try to manually keep my project
up to date with my headless cms and of
course the answer is no a better
solution in gatsby is creating pages
programmatically and we'll take a look
at two approaches
one approach that's pretty much the
latest and greatest is file system route
api
and the other one is setting it up in
gatsby node and since i want you to be
aware of both approaches
for the tags we'll use the gatsby node
and that one is coming up and then for
recipes we'll use the file system route
api now since there's a lot to unpack
we'll do a bunch of small videos
and also in the beginning just type out
the code with me
and then i'll go over everything in
detail so first i want you to go back to
your files and once we're here we need
to look for pages directory
so that's not changing however we need
to create a file with a very funny name
so basically i want you to set up the
curlys and right away add js
and then in here remember when we were
setting up the query we used a field by
the name of all contentful recipe now in
your case if the name is different
please use that name but in my case it
was all contentful recipe and now we
need to type that field without the all
i'm gonna go with contentful contentful
and make sure that the syntax is exactly
the same so again if the name in your
case is different if you're named your
content type differently make sure you
use that name otherwise you're just
gonna get an error so i go with
contentful recipe again without the all
up front and then i need to look for
specific field so in my case i'm gonna
go with title and of course later i'll
show you that we have other options as
well so once you create this file
then of course i can zoom out
so we create a file and then i'll use my
snippets to create the component now
this gives me this funny name of course
i don't want to use this name so i'll
remove it and i'll just say
recipe
and then template and inside of it i'll
do the same thing there's going to be a
heading 4 with the text of recipe
template so we save it and just to be on
the safe side i'll restart the server so
i'll clear everything i'll close the
sidebar and we're going to go with npm
start and once the server is up and
running i'll show you something
extremely extremely cool and that is the
fact
that we created
pages for all our items
so if you go to a localhost 8000 and
then just navigate to a page that
doesn't exist so in my case i'm going to
go with another page that is obviously
not there and now notice something
interesting
i have pages now but the value e is 12
and if i keep on scrolling keep on
scrolling
check it out we have one for vegetable
soup one for greek ribs and one for
banana pancakes as well as the last one
here we iterated over our recipes and
created page for every recipe now
granted
there's not much here we just have a
recipe template but trust me this is a
huge huge deal and then like i said
since there's a lot to unpack i'll
divide this into multiple videos
just so you're not overwhelmed by the
amount of info all right and i guess
let's start with the most pressing
question first
what just happened
well
what just happened gatsby was smart
enough to run
this query and then for every recipe
gatsby created a page
and the url of that page is actually
equal to the title and then if i were to
have i don't know 20 more recipes i'll
get all those 20 pages
the moment i set up of course my query
and the reason why we went with title
here is because gatsby uses that
property value when it sets up the url
and since i want my urls to be more
user-friendly since i want text instead
of just some random id
i prefer using the title now keep in
mind you can use other properties that
are in the object as well you're not
limited to the title one and notice how
this needs to be in the curly braces and
then we need to add still this js and of
course this is the field without the all
and then i pass in the title so i go
with dot title now
you can set up a different property so
for example if you don't like the title
then of course you can go with dot and
then id
but the difference of course is the fact
that the id is going to be used in the
url
and in the typical setup you want your
urls to be friendlier
and that's why you use some kind of text
and effectively it's called slug
if you're not familiar with that and
what's super super super cool is the
fact that notice the url
gatsby is smart enough to take our title
and then basically turn it into a slug
into a usable url because if you're
familiar with urls we cannot have a
space in between so gatsby sets up
everything in the lower case and adds
that hyphen in between and as a side
note our current project still has the
issues with the links that we created
together and don't worry we will fix it
in a second because at the moment if you
take a look we actually still have the
error if we click on this link because
check out the url again we still need to
fix it but when gatsby creates the pages
usb is super smart and it right away
sets it up as a slug
okay hopefully that is clear so you can
set up the query over here just make
sure that you follow this syntax and
then remove the all so in your case if
the name is different make sure that you
use the same name and then more
specifically that title so for every
recipe i have gatsby will create a
new page using
this template
and then in the url
i'll have the title of my recipe
and you're probably wondering okay but
what's the big deal i mean at the end of
the day i still have the recipes
template that's it that's all i have
well remember that recipes template or
recipe template to be more correct is
still a page correct
and remember that behind the scenes gods
be passed in a lot of useful information
when the page was created and the same
works over here
if you go to the recipe template and if
you type props and if we can't log it
you'll notice something pretty pretty
cool so let me navigate back i have my
greek ribs now let me go to another page
just so you can see the difference and
again the easiest one you can just
navigate to the narrow page and you'll
see all the pages that you have in your
project so in my case i'm going to open
up a new tab and i'm going to look for
my banana pancakes and let me refresh
just so i know that for sure i'll see my
props and if i open up the dev tools
check it out
now of course i have this params
property
and in the params primary i have a title
and what is the value here well that is
greek ribs now you can probably already
guess that if i go to the banana
pancakes page and take a look at the
same dev tools i'll have a different
value and you're correct because notice
we still have this params property and
inside of that object we have title now
this style of course is different the
same how the url is different so for
every title we create that page and this
is why it was important remember when
we're setting up the headless cms
i set up a unique value for my title
so that way of course if i'm creating
the pages i specifically create page for
every item instead of creating i don't
know some duplicates or something like
that and now of course we can try to
access this title
and i'm going to navigate back again
remember the property name was params so
instead of the heading 4 why don't we go
with adding two here
and we'll simply drill down we'll say
props
then params and the end title so now of
course you'll notice that i have banana
pancakes here and then in greek ribs
of course the title is different the
title is unique to that page and again
this is super super super super useful
to us because now we don't have to
manually create those pages gatsby does
everything for us
now there's still one piece missing and
that is the fact that of course we need
to go back to this recipe template and
we need to set up another query
and in this case we'll be looking for at
one specific item
so when we're setting up those pages we
use this query so for every recipe we
created a new page
but
in that template we'll actually have to
set up a single query and in that query
we'll use something that we covered at
the very beginning and that is a query
variables
now first let me just showcase where you
can get more info about the file system
api
and simply go to the gatsby docs again
and then we're going to go with search
and we're looking for
file system
file system
and
route api that's the one that we're
looking for and here you can find all
the info so again there's more setups
available
and like i say notice here they go with
pages and then in the product they set
up the query you can set up a path
inside of the folder as well just like
we did previously with examples and then
we have the query and notice how again
they're not using this all so they're
looking for all the products but they
don't add this all and then by default
there's always going to be this id but
then since they add dot name so that is
a different property then of course they
get the name here as well now why is
that important because we can also use
the id
when we're fetching data about that one
specific recipe and behind the scenes
they say that it is faster if you do it
that way
but i mean in our case we're just gonna
use the title now as far as if you have
a bit more nested structure if you have
a recipe and then you have the field
that you're looking for inside of the
field that is an object so if it is a
subfield then you go with a property
you're looking for that is on the nodes
object and then in this case they go
with underscore underscore and then they
look for the skew so again in our case
if we were to have another structure
then we go first with a contentful
recipe then dot the property name where
is that nested structure and then you
look for the actual property so again if
you want to find more info just navigate
here but in our case we're pretty much
done setting up the pages
programmatically as far as this approach
now of course we just need to connect
the dots and set up the query in such a
manner where it's dynamic because keep
in mind again this is not just one
single page basically we create page for
every recipe so somehow we need to make
our query dynamic
where we can pass in that title value
and based on that title value we'll get
specific info about that one recipe
not all of them but that one specific
recipe and of course by doing so we'll
actually have the pages for every recipe
item
all right and before we take a look at
how we can pass in dynamic values into
our queries so how we can start using
the query variables let me just fix our
tiny bug
where currently in our project if i
click on one of the cards on one of my
recipes i don't navigate to the page
and technically the page is there
so this shouldn't be happening now the
reason why is that happening because we
just take the title and then we pass it
as our url however if you take a look at
the syntax that is not allowed so when
we're setting up the url we need to have
hyphens between the words now we don't
have this issue with the tags so for
example
if you go to home notice tags is just
one word anyway so it doesn't really
matter so this is going to work we're
not going to have to do that in a tags
list however with the recipes list we
need to sluggify our title now
alternative is setting up another field
in the headless image and again common
name is calling the slug which just
represents a
friendly url
and you can manually set this up some
headless cmss offer this option where
when you enter that field it right away
has the type of slug and it does that
for you in strappy as you're typing the
title in our case it right away creates
the slug for you like so that way we
don't have to do this extra work but
since contentful does not do that and
since i don't want to go back and
manually add them as slugs i'll show you
how we can set that up programmatically
and in order to do that we'll have to
install another package and again this
is not a gas b plugin this is just a npm
package and the name is sluggify so we
go with npm and of course we need to go
with install and we'll just run slugify
we run this one and then once the
package is in place i'm just going to go
with npm start then we need to go to the
recipes list
and of course i want to import that one
so i'm just going to go here with
sluggify
logify and that is coming from the
selectify so i get my function and this
function will return
my title
in a manner that is acceptable as a url
and we're going to create a new variable
i'll call this slug and this is going to
be equal to the sluggify then we pass in
the title and then we'll set up some
options
and we do that by just passing in the
comma and then the object this will take
this string and this will sluggify for
us so this will make it in a syntax that
is acceptable as the url and here in the
object we just say that we want to pass
in the lower
and we'll say that it is equal to true
so i want everything lowercase
and pretty much we're done because by
default it will add the hyphens in
between and now if i change this around
and instead of title
if i access the slug
you'll notice something pretty cool now
once i click on one of those cards we
will correctly
navigate to our template if i go back to
my home page and if i click on banana
pancakes there it is now of course we
navigate to banana pancakes now at the
moment we just have the heading for
there don't worry we're gonna work on
that next but the idea is that every
time you click on one of those cards we
correctly
navigate to the page
because that's the url that gadsby set
up for us because again this is the
syntax we need to use when we set up the
urls we cannot have spaces in between
and with this in place now let's focus
on the query that will fetch the data
about this one specific recipe
beautiful so how we can make our queries
dynamic
first let's back up a little bit
and cover the basics we learned in
previous videos so first i just want to
remove everything and i'm gonna go with
my explore option
and specifically i'm looking for
contentful recipe field now we already
know that this works so there is no
issue here but of course we'll just get
some random recipe because in order to
get a specific one of course we do need
to provide what well we need to provide
the arguments correct so if i go here
with the title
yeah this is awesome if i'm looking for
vegetable soup but if i'm not looking
for vegetable soup then of course this
is meaningless because yes of course i
can access for example cook time here
and everything is going to work
but if
i'm looking for my banana pancakes i
mean
what good does it do for me nothing
okay so why don't we do this why don't
we open up a new graphql sandbox
just so i can get all the names since i
will use them and in this case i'm gonna
go with graphql okay awesome and instead
of this one i'll remove it we're going
to go with explorer and let's go back to
all the recipes so we're going to go
with all contentful recipe then we're
looking for notes and i just want to
grab the title and we're doing that
because i want to copy and paste and i
think it is going to be faster and of
course once we run it we get all the
recipes and more specifically we get
titles so now of course we can go back
to our
first sandbox
and in here i can add the argument
correct i can open up the explorer again
and i can say you know what get me the
recipe whose title
matches to whatever i'm passing in and
of course in order to do that i just
need to look for my title 1 here and i
need to say equals
and simply we can start by copying
pasting and in this case i'm going to go
with banana pancakes
so i'll pass it in and then once i run
it i can clearly see by my title that
this works
so that's an awesome start of course
because now if i'll add more fields here
i'm going to get a specific data
about this recipe
not just some random one and of course
we control that with our argument so now
let's take a step further
i want to pass this in as a variable
and i must warn you that in the
beginning
is going to look useless you're going to
be like well it's pretty much the same
thing but trust me there's a reason why
i'm showing you that first i'll just
give it a more meaningful name i'll say
get
single
recipe and now let's set up the variable
you see we can pass in
variables into our query
now the way it works first we need to
instantiate the variable and syntax is
following where we go with a dollar sign
and then the name of the variable
now i'm going to go with the name of
title but here sky is the limit just
keep in mind that later
we'll have access to the title variable
simply because that's how we set up
those pages programmatically
so i strongly suggest you use the same
name and then we just need to say
what is going to be typed for our
variable and i'm going to go with string
okay
that's a start
and of course i misspelled it here it
has to be a string
and then of course i can use that
variable
so in here instead of saying equals to
whatever text i'm passing in
i'm going to go with equals and of
course now i need to use my variable and
i'll say title after that in query
variables what i want is to set up a
object and of course i need to give it a
name for my variable which has to be
exactly the same so since i'm using
title here of course you can guess that
i'm going to use title over here as well
and of course i'll do the same thing
where i'm going to navigate back and
i'll just select one of the recipe
titles and if i go back and if i run it
now of course i get a specific data
about this one recipe
and i'm controlling that using the
variable
and like i already mentioned probably
your first thought is following okay but
what's the big deal
i mean the only difference is that now
i'm passing in my string
where i have the variable
instead of passing it directly in the
query but the end result is the same
every time i want to get that specific
data
i need to pass in that value and you're
correct
but here's the kicker
what if i go back to my recipe template
and i'll import graphql here
so i'll say graph ql
coming from the gatsby and then below my
component i'll set up my page query
and we do that by export then const and
query and of course we just need to
provide the value correct because we
have the graphql so let's set up a graph
ql tag template and i'll set up the
template strings and of course i just
want to copy and paste this query
so i'll grab it
i'll copy and paste and let's console
log the props one more time so let's go
with props here
and let's see what we get back
so if i'm gonna navigate to vegetable
soup one and if i'll refresh you'll
notice something interesting where in
the console i have the object again
that makes sense but what do you see
here in the page context
i see the id
and i also see the title and remember
how in one of the previous videos i
mentioned that when gatsby sets our
pages programmatically it actually makes
query variables available by default it
will pass e and the id and then whatever
field you set up in a query of course in
our case that field is title
and as you can see we can access those
variables in a page context property
now what's even better when it comes to
query gatsby will pass that value
automatically
so we don't even need to do anything
just make sure that the variable name is
the same
and again in our case the name has to be
titled since in query the field that
we're using is title and once we do that
we are good to go so here when we are
setting up our single query we just say
that yes there is going to be a title
variable coming in and for every page
that value will be unique so we won't
have to do that manually gatsby will do
that behind the scenes the only thing we
need to do is set up a query with a
variable where we say yes we set up the
file path using the tile property so now
this title will be set up as a variable
and that value will always be unique and
it will represent the actual title so
therefore if again we go to banana
pancakes in this case we can see that
the same thing works here where now i
have the page context and of course i'm
getting the banana pancakes so basically
what that means is that we just need to
go back to our sandbox get all the
properties that we want for specific
recipe and then we'll be able to access
that in our template and then for every
recipe we will set up this unique page
so i go to my recipes and i can click on
any of the recipes and in there there's
a query that gets specific data about
the recipe and just pulls it in
so that way of course we can have the
page for every recipe hopefully that
makes sense i fully understand
that this looks scary a bit in the
beginning where we have the syntax of
setting up the variable we need to say
that it is a string
and then of course we just use it
somewhere in our query that's why we did
everything step by step where first i
showed you how we would do that manually
then we pass in the value ourselves and
then lastly just remember that whatever
you'll set up here e in the file path
is going to be available as a variable
that's why i said that in my case i'll
definitely use my tile variable so if
you use the different property of course
then use a different variable and then
once we pull the data we're pulling data
for that specific recipe nice and once
we know how we can access the variables
in our sap template now let's set up a
proper query in the sandbox and of
course then we'll use it in our template
as well so let me scroll up a bit
now we just need to
explicitly say which fields are we
looking for
so i'm going to grab all the content
ones and look for ingredients
instructions
also check the tags and tools then i
also want to get the description but
just keep in mind that since description
is a long text it's actually an object
so if we want to get the value we need
to go with description and then
description so if you run it notice this
is going to be my recipe and if i keep
on scrolling i have description object
and then the actual value is inside of
it with the same name that's just the
contentful setup after that i want to
look for prep time
as well as the servings and finally
let's not forget about the image correct
so we're going to go with image we're
looking for gatsby image data
and then i want to go with a layout that
is constrained and also i want to go
with my placeholder and i'll set it
equal to the traced svg so again i just
grab this whole thing now
and copy and paste
in my template in recipe template so in
a graphql i'll remove
whatever i currently have and copy and
paste
and in next video of course we'll set up
the return but first i want to grab
all the imports
and then i'll also destructure it right
away and you know i'll start by removing
these props
because we need to understand that this
is a typical page at the end of the day
so
the data that we're getting back from
our query is going to be available in
the data property remember every time we
were setting up the page query the
return was available in data so the same
works here i was just showcasing the
props for two reasons first the query
variables are available in the page
context gatsby provides them but i was
just showcasing where you can find them
don't worry you don't have to go with
page context and then dot title i was
just showcasing what variables are
available to us that's number one and if
you want to access directly the title
property you can either go with
pagecontext.title or
params.title now in our case
i don't want the title because i'm
getting the title here anyway so it
doesn't really matter and that's why
i'll remove the heading 2
and also console.log for props we'll
simply get back the data but before we
do any destructuring i just want to set
up my imports and i'm going to go with
import and first i want to get the
gatsby image
then i want to get a image function
so from and that is of course coming
from gatsby plug-in image
i think i can make this one smaller a
bit
and also i want to get some icons
because if you take a look at our
complete project notice i'm using these
icons for the recipe so we might as well
import them right away and this one is
going to be a bootstrap one so start
with bootstrap and then clock
and history
then we have another one with a clock
and the last one
will be a people one so let's say
bootstrap and people and that is coming
from the react icons and we go with
forward slash and of course the
bootstrap one
that should do it and after that i wanna
destructure all our data just so we can
see what we're getting back
and here i'm gonna go with const and
i'll set it equal to the
data and then what is the field name
well that one is this one the contentful
recipe if you want you can give it an
alias but in my case i'm just going to
go with dot and contentful recipe so i'm
getting back the object and then instead
of that object i have contentful recipe
property and the property is an object
itself so now of course i can pull out
the titles the cook times and all that
so in here let's just go down the line
we're going to go title
cook time
and content
as well as prep time
prep time we have servings here and also
we have description but just remember
that description is an object itself so
we're going to go with description is an
object and then more specifically we're
looking for description property inside
of it and then lastly i want to get the
image so i'll say this one and then
right below it why don't we set up the
path to image right away so we're gonna
go with const and remember we just need
to pass in the object where the gatsby
image data is sitting so we simply go
with some kind of variable path to
image is equal to get image or helper
function and then of course we pass in
the image object
and right below this one i want to pull
out from the content if you remember
content was an object with those arrays
with ingredients instructions tags and
tools and
i will iterate over them so that's why i
want to pull out all of those arrays i
want to pull out the tags instructions
ingredients as well as the tools and we
simply do that by again setting up
another line for the structuring where
we go with tags
instructions
then ingredients
just need to make sure that i don't do
some dumb typos because i'm an expert on
doing that and that one is equal to the
content again
tons of ways how you can set this up
if you want you can structure it here or
even in parameters it only depends on
your preference for this example i just
chose this one there's really no rule
that says that you can do only one way
and you cannot do the other way and then
as far as the return
let's simply set up our page
as well as the div inside of it and then
next video will display everything so
for time being i'm just going to go with
a main tag
and add a little bit of class name we'll
say here page
and then inside of this page we're going
to go with div with the class of
recipe page and then instead of this div
since i want to see something on a
screen again i'm going to go with a
title one so for time being there's
going to be a heading two
with my title just so i can see that my
destruction works and now of course i
just need to navigate back to homepage
or recipes
then look for one of the recipes
and then once i click
check it out of course i have my banana
pancakes now just double check yep this
is going to be four degree ribs
and of course what's left to do
is just grab all of these properties and
set them up in a meaningful return not
bad not bad i think we're done with the
structure so now of course let's work on
return but you know what i think i
forgot in a previous video to get my
layout so i'm going to go with import
layout from and of course we're looking
in the components
and then more specifically layout so now
let's scroll down and then let's just
wrap our return
in the layout so that way we'll get our
navbar as well as the footer and once we
save of course now everything works
and then
there's going to be two parts of this
return first we're going to have a hero
where there's going to be a image with
the title description some icons as well
as the tags and then we'll get another
set of columns where we'll display
instructions ingredients and tools so
i'm going to go back to the page to the
recipe template and i'll remove that
heading 2.
i'll add a comment for the hero this is
where i'll set up my section with the
class of recipe
and then hero
and then we'll right away set up another
section where we'll place a rest of the
content so rest of the content and again
this is where the instructions the
ingredients and all that so i'm going to
go with section and again same class
name recipe
and content
beautiful
and then let's start working on hero
first
and we're gonna have another two column
layout where one is going to be a gatsby
image and then the second one will be
the article with the rest of the info so
we just start here with our component
remember image prop and then we pass in
the path to the image that should work
and then as far as the alternative i'll
use the title property
now i did a little bit of styling to the
container so i'm going to go with class
name and about img let's close it and
yep of course i have my gatsby image so
that's the first column now the second
column
is going to be my article
with a class of recipe
and hyphen info
and then inside of it let's go with
heading 2 where we'll display title
properly now and i'll scroll down a
little bit and then we'll right away
grab the description and then remember
the biggest gotcha between the long text
and the short text is the fact that
description is an object itself so if i
scroll down notice that's my title and
this is my description and the only
difference is that this is sitting
inside of the object so keep that in
mind then there's going to be a div
with a icons and
right next to it there's going to be a
paragraph with a tags so let's right
away set up the structure
we're going to go with recipe
icons like so so that's where we'll set
up the content and you know what in here
i'll say icons and then right next to
this div
we will place the paragraph so say here
tags
and then we'll just basically iterate
over our tags and display it inside of
the paragraph and i think we can start
with this one so i'm going to go with
paragraph and then the class name is
recipe tags again a little bit of
styling and then as far as the text i'm
just going to go tags and then colon and
i want to go with tags map now remember
tags is an array
and in this case
we're not passing it through the setup
tags the helper function we created this
is just write up array
and i'll reference each tag with a
parameter of tag surprise surprise and
i'll also set up my index so tag and
index because i have the list and i need
to use a key prop and as far as return
well i want to grab the link so it's
kind of funny in last video i was
getting all the imports and i missed out
on two important ones so scroll up and
just look for the link from the gatsby
and then let's return here and then
we'll go with return we're returning a
link to now in this case again keep in
mind
the url will point to a page that we
haven't created yet
in the following videos we'll set up the
tag pages in a similar fashion now we'll
use gatsby note for that but the idea is
going to be the same
where for every tag there's going to be
a page set up programmatically for time
being we'll just navigate to the error
page
and we pass in two now this is going to
be dynamic again and that's why we need
to use the template string forward slash
and then we access the tag here so i say
tag
and then we need to add a key here
so key and that will be equal to an
index and then inside of this link let's
display the tag so save and there is now
of course we have tags and these are all
the tags again these are links so once
you click on them you'll navigate to the
error page and then eventually we'll fix
it now emmett i guess or the formatter
he is trying to help me so i'll just
remove this one
this really has nothing to do with our
return
and then i'm gonna swing back to the
icons and then in the icons we'll set up
three different articles pretty much for
every icon that we have and then of
course we'll add some text there as well
so i'm gonna go here with article
and in the first article i just want to
display my clock
so i'm going to go here not clock
history just clock
and again that's just a react icon and
it is a component so we go with heading
5 with some text so prep
prep time here let's save that one yep
and also let's actually access that
dynamic value so in here i'm going to go
with a paragraph and we're just going to
go with prep time and we'll add here min
as well as that and that's our first
icon so now let's copy and paste and we
just need to change the values
so there's going to be three of them
second one will be a history one and of
course this will be a cook time and the
property also
is going to be a cook time and then
lastly we have servings so we're going
to go with a bootstrap people one
and in here
let's access the
servings value
and let's also change here
the text let's say we're getting the
servings
and once i save and once i refresh
i should see three of them now of course
i have all my three shotguns and lastly
we just need to scroll down where we
have the recipe content and we'll have
to set up a two column layout one is
going to be four
instructions and the second one will be
for ingredients and the tools but again
the idea is exactly the same where they
are arrays
so i'll set up some kind of html element
and then in that element i'll iterate
over those arrays and return something
so for example for instructions i'll
return this step 1 2 3 and whatever and
then these will be the values for
ingredients i'll simply iterate over the
list and hopefully you get the gist so
let's go back we have a recipe content
and we'll start with setting up two
columns first one will be article and
it's not going to have any classes so we
simply have an article and then the
second one will have a class
a second column second column
as you can see i was a bit lazy with the
class name here
and then inside of the first article
this is where i want to set up a heading
for with the text of instructions and
you can probably already guess that
we'll iterate over our instructions
array since that's the name in my
heading 4 so we'll go here with
instructions it is an array so we can
use a map and then i'll reference each
item simply as an item just because i'm
lazy and then as far as return well
here's the thing i want to return a div
and instead of that div i'm gonna go
with my step
as well as the actual instruction so
let's go back and we're going to go with
return
then i said we're going to go with div
we do need to add a key prop we say here
index
and then also let's add a class name and
we'll say single
and hyphen instruction
and then instead of this div i'm gonna
go with a header
and in there i'll set up my paragraph
with that text off step so i'm gonna go
with paragraph and then step now for the
step you can set up the index however
it's not going to make sense because
you'll have step 0 1 2
and i think it makes more sense if we
add just plus one we start with step
number one instead of step number zero
and then right next to it i'm going to
set up a div and there's a reason for
that that's how we have this horizontal
line so let's save it and now of course
we have the line as well and then right
next to the header so not within the
header right next to the header i'm
going to go with paragraph and i'll say
that i actually want to render that item
meaning my instruction
and now of course i have it
now as you can see i was pretty smart
and i iterated over the ingredients so
my bad i need to go back to instructions
instead
and of course once i do that i have my
proper instructions
then we're going to scroll down to the
second column
and we'll set up two more divs in a
similar fashion
one for ingredients so the suckers that
i was trying to render a second ago and
then of course also for the tools so the
setup is gonna be almost the same we're
gonna go with div here and then
we have a heading four with ingredients
hopefully i'm spelling this correctly
then we're going to iterate over
ingredients and then of course we just
need to go with our map again i'm going
to be lazy and i'm just going to say
item
so whatever ingredient i have i'm going
to reference it as an item
and then when it comes to return
we're going to go with paragraph we do
need to add the key of course so we go
with index
then let's add a class name of
single
and then ingredient
and then instead of this paragraph let's
just showcase the item
and of course i have my ingredients and
at this point i think i'm just going to
copy and paste because it's going to be
faster so everything starting with this
div and ending with the closing one just
copy and paste
and we just need to change some values
around where of course we have the last
array and the name is tools
so we go with tools then we're not
iterating over ingredients we're
iterating our tools i still reference
this as an item
and then the class name will be also a
little bit different
we'll go with tool and once we're done
with our tools of course we can navigate
to the bigger screen
and that's our banana pancakes page
and of course if i go to the different
page this is going to be a recipe page
for that recipe and hopefully you get
the gist
again key takeaways we can use the file
system route api to set up those pages
we pass the value the property value as
a variable and then of course we can set
up those queries
using the variable name so in our case
of course since i'm looking for the
title property i have access to the
title variable there i get that unique
value and of course i can set up my
query and get the data about that one
single recipe nice i think we're in good
shape
now we have a page for
every recipe where we display
all the useful info
and of course this data is only about
this recipe so we get the title
description and all that and now i want
to do the same thing for the tags
however for the tags we'll take a look
at another way how we can set up pages
programmatically
and
prior to the file system api which was
introduced i believe
at the later versions of gatsb2 gatsby
node was the only way how you can create
pages now don't think that gatsby node
is a old way how you can create pages
yes of course you can use the file
system route api and it's an awesome way
how to set up pages because you can
basically do it faster because you'll
see in a second that gatsby node is a
bit trickier however don't dismiss this
approach and there's a reason why i'm
showing that because there might be some
cases at least in the current gatsby
setup where you still need to use the
gatsby node approach because it just
gives you more flexibility now if you
want to find out more about gatsby node
just go to the docs and more
specifically look for
gatsby node and essentially the way it
works
we can respond to events during the
build life cycle and we do that using
the special functions that are provided
for us so in our case we'll use a
function by the name of create pages and
you can probably already guess by the
name of it what this function does so
yes it creates pages for us
that should do it for theory now let's
head back to our project and we don't
have the template folder we don't have
the gatsby node so let's just start with
that so unlike the previous setup where
we directly set up the page inside of
the pages directory
a common approach when you set up the
pages in the gatsby node is to create
another folder so let me just close
everything here so i can start from
scratch and then in the source
again name is up to you but a convention
is calling this template like so let me
zoom in that's my template and then
instead of this template you create
another file as always you can go as
wild and crazy as you want but a typical
approach is just calling it whatever
page you're going to be creating so in
our case we'll be creating tags pages
and that's what i'll call this tag and
then hyphen and then template and then
of course i'll add the gis now i do want
to create a component here so i'll use
my snippet and again i just need to
change these values here because of
course i cannot call my component like
that and i'll just say tag
template and then instead of this div
let's just say tag
template and page and once we have our
template in place
next i want to create that gatsby hyphen
node.js file again this is the case
where name matters
and also the location so don't set this
up in the source
make sure that you're in the root
and then in the root go with gatsby and
of course
gatsby and then hyphen node and js
so that's my file name and of course now
we're back in the note line and you'll
see why it's important e in a second
also keep in mind that every time you'll
type something in a gatsby node you will
have to restart the server that's why
i'll try to move somewhat slow since
that way i can avoid some unnecessary
typos and bugs
and as a result
you don't have to watch me constantly
restarting the server
and like i said
we have the api provided already for us
meaning those functions that we're going
to be exporting are already provided for
us so we just need to access them and
the setup is somewhat similar to what we
have here in the gatsby config
notice we have this module
and then we're exporting the object
correct and i mentioned previously that
the property names here are important so
the same works in a gatsby node where
again we go back to the node lan and
that's where we use the node syntax the
common js one where we go with exports
so now we're exporting
and the function name is important so we
are creating a function here and the
function name is create pages so now
gatsby knows all right so this is going
to be a create pages function and you
just need to provide the values and i'll
do the rest
now from this function we need to return
a promise and if you're familiar with
javascript we can either use promises or
we can right away set up async await and
this is going to be my approach where
i'll right away set up the create pages
function as a synchronous function
because that just means that by default
it's going to return a promise and it's
going to be easier to work inside of
this function because we'll have to wait
for some promises to be settled now
since this is a function we actually get
parameters and more specifically we're
looking for the parameters of
graphql again this is provided by gatsby
it's not like i'm just making this up
and then also the actions object and
then right away instead of the function
body i wanted the structure even more
from the actions i want to get a create
page function so i'm going to go with
const and then create page and that is
coming from my actions object keep in
mind that of course if you want you can
structure it here instead i just thought
that it's going to be easier for you to
understand if we do it in new line
and once we have our function
now i want to set up my query and
essentially the idea is similar to what
we have here in the pages so if we take
a look at the page folder we can see
that we have our contentful recipe title
and the idea is the same here where i'll
have my query
i'll get back the result
and then i'll iterate over
those nodes
and then for every item i'm going to
create a new page
now of course the difference here is
that we're going to be a bit more
explicit where in this scenario gasby
does a lot of things behind the scenes
so we just set up the query and we're
good to go we say yeah get me all the
recipes and then behind the scenes
gatsby creates the page as well as sets
up the url and all that good stuff in
this case we'll have to do more manual
labor and first we want to start by
invoking this graphql now idea is
exactly the same where we pass in the
query however since we are in a node
land so this is not a react file now of
course we need to use the parentheses so
there's a little bit of different syntax
and essentially the way it works i'm
going to come up with some kind of
variable and i'll call this a result
and then i'm going to wait for this
promise to settle because this graphql
returns a promise and since i set up my
function my create pages function as
asynchronous i can just use a await
keyword inside out function and here
like i said we go with graphql
so graphql but instead of tag template
we are going to go
with a parenthesis because this is
different this is a node file and then
we'll set up the template string now
second you're probably wondering okay
but what kind of query we're going to
pass it in well the one that gets the
stacks so if i go back and
[Music]
if i take a look at my sandbox and you
know what i'll remove everything here
and then i'm just going to set up a
query where i'll query the all
contentful recipe field
then i'm looking for the nodes
and more specifically i want to look for
the content
and then tags
and you'll notice that once i run my
query
i get all my tags and that's exactly
what i'm looking for so now of course
we'll just have to set up the
functionality and gatsby node where
again we iterate over
the nodes array and then more
specifically we iterate over the tags
array inside of it
and then for every item we create that
page
so hopefully that makes sense just like
we set up regular queries in the
components in the pages as well as with
a file system route api we do the same
thing in gatsby node now in this case we
do need to provide the
value that is exactly the same as in our
sandbox because if you remember
in here the syntax was different correct
we use the field without that all in
front of it now when we're working in
gatsby node no the query needs to be
exactly the same and i think i'm going
to start by giving it a bit more
meaningful name first and i'll say get
recipes
so then take everything here
and navigate back and copy and paste
and just so we understand what is
happening i will cancel log it now that
just means that i'll have to restart the
server and i'll have to stop it one more
time because there's more code coming up
but since i want you to be aware of
what's happening i will do it so
i'm gonna go with log
and i'm just gonna
set up some hashtags here
and then i'll just showcase what we're
getting back so the idea is that we
still have access to this data object so
that doesn't change now of course the
difference is that we're working in the
gatsby node and you can probably already
guess that we'll have to use somehow
this create page function and for now i
just want to showcase what we're getting
back as a result and notice right away
the moment i open up the terminal it
says develop process needs to be
restarted to apply changes in gatsby
node so always always
whenever you do something in gatsby node
remember to restart the server and then
since i have those hashtags i just need
to wait
for my dev server to spin up
and once it's going to be in full gear
somewhere in the terminal
i should see the result now if you don't
see anything if there's some errors or
whatever please troubleshoot because
it's important that we get back this
data and hopefully you can see i have my
object and then inside of this object
now i have the data property and as you
can see the result is tiny bit different
because if you remember in components we
were right away
accessing the object
the data object that we're getting back
in this case
we're getting the whole thing so i get
the whole object so that's also
something that we need to be aware of
and once we can access it now of course
we just need to do a little bit of
javascript magic where i want to iterate
over the nodes then access the content
and then more specifically tags and then
for every tag we will run that create
page function
and we'll have to pass in that variable
manually if you remember when we were
setting up the pages with a file system
route api
gatsby provided that variable for us
correct in this case we'll have to do
that manually and the way we do
everything and by the way just so i can
have more room i will remove my terminal
for time being and then i'm going to go
with a result
so that's the object that i'm getting
back the property name is data then more
specifically i'm looking for this all
contentful recipe
like so copy and paste then i want to
access nodes property and i want to
iterate over it and i'll use my four
each and i'll reference each and every
item as a recipe
so far so good
then of course i want to access those
tags now because keep in mind i'm just
iterating over the recipes so i'm just
iterating over my notes what i'm looking
for is actually the tags since i already
created pages for recipes i don't need
to do that now i want to access the tags
and we do that with the help of recipe
then content
because that is the property name then
tags and then one more for each so we
set up two four eaches and then in this
case i'll reference
my tag with a tag parameter
and then inside of this function this is
where we finally call this create page
and then in the create page we pass in
the object with three properties we need
to set up the path so what is going to
be the path
for the page so for example remember
when we set it up for the recipes
meaning technically gatsby set it up for
us we had a forward slash and then the
title for recipe now in this case we are
in charge so what is going to be the
path well i'm going to set up my
property first and then i'll say that
the path will be forward slash and then
whatever is the tag value because if you
remember
when we were setting up the links
in the tags
meaning in the tags list this is what i
used
so i have access to the text and i just
passed it in the url so now i'm doing
exactly the same where i go with path
and it's going to be forward slash and
the tag name now nothing stops you from
adding more info here
you can go here with tags and then
forward slash and then tag
now the reason why i'm not doing that is
because when i was setting up my links
for the tags of course i just used a
forward slash so sky is the limit here
just keep in mind that both of those
values need to match and therefore i'll
remove this tags one and i will save it
and once i have my path in place next i
need to provide two more properties i
need to provide the component
as well as the context property where
we'll pass e and d variable now why do
we need component because we'll need a
template because if you remember when we
were setting up the recipes pages
well the file was used correct so the
file where we're setting up the query
that was used as a template
however in this case we're doing this
manually so we need to point to some
type of template and of course we
already have the template folder and
then inside of template folder we have a
tag template so that's the file we're
going to use so this is where we'll
eventually set up the query with a query
variable just like we're doing in the
contentful recipe title one now
i think i'm going to rename it my
apologies i think i set it up as
template and actually want as a template
and then back in the gatsby node now i
want to set up a component property so
let me close my sidebar and make this
one smaller and again the name here is
extremely important you cannot call it
whatever you want you need to go with
component and then that one is equal to
the path to the component however since
we are in a node file
we need to provide a proper path and in
order to do that we need to use one of
the built-in modules and node and that
one is the path one again the syntax is
gonna be a bit different because we use
common js syntax and we just look for
path so this one we don't need to
install it comes pre-installed with node
and of course we have access to a bunch
of properties and methods that this
module provides now the one that we're
looking for is path dot resolve which
basically will point to the directory in
our case it's going to be a root and
then from there we want to point to our
tag template.js so i set up here the
parentheses and then i just say that in
the source look for templates templates
and then forward slash tag template
if you have a different name please make
sure that you use that name instead
otherwise you'll have the bug
then
i need to set up the last thing and that
is actually the variable so again
something that gatsby does behind scenes
when we use the first approach in this
case we need to explicitly pass that
value in and the way we do that the way
we pass in that variable is by using the
context property and it is an object and
now we just need to set up a key value
pair
so first one is going to be the name for
my variable and the second one will be
value so in my case for the name i'm
going to go tag and as far as the value
i'll pass in the tag as well so this
will be the name that i will use in my
query and this provides me the value so
now of course i just need to save it
and restart the server and if everything
is correct
once we navigate to the error page
you'll see that we created
more pages in our project so now we're
programmatically creating pages for all
the tags
so let's see that i'm going to clear
everything and we're going to go with
npm start
and once dev server is up and running
and if i don't see
some massive errors in the terminal
we should be in good shape where once we
navigate to a page that doesn't exist
you'll see that we have more pages in
our project so let me just go to the
browser hopefully everything works i
will refresh
and yep i should see it so notice the
amount of pages i have
now we have 21 so for every tag we also
set up a page so if i navigate to the
food of course i'll have my template and
we can test it out in our project where
either in a tags page or in recipes or
home just simply click on a tag now of
course i navigate to a breakfast one so
if i'll go to the food then this is
going to be a food template and
hopefully you get the gist where again
for every tag that i have i'm able to
set up a dynamic page and in that page
eventually there's going to be a query
and i'll use my variable to access
specific values and let's just go back
and go over the setup where again we
work in gatsby node
we need to set up that file first it has
to be in a root and since it is a node
file we use a common js syntax with
require as well as exports
we create a function by the name of
create pages and the name is important
now we do need to return a promise from
this function so we right away set it up
as async and as parameters we have
access to graphql function as well as
actions object now from the actions
object we access a create page function
and then first we set up the query now
since the graphql returns a promise we
wait for it to settle
and the difference in the syntax is the
fact that since we are in a node line we
set up the parentheses and then inside
of the parenthesis we go with a template
strings and then we pass in the query
then just like with a normal query we
get back the result and then we iterate
over our list now in our case not only
we are iterating over the recipes
since the tags are sitting inside of the
recipe and is an array itself we
actually iterate over recipe and then
inside of the recipe we look for tags
and then we create a page for every tag
and we do that by calling a
create page function where we pass in
the object with three properties a path
property which just sets up a path in
the url for that page so forward slash
and then the tag name
then we point to a component and this is
where we use the path module where we go
with resolve which points to a directory
where the file setting in our case that
is of course our route and from there we
just point to a specific template which
in our case is sitting in the template
and then tag template and eventually we
want to pass in the variable since we'll
use it e in the query and we do that by
setting up the context property it is an
object and then we just need to come up
with a name of the variable and the
value so in our case we're setting up
the variable with the name of tag and
the value for this variable is equal to
the current tag in our iteration and as
a result you'll have more pages in your
project that are created
programmatically using gatsby node not
bad not bad once we have the tag pages
in place i think we can simply start by
console logging so i think at this point
i can close the gatsby known one and
then back in the tag template remember
these are still pages
and we can access of course all the
props so in here i'm going to go with
props and i just want to specifically
show you where we can access the value
again
this is going to be done technically by
gatsby so we're not going to have to
worry about that but i just want to
showcase where are we getting the
variable from so if you go here
and then expect and of course this is
going to be for the food and of course
in this case again i'll have to
probably cancel log for some reason i
thought that i'm going to skip that part
and there it is now of course i can see
my path
and then notice that page context
same how we had with a previous setup
but of course the difference in this
case is the fact that in the previous
video we set up that variable
correct we set up that variable and
here's the value so now of course again
we can set up the query
where we look for specific recipes that
match the tag and now of course we just
need to go to the sandbox and set up the
query for that where we use this
variable name by the name of tag
and i'm going to leave this one open
just because
of course i'll grab once in a while some
tag values just so i don't have to type
it out and i'm going to go to the second
one to my second sandbox and i want to
repeat one of the previous queries
because we need to keep in mind that
eventually
when we're setting up the tags page
it's not going to be a single return
like we have in the recipe page no
what's going to happen in the tags if
you remember we have the recipe list
component
and essentially i'm just going to get a
array of recipes and i'll use that
component to render those recipes
if you go to tags where the value e is
for
notice now i have the list so the same
list that i'm using in the home page
same list that i'm using in recipes page
as well as about page and hopefully you
get the gist so this setup will be a bit
different where we're not rendering info
about one tag we basically get a bunch
of recipes that
have that tag value hopefully that makes
sense so now let me navigate to my
second sandbox
and here i'll repeat our first query i
want to get all the recipes that's why i
use all contentful recipe then
specifically i'm looking for nodes
and as far as which
properties i want i want to get the id
so select it here then i also want to
have a prep time and cook time because
remember that's what the recipes list is
looking for it's looking for a list of
recipes and more specifically those
values so we look for prep time cook
time then i also want to get a image
so let me see i have the image i have
gatsby image data and
i just want to set it up as constraint
so as far as the layout is going to be
constrained and also for the placeholder
i'm going to go with my favorite one i'm
going to go with traced svg so that of
course gets me all the recipes
now i want to sort them first and second
i want to filter them and i want to
filter them based on a tag so first
let's sort them and we're going to do
that by saying all right based on the
title field
and we're going to do the ascending one
so we just go here we run it and now of
course we are sorting it alphabetically
okay that's step number one now second i
want to filter based on a tag and
remember in the gatsby node
that's the variable that we're passing
in in the gatsby node the variable name
is tagged so set it up exactly the same
in my sandbox where i'll say
filter
and then
as far as the value well
it is still going to be a content
because the tag of course is sitting in
the content so i'm going to go with
content then tags and then equals so
effectively what we're saying here is
get me the recipe
where one of the tags is equal to the
one that we're passing in so set equals
and for time being why don't we hard
code this and i'm gonna go with food so
we can get more values
so i'm going to go here i'll pass it in
and once i run it this should get me
four of them now if i'll use another one
if i'll use beef
then of course i'll get only one value
correct
so we go here we set up the beef and
this is gonna return only one value
hopefully that is clear again it's
exactly like our previous setup and now
i'm just gonna give it a bit more
meaningful name and i'm gonna say get
recipe
by
and then tag
now i want to set up my variable again
since i'm passing in the variable by the
name of tag i'll set it up exactly the
same in here once i tag it is going to
be a string now of course instead of
hard coding this value it will depend on
my variable name so i just need to go
with a tag and then in the sandbox of
course we'll have to hard code that
so again we open up the query variables
we set up the object and in here i say
tag and let's just use the same one
let's say food let's run it and again
this will return
all the recipes since i added that tag
to all the recipes but then if i'll use
i don't know i believe one of them was
soup
then i'm gonna get less because
less
recipes have that specific tag and now
of course the setup is exactly the same
where i simply want to take this one and
something to keep in mind where if you
go with code exporter
notice how it omits the setup it omits
the query keyword as well as the name so
that's something to be aware of that if
you'll just copy and paste essentially
you'll get an error so make sure that
you do this manually with me so we're
going to navigate back to the
tag template page
then we'll set up our query
and probably it's better if we import
first the graphql as well as the recipe
list because we'll iterate over
so go with graph
ql from
and then of course this is coming from
the gatsby
then after that i'm going to go with my
import and then recipes
list from and in this case i'm looking
in the components and then recipes list
and then let's just scroll down and set
up our query i'm going to say export
const and then query and that is equal
to my graphql
and then of course we set up the
template strings and now i want to pass
in the query
so in here i have a bunch of things open
so let me just grab this one and again
let me stress something the only reason
why i use this tag is because that's the
value that i set up in my gatsby node if
you set up a different name of course
use that name instead i'll copy and
paste
and then
if you take a look at the props you'll
notice that of course now we'll have
access to the data
and in that data we'll have that array
of recipes again let's save it
and let's go back to the food one
and if you inspect and if everything is
correct we have the object okay that's
the props like i said we have the page
context where we pass in the tag what's
more interesting
notice the data now
now of course i set up the query
i set up the page query again i have
access to the data property and what do
you know
i have nodes array
and that array has four items so what's
the only thing left to do well we just
need to go back to our tag template
and again in my case i'm going to use
the structuring
i'm going to say i want to access the
data and in order to set up proper
syntax i need to wrap it in the
parentheses so that's my property i will
grab my recipes by drilling down so i'm
going to say data and then again i need
to use this guy all contentful recipe
that's the property and then more
specifically i'm looking for the nodes
and i just need to pass in this recipes
variable with its value into the recipes
list so as far as the return
again i'm going to go with layout and
again i forgot to import that one so
let's go here with a layout
layout from
and we're looking for the components and
then the layout one i'll wrap my whole
return in the layout
and then inside of this layout let's go
with a main tags again
with a class of page
and then instead of the main we're going
to set up a heading 2 and for time being
i'll just hard code that and i'll say
tag
name
and then right after this one we're
going to go with div with the class of
tag
recipes and this is of course where we
go with our recipes list and we provide
those recipes so in some cases it's just
going to be an array with one item and
in some cases like in our example with
the food we're gonna have more recipes
available so we save here
we navigate back to our project we
refresh
and in this case it is complaining
that there's some kind of bug so it
tells me that the recipe is not defined
and yep of course i made a small typo
it's not a recipe it is recipes and then
once we refresh we have our tag name
something we'll work on in a second and
notice these are all the recipes that
have that specific tag so if i go back
to all my recipes i have beef blah blah
blah and if i go with lunch this is
going to get me these two recipes now
how we can get this one dynamic well if
you remember it was in one of our props
and more specifically page context prop
and again behind the scenes gatsby is
using it to pass it into this query
but in our case since i want to showcase
that specific value i can simply go with
comma then page
context and then where i have the
heading 2 instead of the generic tag
name i'm going to go with page context
that's my object and i'll just access
the tag and now of course this value
will be dynamic and that concludes
another way how we can set up pages
programmatically ian gatsby and that is
by using gatsbynode.js
nice at this point we're familiar with
two ways how we can set up pages
programmatically in gatsby but before we
continue let me fix two possible bugs
with our current setup
and in order to demonstrate that i'm
gonna go back to contentful and i'll
show you that i created a testing recipe
and as far as the values they're very
similar to our previous recipes now the
gotcha here is e in the json object
if you take a look of course i have tags
array but as far as the value for my
first tag it's exactly the same as my
recipe name
and then also for the second tag i use
two words instead of one and once i
restart the server and i pull in the
latest data
i get two following bugs first if i try
to navigate to a testing recipe page
unfortunately i'm not able to i only
navigate to a testing
tags page
and second if i take a look at my
tag where i use two words now if i go
here
i can see that the url is following
and that's definitely not what i want
and also once we restart the server we
can actually see this bug because notice
gatsby is warning us it says attempting
to create a page testing but the page
testing already exists
and finally if you definitely want to
see
what is happening simply navigate to the
page that doesn't exist and notice we
have one page for the testing one and
this is in the tags and then if i keep
on scrolling i have one for testing in
the recipes as well
now as far as the effects we simply need
to go back to our gatsby node so let me
close my terminal here
and then i want to change the url
where instead of setting up as forward
slash tag remember i said we are in
charge here so i can simply go with
forward slash and then tags and then the
tag value now since i have now a tag
with a two words now of course i also
need to implement that sluggify remember
when we were setting up the recipes list
we implemented sluggify now we need to
do the same thing in three places or
maybe more correctly in four places we
need to do that in gatsby node we need
to do that in a tags list tags page and
also for the single recipe because there
we also have the tags now gatsby note is
in the note land
so in here we need to go with sluggify
and we need to use a require syntax
so i go here with logify then i'm going
to scroll down and then instead of
setting up the tag i'm going to go with
const and i'll call this
slug or tag slug whatever and this is
going to be equal to a sluggify i'll
pass in the tag i'll pass in the options
object and we'll say lower is equal to
true and now instead of this tag i'm
going to go with tag
and then of course we're going to call
this slug so tags slug okay
let's save it now cadbury is going to
help me and restart the server or at
least the browser or no it's actually
restarting the server so let's see
whether that works and now of course i'm
going to close the terminal and then
like i said we need to do that in three
places first i'm going to go to the tags
list now in this case we're back in the
react land so we simply go with sluggify
from
and of course the package name is
sluggify then scroll down and this is
going to be the case where i want to
speed it up a little bit and i'll just
copy and paste
so in the tags list i'm not going to
call this tag slug anymore i'm just
going to go with slug
simply
and then instead of going forward slash
and then the text of course now i want
to pass in the text into the sluggify
and then forward slash
tags
and then the actual tag
and like i said we need to do that in
the tags page as well
as well as the recipe page the single
recipe page because that's where we also
have
those slugs meaning tags set up as links
so let me save in the tags list and
again in order to speed this up
i'm just going to copy and paste and
i'll start with a tags one
so copy and paste
and notice again i have the sluggify i
just need to import
so let's grab this logify here
and then let's keep on scrolling again
the url is going to be the tags
and then slug and lastly let me do the
same thing in contentful recipe page as
well so first let's start by importing
the slug
and up at the top i'm going to get my
slug then let's keep on scrolling and
then notice i have those tags so now of
course i just need to set them up first
so let me go back here we might need to
change something around because now of
course i'm getting a string value
with a parameter of tag so instead of
text i'm going to go back to the tag
this will be my slug and i'm going to go
with my tags page
and then of course i'm looking for
my slug
so once you save we should fix both bugs
now let me go back to my home page
and of course once i navigate to the
testing one and clearly see
that i have a recipes page for testing
not a tags page and now if i click on
this nice rice check out the url
everything worked i have nice hyphen and
rice
and of course we can double check this
by navigating to a page
that doesn't exist so let's say here
some kind of error page and i'll see
that
all my tags
are under the url of tags forward slash
and then whatever is the tag value and i
nicely set up my own slug
and then if i take a look at the recipes
ones of course i still have the one we
the testing so that's how we can fix the
possible issue of the duplicating values
when it comes to tags as well as the
recipe name
nice at this point we're actually done
with our project
but before we deploy our project to
netify so set up hosting i want to add
some small but necessary features to it
and let's start by pre-loading our fonts
you see our current setup works great
especially in local development but if
our user has a slow network connection
he or she might experience some issues
why simply because we fetch our fonts
after our project loads what's the
solution of course another plugin and
just to make my case if i navigate to
our local project
and then inspect
more specifically network and if i look
for css we can clearly see that we're
getting our fonts once our project loads
and once we're done setting up our
plugin
effectively we will pre-load the fonts
and let me start by navigating back to
our project i'm looking in the assets
i'm looking for css and then i'll scroll
up all the way up up up up up up up so
let me see
it's not what i wanted there it is
and i want to remove my import like so
or you can comment it out that is also
an option
so let's save that one of course now i
won't have my fonts
and by the way i'll probably need to
restart
here so let me stop my server
npm start
and probably i should have cleaned the
cache as well so let me run gatsby clean
and i'm going to go with gatsby develop
and then while the project is loading
i'm going to navigate to gatsby docs and
then we're looking for the plugins
and more specifically we're looking for
the plugin by the name of web fonts now
if you'll type fonts in search you'll
see that you have many many plugins
available and you can pick any of these
plugins but let me just warn you that
for some weird reason
font plugins constantly get depreciated
i have no idea why just be aware it when
you make your decision
and actually the same goes for the
plugin i'm about to show you so the
plugin we're about to install
since you're going to be watching this
video in the future at that point plugin
might be out of date now i'm not saying
that it will but i'm just saying it
might be the case since again for some
weird reason font plugins constantly get
depreciated now if that is the case just
simply look for a different font plugin
the good news setup for all of them is
almost the same so switching to a
different plugin should not be a clause
for
too many headaches so i'll remove my
fonts and i'm gonna go with web
fonts instead
that's the plugin i'm going to use as
far as the setup
we just need to use this command
and as i said let's just check
yep notice we don't have the fonts
anymore so we need to prefetch them
instead
and at this point i'm going to stop my
server
we'll install the plugin
so let me see where's my terminal there
it is
install the plugin awesome
and then the setup for all of them is
pretty much the same
where you'll have to set them up as
objects and then of course the value for
resolve property is going to be equal to
the name of the plugin and then whatever
options you want to set up meaning
whatever fonts you want to use now for
this particular plugin if you just want
to use the google fonts setup is
actually easier where again you have
resolve and then within the options we
go with fonts google and then of course
we have the family as well as the
variance so in my case i'm gonna grab
this object i'm gonna navigate back
to my gatsby config
and then i'm gonna keep on scrolling
right after the contentful one
i'm gonna copy and paste my plugin web
fonts
and then i just need to change these
values around in the main css you can
see which ones i'm using
so i'll start with the first one
and i'll just copy and paste so instead
of roboto i'm getting this one and as
far as the variance i'm just gonna go
with 400 in this case
and then the second one
this is where i'll get
more variants
so second front family
and then i'm gonna go with 400 500 600
and 700.
so let me do that 400
500
and 600
okay let's add a comma
and one more time just to be on the safe
side i'm gonna go with gatsby clean even
though i already ran a second ago i'm
gonna go with cats be clean and then
gatsby develop
beautiful and once the server is up and
running you can just go to localhost
8000 once you refresh notice we're not
fetching the fonts when our project
loads but i can clearly see that i have
my fonts because if i double check with
my complete project the fonts are
exactly the same now if you want to see
where are we getting the fonts
if you take a look at the head element
you can see that we have some link
elements with a rel attribute set to
preload
which just ensures that our assets in
this case fonts are available earlier
and as a result improve our project
performance
awesome we're done with our fonts now
let's work on our contact form
and when it comes to form submissions in
gatsby since we ship our project as
static assets so there's no back and
forth between the server and the user
effectively we have two options first we
build our own server
or second we offload this task to a
third-party service and since building
our own server is definitely not an
option since of course this is a gatsby
tutorial i will show you my favorite
service for handling forms in gatsby
keep in mind you have plenty of options
to choose from just utilize the search
engine and you'll be in good shape and
the service i like the most is called
form spree and mainly i like it because
it has generous free tier and the setup
is extremely extremely
straightforward so navigate to formspree
dot io so again the url is formspree
dot io
and then i'm gonna click on get started
even though i have the account
and i'm going to go with my dummy one
i believe it was let me just double
check learn code mail.com learn code at
mail.com as far as the password
let me pass in my uncrackable password
here
and then no i don't want to get the news
let's register
and once we do that
they are asking us to verify the email
okay good
not a robot that's awesome
and what's also really cool that you can
actually use the service in local
development so you can test it right
away and once you verify the email
address then look for the new project
in my case i'm going to call this gatsby
tutorial
i'm going to create the project then i
want to set up the form
and notice here we have form name and
i'm going to call this
recipes form recipes
form okay good let's create that form
and once we do that notice the easy
setup
so that's the url we're going to use and
if we keep on scrolling
as far as the simple html setup it's
following where we have the action
attribute and then we just pass in the
url and that's the same url so you can
simply just copy and paste and of course
we need to add a method
of post so let's try this one out
i'm going to copy these two values then
of course i want to navigate back to my
contact form
so let me look
for my pages
and then inside of the pages of course i
have my form now i'm not using the link
so i might as well
remove it
here okay good let's keep on scrolling
keep on scrolling that's the form and
now we just need to add these two
attributes and once we have the setup in
place
you know what just to stay on a safe
side
i'm gonna go with npm start one more
time and once the server is up and
running i'll try to submit the form so
i'm going to navigate to the contact
page again that's the local project that
i'm working
and i'm just going to go with my name
with some kind of
dummy email
and as far as the message i'm just going
to say hello there now let's see the
server
is up and running
that's good news so now let's try to
step into form so i click here
and check it out now of course i can see
that the form was submitted awesome and
if i go back of course i'm directed back
to my project and effectively two things
just happened
first i got the email
from the service from the form spree and
also i can check in submissions and i'll
see that i have one submission where i
have the message name
as well as email so basically whatever
you set up with that name attribute will
show up in those submissions so for
example for me it was name message and
email and of course i can see those
values e in the submissions now if i
navigate back to my email i can also see
that i just got a form submission
and of course there are paid options you
can do more integrations you can do tons
and tons of things i'm just showing you
the basic one but as far as get up and
running with form submissions in my
opinion formspree is a pretty solid
option okay and let's also see how we
can change default favicon
and if you're not familiar with favicon
it's an icon in the browser tab so this
thing over here
gatsby does provide a default icon and
it is located
in the static folder
so we simply need to get our own icon
and just replace it and while there are
tons of resources for the favicons the
one that i enjoy the most is this one
and the url is favicon
io
then i usually go with the text option
and i'll close the ad then let's keep on
scrolling and we can change the font
color we can change the background color
as well as we can set up the text so in
my case i'm gonna go with letter r
and i'll leave the font color white and
i'll just change it to my background so
again in the main css
i'll have my primary color
this one over here
then of course i just need to navigate
back and then copy and paste
hopefully it is going to work and now i
simply just need to download
and then once the download is complete
you can probably already guess
that we'll simply just swap them out and
of course this is my download now
i'll pop it open
and more specifically i'm looking for
that favicon ico notice they provide
multiple options
but we just need this one so now i need
to go to my tutorial
where i have the static folder i simply
can drag and drop and i'll say replace
and then you might need to restart the
server or even clean out the cache so
let me just first try by refreshing and
actually it works even without doing
those things so of course now i have a
new favicon again the steps are
following just get the favicon and
replace the one that you currently have
e in a static directory beautiful and
now let's set up a search engine
optimization component or seo for short
where basically we'll set up a metadata
for our project and it's very useful if
we want to increase the visibility of
our site for relevant searches keep in
mind two things first since it's not a
seo course we'll just scratch the
surface and second we'll start nice and
easy with just bare bones setup and in a
later course project we are going to
take a look how we can set up a more
complicated component faster by
utilizing the gatsby dogs for starters
the main idea is following
where if i take a look at my source
of course i'll see that i have html tags
that's what the gas b returns and then
of course we also have the head element
and then instead of the helmet notice
these meta tags so that's a metadata
about our project so here we can control
things like title description and that
sort of thing
now the thing is it's not like i can
hack into it myself manually
because keep in mind in our project
we're just working with components
correct so this is my home page and
effectively this is my component
now once gatsby is done performing its
magic
then of course i get back this html and
the way around it is by installing
another plugin
and in this case we're looking for
gatsby plugin react helmet
so you can either search for seo or just
search for helmet and believe me with
1.6 downloads you'll definitely be able
to find the plugin
and then as far as the dependencies we
need to install gatsby plug-in react
helmet as well as the react helmet so
under the hood this plug-in uses react
helmet which pretty much is a standard
these days when it comes to react
applications and setting up the metadata
and let's just grab those commands
and of course i'll navigate back i want
to stop my server and once i clear
everything copy and paste okay
that seems to work
now i also want to add this string
of course
in my gatsby config
okay let's keep on scrolling let's keep
on scrolling and then somewhere all the
way in the bottom
but still within the array i want to
install
my helmet one then let's start up our
server
and i want to go to my components and
create a new one and i'm going to go
with the name of seo and then once we
create this component
then i want to start by setting up the
react component
and then i also want to right away set
up my imports
and we'll be looking for the helmet from
react helmet so that's the package and
also i want to right away get the use
static query and the graphql because we
will utilize the query here as well so
let's start with our helmet one and this
is a named import so we go here with
helmet
and then this is coming from of course
the react helmet package
and then once we have this imported like
i said we're gonna go with use static
query
and i also want a graphql tag template
from and it's coming from the gatsby
as far as the component instead of
returning div
i want to return a helmet component
so we're going to go here with helmet
component and then this is where we set
up the meta information
for example if i want to change the
title of my page because at the moment i
have localhost 8000 i just need to pass
in a
title prop and i need to set it equal to
some kind of value now we will make this
dynamic in next video for time being i'm
just going to go with title is equal to
home
so that is going to be my title
element e in the head element
and then the value will be home and like
i said we are returning a helmet
component from our seo component let's
save it and now of course i want to take
it out for test drive so i'm just going
to navigate to index.js
then we go with import we're looking for
seo component it is coming from of
course our components and then at the
very top i'm just going to go with seo
component for time being we're not
passing anything in
we just save it and then the moment we
do that well complains that cannot get
it from the components because of course
i didn't specifically say which one i'm
looking for my apologies
once we save we should see the title
with a name of them and of course once i
do notice now in my tab you can clearly
see that the title of my page is home
so that's the basic setup for this
plugin
where effectively we need to import a
helmet component that is coming from
react helmet
then we'll need to set up props on that
component and return from this component
and then of course whatever meta
information will set it up will be added
to our page and if you're interested in
even more info
just navigate to the bigger browser
window
and let me refresh
just so
everything is up to date and then take a
look at the elements
if i open up the head element
notice now here all the way in the
bottom
i do have my title tags so i have my
title element and of course the value e
is home so everything works whatever
i'll set up on the helmet component
it will be added to
my head element and in turn i'm going to
be setting up meta information about my
project all right so this works pretty
great we can have title we can have it
also e in the browser tab but of course
the issue is that if i wanna reuse this
component at the moment i'm hard coding
this value
and we already know what we can do in
order to solve this problem because of
course at the end of the day we have the
component we have the react component so
we can right away set up two props
and i'm gonna go with title prop as well
as the description prop so these are the
two things that will pass in description
and then in order to test it out of
course i'll have to set up a description
meta tag as well now this one is a bit
more complex because we need to have
property and there in most cases they
set it up as an array so don't worry
we'll get there let's just start by
testing out the title so this is the
first prop that i'm going to be looking
for title prop and then instead of hard
coding this home i want to go with title
and what this allows me to do
is to reuse this component so i take my
seo component and now of course since
i'm looking for the title prop
i can render it in about page and then
pass the about page value e instead of
hard coded home correct so first let's
go back to the index just so we can test
it out and of course we have now tile
prop and as far as the value
let's just write home
and page and of course the moment i save
it check it out of course now our title
is different all right so let's write
the same thing in the about page so let
me select this one again in order to
speed this up i'm just going to copy and
paste
and then i'm looking for
the return and of course like i said
we're gonna go with seo and then as far
as this title we'll just say about and
once i say i do have a tiny bug because
i do need to close it out and then the
moment i save everything seems to be
working fine i just need to go to the
bigger browser window and then once i
navigate to about page again
everything is working i have my title
and of course the value is above
because that's what i passed in the prop
and the same thing i can see in my
source code awesome so now let's see how
we can pass in that description and like
i already previously mentioned as far as
description it is a bit more complex
because we are setting up meta tags
and usually you set up quite a few of
them
so the syntax what they're looking for
here is following so we go here with
meta and then we'll set it up of course
with curly's
and then we'll be looking for array and
then it's going to be an array of
objects and now for this meta
description tag we simply need to say
name so this is going to be the name of
our meta tag
then we need to go with template strings
and then we just type description so
that's going to be the name of our meta
tag and as far as the content
let's just set it up equal to our
description to the prop that we're
passing in
but in the next video i'll show you how
we can actually
use our gatsby config
and more specifically remember when
we're setting up the site metadata well
now set up a query to pull in that data
and first i want to add the comma just
keep in mind we're still working in the
same object
and we're going to go with content again
that's the property name that we're
looking for and then we pass in our
description
now i'll save
and i simply need to go
back to my index.js and i'm just going
to write some gibberish i'm going to say
here description
and we're going to go with this is home
page because in the next video we'll use
our site's description and then i'm
going to go back to about.js and in this
case i'm looking for seo component of
course
and i just want to copy and paste now i
do want to change the value around and
i'll say about page
and again the reason why we're just hard
coding this gibberish is because in the
next video i'll show you how we can pass
in the site description so now i just
want to navigate back i want to refresh
and then if we take a look at the header
element
and if we keep on scrolling keep on
scrolling notice here we have meta so
the name is description and then as far
as the content of course in the about
page i'm going to have
this is about page now if i'll take a
look at the home page where this value
will be different now of course
i will have a
this is a homepage all right and lastly
in this video i just want to showcase
how we can set up a language for our
project now this one will be a bit
different
because this one we're adding on the
html tag
and the way it works in the seo
component on a helmet we need to go with
html attributes and then we'll have to
set up an object
and they're looking for the property of
a language so they have a language
property and you just want to set it
equal to whatever language you want so
in my case i'm gonna go with english
i will save and again once i go back to
my project notice the html element now
of course i have the language and that
is set equal to an english so that's how
we can add
more
tags to our head element by using our
plugin
beautiful i think we're in good shape
but what's missing
is our site information
if you remember in the gatsby config
more specifically in site metadata we
already have
info about our site
so why don't we try this why don't we
pull in this data
in the seo component
and then utilize it
and we'll have to start by setting up
our query
and i simply want to go with my explorer
i'm going to go with site
i'm looking for my site metadata that's
not a surprise and i'm going to go with
my title
and description
now i will run my query
and of course i can see that i'm getting
back my simple recipes as well as my
description i just want to grab
everything and i'm going to go with code
exporter in this case and now of course
i just want to take everything apart
from export
i'll navigate back to my seo component
copy and paste and then set up the
component
i want to access that data and i know
that i'm going to be getting back my
object and inside of it i have the site
so right away the structure and i'm
going to go with use static query and
i'll pass in query and once i save
there seems to be a cache bug
so let me try this
let me try clearing out the cache
and once i run gatsby clean
and restart the server
everything is working as expected so now
of course we're pulling
our site's information
and in here i'll use it in two places
first i'll set up a vertical bar
for my title for my page title and what
i'm trying to do here is
having a title with home and then
vertical bar and then whatever is the
project name and if you're interested
how it's going to look like take a look
at the complete project notice here we
have home and vertical bar and then of
course we have our sites title that's
the first thing that i want to do and i
simply need to change this value here
where it's not going to be just title
i'm going to go with template string
then i'll access the value and i'm going
to go title then like i said we're going
to go with our vertical bar
and then
right next to the vertical bar we'll
place our site's title now where's the
site titled setting of course it is
sitting in sight set metadata and title
now in my case i'm not going to
destructure it i think i'm just going to
drill down to the property so let's go
with site
site
meta
and then data and of course finally i
want to access the title property and
again once we save once we refresh we
should
see these simple recipes and finally
after struggling with it a bit now of
course i can see my homepage and also i
have the site title now i think in the
index.js i will remove this homepage i
think that's better and as far as
description i want to make it more
flexible
where if i pass in the value for the
prop then of course
i'll set it up as my value for my meta
tag however if i don't pass it in then
i'll use our site description and the
way we do that we go to the meta and
then take a look at the content of
course at the moment i'm looking for my
description however above the return i
can just set up a new variable and i'll
call this meta
description and this one will be equal
to the description and i'll use the or
operator so if the description is passed
then of course we'll use it if not
then we'll default to
site description
again we go with site site metadata and
then description
again the only gotcha here is this or
operator
i say get me a description if
description is undefined so if it's not
passed then use site description and of
course i need to change it in my meta
prop as well so i'm gonna go with meta
description and in order to test it out
i'm gonna go back to index.js i will
remove it and i'll do the same thing in
about
so this is going to be my about page i
pass in the title
but i will remove
my description let me save it
and in order to test it out i'm going to
go to my bigger browser i can see that
title is correct and if i take a look at
my head element
somewhere there should be
meta tag with a name of description and
notice the value now of course i have
nice and clean recipes so if i were to
go back
and actually add this description for my
page so if i'll say this is
about and then page then of course if we
navigate back and again we just need to
refresh and navigate to that about page
of course you will be able to see
that
the content is different and hopefully
you see how it works
if we pass in description awesome then
of course we'll use it if not then we'll
always default back to site description
and now of course i just want to set it
up in all our pages again a little bit
of copying pasting but i'm not going to
pass in description i'll always default
back to a site's description and we
simply want to start by setting up our
seo component in 404 that's going to be
our error and again we simply want to
set it up in return so we go with seo
and as far as the title i'm just going
to say error
and then i'm not going to test it out
right now i want to add it to all the
pages and then we'll test all of them
together that was my 404 then of course
we also have the contact copy and paste
we need to set up our seo component and
we just need to set up our title so this
will be a contact
and then of course
we're going to close the seo component
then i'm looking for the recipes again
we import seo component
and then we go with seo then title will
be equal to
recipes again close out our component
and then lastly we have the tags
where again inside of the layout i want
to go with seo component and then title
and of course the value
will be
tags let's save this one and now of
course we have two dynamic pages we have
contentful recipe and also a tag
template so let's start with contentful
recipe
we'll get our seo component again as far
as return we just go inside of the
layout but as far as the values now of
course this is dynamic
so we're getting the title and
description for every recipe that we
have
because remember we are creating this
page dynamically so here we simply go
with title is equal to our title
property whatever we're getting back
from data dot contentful recipe and the
same thing will be with description so
we're going to go with description
and we'll just pass in that description
and of course we want to do the same
thing in our tag template we navigate
there copy and paste the seo component
inside of the layout we're going to go
with our title and as far as the value
remember if we want to access that
specific tag we need to go with page
context and then
dot tag so here we go with title and
that one will be equal to our page
context and then we're looking for the
tag again i'll close my component and
now of course let's go and test it out
on a bigger browser window i'm first
going to go to about page i can see that
everything works i have my about and of
course i have simply recipes then tags
then recipes
back to home
then contact and then eventually i also
want to test out my error page so just
type some gibberish and we'll take a
look at the error page and it looks like
everything is working great
and then let's take a look at our
programmatic pages so in here i have my
banana package and i can clearly see
that everything works as far as the
title okay and then if i take a look
at my description
that also showed returns a value and of
course i can clearly see that i have my
meta with my value that is coming from
the contentful and lastly let's just
take a look at the tags so now in this
case i want to go to home and then take
a look at one of the tags and once we
navigate there you can clearly see that
in the tab
i have the correct value this is for the
ribs and we're successfully done setting
up our seo component beautiful at this
point our recipes project is complete
and now we just want to host our project
online so everyone can see our awesome
work when it comes to hosting you have
plenty of options to choose from since
at the end of the day our project just
contains cluster of static files and for
the most part we have two options we can
build project locally with the help of
gatsby build or use the continuous
deployment where we utilize git and of
course in the following videos i'll
cover both options i prefer hosting
provider called metalfi and i like it
because the setup is extremely
straightforward and they do offer
generous free tier but of course like i
said it's just one of the options out
there
now in order to create an account if you
don't have one already navigate to
netflix.com again the url is netlify.com
and just follow the signup link and once
you create the account just log in this
is going to be your dashboard and at
this point we have two options
we can do the drag and drop
where basically we will build our
project locally
and then the second option is the
continuous deployment where we'll push
our project up to the github
and then from there netfly will build
our site for us so let's start with the
simpler option first which is the drag
and drop and then next video we will
take a look at the continuous deployment
and in order to set up the drag and drop
you simply need to go to this site
here and then keep scrolling keep
scrolling and here all the way in the
bottom you have this window so i'll make
this smaller and maybe not this small
but i'll set it here
and what i want right now is to go back
to my project
stop everything
and then clear my terminal
then first i want to run gets be clean
i just always prefer
running this first and then we want to
run the gatsby build now keep in mind
something extremely important your local
gatsby build will fail
if
you don't have this env production or if
the values here are incorrect
that's just the way it is that's why for
development we have one
and then for the production we have
another one so make sure that if you
do get some errors to first check what
is happening with enemy production and
here we simply need to run gatsby and
then build and now of course gatsby will
build the production ready site for us
and once the gatsby is done
we can go to our folder
and then of course we have the public
one and this is where our production
ready project is setting so at this
point we simply need to take this public
folder
and just drag and drop
again the setup is going to be pretty
fast once you're done with gatsby build
because middle file doesn't really need
to do anything of course now we are in
good shape
and before we check out the site let me
just change the site name
so click on the site settings and then
more specifically site name now if the
name is already taken of course you
won't be able to use it
and therefore i'm going to go temp
gatsby tutorial hopefully
that name is not taken so gatsby
tutorial
and notice how they will add this notify
that app so eventually yes of course you
can set up the custom domain that is
definitely an option
but for time being of course we're not
going to do that
and once i'm done changing the name
i want to navigate to the url and this
is my site and notice how it is live
because of course i have my netlify.app
good so let's see we have recipes we
have tags
everything seems to be working i can
click on a recipe this is going to get
me the individual recipe
beautiful
contact page yep
still everything is in place and now
let's test out that error like i said
you always want to test out those arrow
pages actually in production and just
like that we're done with the drag and
drop option and our site is live all
right and next i want to showcase how we
can use the other option the continuous
deployment where basically we set up a
github repo
and then
netfly does the building for us
so it is smart enough to check if there
are any changes in our repo and the
moment we push up some changes then
notify restarts the build process since
this is somewhat of a advanced course
i'm not gonna go over the basic git
commands as well as how to set up a
github repo
if you need to brush up on that please
utilize the search engine so i'm staring
at my github dashboard and i want to
create a new repo
and since i'll remove it once i'm done
with this video i'm going to go with
temp gatsby
and then tutorial okay awesome
and i'm gonna go with public one i'll
create the repo
and i right away wanna copy and paste
these three commands because i wanna
point the url to the repo and i guess
let's start by navigating back i'll
clear my terminal
and i want to set this up as a git of
repo
so just in case it is already a github
repo i'm just going to go with rm and rf
and git
i remove the github repo and then i'll
create a new one get in it
then i'll add all the files and again
just make sure
that you have a git ignore
and that you're ignoring the env
variables
otherwise everyone will be able to see
your secret api keys and i'm just going
to go with git commit
and i'll just say first
commit
and then i'll copy and paste those three
commands so now i have the url pointing
to my repo
and then from there i simply need to go
back to my repo refresh
and of course this is my project
and once i have my repo in place
now of course i want to navigate back to
the netify
and i'll create a new site however now
is the other option new site from git
and as a provider i'll pick my github
and then more specifically i need to
look for my temp one so let's say i have
temp
and then once i find my repo so temp
gatsby tutorial
then we simply need to set everything up
and as you can see i have the owner i
have the main branch okay that is
correct and then notice how right away
netify sets up the command the build
command so this is what i said nutella
file will build the site for us and then
as far as the publish directory it is
public so make sure that these match now
in most cases nettle fire is smart
enough to get the correct commands but
if you do experience some bugs make sure
that the commands match exactly that
because this is where our gatsby project
will eventually sit
and also in our case since our project
is more complex we want to add this env
variable because we need to keep in mind
that since
network is doing the build process
of course
it also needs to know well what is the
value here correct
otherwise everywhere where we use that
can be variable nut fly is going to be
like hey listen you want me to provide
some kind of value here but i have no
access to it and therefore we're gonna
go with show advanced and in a second
i'll show you where we can do that in
the dashboard as well just in case you
ever forget so here we go with new
variable and now you want to go back to
your env file
take the contentful part and then do the
same thing with the value so select
everything and then copy and paste
and then of course we just need to go
with deploy site now i can tell you
right away that the process takes longer
therefore i'm going to go back to my
dashboard
and i'll simply remove this site so in
the process i can show you how you can
do that so go here to the site settings
again keep scrolling keep scrolling and
notice we have this option of delete the
site
so i'm going to copy and paste
we delete the site then i'll add the
same name for this guy
notice we're still building
and again we do that in the site
settings
change site name
and then i'm gonna go with the same one
so i'm gonna go with temp gatsby
tutorial
we save it that's awesome
and then as far as the build process if
you want to take a look what's happening
or if you want to check errors
if you do get some
then go with deploys
and then notice this is our current
build
so in here you'll be able to see what is
happening as far as the build process
now if you ever want to change those env
variables
if you want to add a new one or maybe
change it then again you're looking for
domain settings
and more specifically you keep on
scrolling or no sorry you're looking for
build and deploy
and then of course we have the build
command we have publish directory so
this is also a place where you can
change that keep scrolling keep
scrolling then we have hooks which we're
going to cover in a second
and then of course we also have the
environment variables so notice if you
ever want to add a new one or edit the
existing one again look for this window
and then more specifically for the edit
variables option so let me navigate back
and i'll take a look at deploys
now the netfly is still building like i
said this will take longer because now
netlify is doing all of the work
and it looks like everything is nice
because my site is live and again if you
ever
need to check for the errors or what's
happening just navigate here and you'll
be able to see what's happening with
your project so i'm going to go back to
my project and again everything works
pretty nice now why do you want to use
this option why do you want to go with
continuous deployment even though it
looks like there are more steps involved
simply because
at the moment i'll push
a new change up to my repo natalify will
rebuild my site for me so i'm not gonna
have to do this manually
and as always the most
basic and drastic probably way is simply
adding some kind of background color so
let me scroll down
and where it is where it is body
and then instead of the background
of whatever i have as a css variable
i'm just going to go with red now i
don't think i'm going to run it locally
but i'll right away push it up and i'll
say
testing testing background
and red let's see okay i want to push
this up and as i said i'm using the
visual studio gui for this notice we
just need to add a message then i click
on commit and then in order to push it i
go with a push option
and now of course i just need to double
check that
in my repo
so let's navigate here let's refresh
notice i have testing background red so
that's good and then what's even nicer
that if you navigate back to your
project you'll notice that there's
another
build process started by the nutella
file so again netflix smart enough it
has hooks right now in the repo so now
every time we push some kind of change
metalfire will rebuild the site for us
and at this point i'm not going to wait
till the build process is complete since
that seems like a waste of your time and
once everything is done i'm just going
to showcase that of course the
background color for our project is
going to be red and once notify is done
building
my latest project
of course i can just double check
and i can see that everything went fine
and
we of course can check out our full
project as a very very quick side note
if
one of the build processes is going to
fail then of course it's just going to
revert back to the old one so for
example
if this for some weird reason would have
failed
then we would still be using the
original one something to keep in mind
and let's just test this one out
and of course now my background is red
so hopefully you can clearly see the
benefits of using the continuous
deployment all right and as a last thing
in our first project i just want to
showcase how we can utilize the web box
now before we do anything web hook
related let me just remove this
background color because it really
annoys me
so let me go back to my background color
again
i'll make another commit in this case
i'll say
back to default
and then we push this up like i said i'm
using the gui and i'm just going gonna
go with push and as far as the web hooks
the idea is following where
if i go to my contentful right now
and if i log in and
for example add a product
with our current setup
either we need to go
manually to netfly
and
restart another build here you can clear
the cache and
trigger another deploy or we need to add
some kind of change to our project and
then push it up to the github because we
know that
the deploy process will be triggered
that way as well however there is a
better option
we can actually connect it to
where we set up something called
webhooks and the main idea behind the
webhooks is that we send a post request
now in netfly
we need to go to our site again we're
looking for
domain settings
more specifically build and deploy keep
on scrolling keep on scrolling and
notice we have this build hooks now we
add build hook here and we just need to
come up with a name here i could say
contentful
contentful recipes
we save it
and then we want to copy and paste this
value
so we copy this one so this is going to
be the url
where
netfly wants us to send a post request
and then if we go to contentful and more
specifically settings and then the
webhooks we can simply add that value i
want to add a webhook
now
for the name here of course we're
dealing with contentful now some names
don't need to match is just something
that makes sense to the contentful and
then we copy and paste the url this is
where we need to paste and here i'll say
network recipes just to showcase that
those names do not need to match so we
save it here and what's going to happen
every time i'll make some change to my
project again netlify will restart the
build for me and i think the easiest way
for me to showcase that is by removing a
item so i think i'm going to go with
this one i'll say on publish and notice
how we cannot directly delete it we
first need to unpublish
then click it one more time and then
delete it and i can right away see that
something is happening if i take a look
at my web hooks because i have right now
the successful calls
and if you click on it notice there were
some http requests okay
that's good and then if i go back to my
netify application
and more specifically again i'm looking
for deploys
notice i have another
deploy triggered
by the hook
now of course if you want to be more
specific
when you will send those post requests
then you need to do that when you're
setting up the webhook because notice by
default it is triggered for all events
but just keep in mind that in some cases
it might get annoying
where you have data for multiple
projects and then every time you change
one data then you're rebuilding all your
projects so we're not going to cover
that but
just keep in mind that you do have the
option of only triggering that
if there is a specific event and now of
course i want to go back and once the
build process is complete let me just
navigate to my project i can clear